e
e e
now from you're still thawing
out okay we're going to go ahead with
this hearing uh a number of people are
still coming out of meetings upstairs so
but we are scheduled for 9:30 we're
already 5 minutes late so I'd like to uh
go ahead and open up today's um uh
hearing for uh HB
366 uh this is a bill relative to school
building aid for eligible projects and
um I'd like to welcome represent kahill
here uh he has been a frequent flyer on
building Aid projects in past years so
welcome to our committee thank you very
much Mr chair and and I I do appreciate
you being my
wingman um it's an important issue I I
do wanted to ask you about the pledge
are we going to begin with the pledge
first or no we're going to go right
ahead with the meeting all right I'm
ready then okay so um as you've said uh
this has been a long-standing issue
I think it was problematic before the
moratorium before the Great Recession
but it has certainly gotten worse with
all that 10 years of not accepting
applications not uh meeting the need
that's out there in our traditional
public schools and so I I've uh what I'd
like to do and I know we I know uh
chairman lad agrees with me that we
should probably ask for a 100 million
but I don't think we get it uh so what
I'd like to do is is change the Min the
maximum 50 million per fiscal year to a
minimum of
60 and this would allow you know if we
if we do run into Good Times uh a future
legislature could add more perhaps 65
6750 uh whatever whatever they could uh
put toward this uh School building aid
program so that we might begin to chip
away at the estimated $200 million
backlog out there across our state uh
the other part that's uh of interest to
me is the uh the schools that really
were forced to act during the moratorium
I I know there was no promise to fund
actually the applications were not
accepted because there was no money and
they didn't want to use the resources
trying to uh evaluate the applications
when there was no money but
um and I know there was discussion about
putting your you know with with the
state Bond you know putting your visa on
your Discover card but it ended up on
the Discover Cards and Visa cards and
property tax bills in those communities
and I've included uh in in the documents
I've included the list of those people
that acted and there could be more this
is hasn't been updated these uh those
communities spent uh
537 milon
174,175
uh on their schools and the state had it
been uh contributing this the share
would have spent
186,000 million1 141,142
in our tool aged and uh insufficient
school buildings added
$3.15 to our already high property taxes
and as you know property taxes keep on
going up especially with the re
reassessment so it's it's a burden it's
it's a it's a burden and it's the state
should share in this we have a
constitutional obligation to provide an
adequate education that to me means an
adequate building a building without
Fire and Life Safety hazards a building
with sufficient space uh a building
which the doesn't have modular a school
doesn't have modular
classrooms and yet we're we're
installing more modulars I I read about
um down in Londoner where they tried
they couldn't pass the bond last time
last year so now they're offering a
scaled back plan uh where they're going
to use modulars which they think will
solve their problem for 15 years and
then then I guess they'll have to come
back because they have to they have to
get a cheap cheaper cheaper cheaper so
they can might be able to reach the 60%
threshold again because the state is not
a partner uh London there I note uh got
a u they're anticipating a uh sneaker
Factory part of this restoring
manufacturing and that sneaker Factory
got a $70 million Bond through the
BFA now public schools don't have that
option you know we're encouraging
business but we're not investing in and
encouraging our traditional Public
Schools um another piece of paper that
I've provided to you is the uh School
building Aid weight list as you know we
have a rank list now and there were 17
applicants and we funded three leaving
more now I I the number here at the
bottom I did calculate the enrollment
and what I'm seeing here on the page in
front of me is 8,028 students I thought
it was 7,000 but anyway there's a lot of
students even more than those using the
EFA that are waiting for the state to
step up and help fix their
schools uh if you have a if if one of
you one or one of you has a school in uh
on this list or that list you might want
to help to vote to pass this bill and
even if you don't you should because
it's the right thing um I sent you a
link to the
uh that's the other Bill anyway the the
point I'm trying to make is that we we
we need to invest in our
schools and in order to ensure that
people have an adequate education maybe
even better than adequate that should be
our goal but we need to do it and we
need to we can't keep on kicking the can
down the road further and
further thank you very much thank you
very much are there questions for
represent kill yes represent Maguire
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question as you know um School
building Aid is very chunky right
certain a handful of schools get it and
and the rest don't would you be
in how would you think about a system
that changed it so that um a uh whatever
the money is that's allocated that
particular year 50 million whatever the
number is was given as adequacy to all
districts that they could put in escrow
or use for repairs or whatever so that
they would all have a fund for building
schools uh that's an interesting
proposition um I I recall there was a
bill put forward from the other chamber
last year to allow it to provide a
certain amount of money every year to
all the schools and they would save up
and save up and save up which I I don't
think that was going to work uh we don't
we don't often save up for our homes or
our cars and and they don't cost quite
as much as a school building or or often
repairs uh let let me bring up another
another area of the reform that happened
in 2013 on sh the chairman lad remembers
we used to pay building Aid out in
conjunction with the local Bond it a
long range set 20 years 30 years
whatever but we paid along with that and
then it was a change made where we'd say
in order the save everybody some
interest we would pay 80% upfront and
20% upon completion that's a big chunk
of money in a short period of time and
that's part of why we can't approve more
than three schools in the bium because
we're laying out so much money for one
school maybe two and I think that's
that's something we need to examine
because it it contributes to this
problem go not enough money and too much
all at once
thank you further questions yes
representative luno thank you very much
Mr chair thank you very much
representative kale for uh for bringing
this forward I was I was wondering if we
could um if you could sort of step back
from this just uh just for a little bit
and I know how close you are to the to
you know uh building Aid proposals and
and bills that are that are brought
forward and if you could spend a minute
and give the committee maybe a highle
flyover of other bills um
that would relate to um to building Aid
and
appropriate you know similar amounts in
similar ways to what you've got proposed
here I'm just wondering what we've got
what we'll be seeing on the tape on the
proverbial table U this session well I I
know that right up after this we'll talk
about uh repealing the bill that would
the bill that allowed uh charter schools
to be eligible which I see as a further
drain on our very limited funds and I
think in another week or two we'll be
talking about my my other bill which
would be repeal the bill that gave
charter schools first refusal on
unoccupied school buildings which I
think removes the right of uh the people
in the community to decide what is best
for them and sort of it's kind of a
statist approach to just sort of you
will do this with that
building um uh so there's a long there's
a long history with with the building
started in the 40s that was before my
time and uh I know we have other bills
talking about uh 550 talking about
giving more money per student I don't
think that necessarily I don't think
that gets to building Aid and um but I I
guess to the I do have a follow question
just just a
clarification just um are there are
there any other bills that you're aware
of that have a similar uh framework to
this where where it's it's you know um
making a um an appropriation to the uh
to the building aid program whether it's
$50 million or $60 million okay I'm
going to interject on that question
because I want to explain to the
committee what we are going to do this
year we have a number of bills coming up
catastrophic Aid we have special
education Aid we have school Foundation
formula we have building Aid we will be
having work sessions in all these in
terms of what formula we have is there
another formula available that might
expedite or make it more
or be more palatable in terms of the
economics associated with it so the
question you're asking that I would say
yes we'll use one of these bills there
were a number of bills which weren't
submitted on building a simply because
we only needed one to open up Pandora's
Box and so um that's thank you Mr chair
that's exactly what I was getting at so
that so that we're we're looking at all
these bills as as a whole this thank are
there any further questions for
represent kahill yes represent papovich
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking the
question in your opinion does building
aate historically get spread around to
all towns or is it U you know tends to
be clustered in certain towns and if
that second scenario is the case do you
find that to be Equitable to everybody
in the state thank you for the question
as I I'm aware that it is difficult in a
town to get 60% of the vote to do
anything and I know that if you if the
town has fewer resources that the
building a program offers more a more
generous
portion uh up to
60% uh to make it to help enable those
poorer communities so I think that's a
good step that we has have historically
taken um and and I know that uh when
when the state was a reliable partner
and the money was available and we could
approve these projects schools were
getting done uh it's unfortunate that
for example uh my my friend um
representative cluder will might tell
you about the uh situation in Claremont
at the Stevens High School where it fell
one vote shy of that 60 60% majority and
that Pro that offering uh with building
a available uh was not approved and a
couple years later they came back
with a smaller smaller project and guess
what no money from the state so you have
you have to wonder sometimes whether or
not we're doing the best thing we can
and I I don't think we are and by the
way Windam is on that retroactive
further questions from the committee not
seeing any thank you very much thank you
sir i' like to invite uh represent
cluder welcome to Ed okay yes thank you
very much uh Mr chairman members of the
committee and I will be brief I have a
meeting at 10: so I can stay for just a
few minutes to testify and answer
questions for the record I'm state
representative John claer from Sullivan
County district 6 which comprises the
communities of of cin and Claremont uh
and I live in Claremont just to be clear
but I did want to Enlighten you as the
prime sponsor just touched on the issue
in Claremont dealing with Stevens High
School and I was around and this was in
I believe 2009 the chronology we needed
to renovate Steven High School our only
school public high school because uh we
otherwise the high school would lose its
accreditation it make it much harder for
our students graduating from the high
school there was a vote in March I
believe March of
2019 and it it won by I think one or two
votes but the people opposed to the bond
issue wanted a recount which is their
right and they had a recount and then
then the bond issue lost by one vote and
it just shows the the principle of every
vote counts including a bond
issue uh
then wait yeah okay let me the policy
and basically to please our voters and
try to get the
support we went the school board working
with the
superintendant had to change some
because uh some stuff to change in order
uh the proposal in order to get it
passed uh and especially to as at the
same time our legislature I was a member
of the house then uh along with then
Governor Lynch and we were undergoing
the Great Recession and as our duty as
members of the House of Representative
we have to have a balanced budget that's
law basically it's actually under house
rules but it has the force of law uh and
nobody could come up with additional
revenues and so it was cut across the
board and as a result building Aid was
cut out and our school district was
ineligible to get any building Aid we
had to proceed on a lower cost project
we had to cut some things I believe it
was in 2011 and we approved the project
we still had hope to get some State
Building Aid we did not the city of
entire the city of Cl had to basically
fund the entire renovation project on
its own I don't have figures but it
pushed our Pro and we the after two
years the high school opened up in
2013 I remember then Governor Hassen
coming to sort of do a grand opening but
she didn't bring any state aid
unfortunately uh so result this pushed
up our our property taxes and I remember
in 2014 during the election voters were
coming up to me and complaining why are
our property tax rates the highest at
the time in the state of New Hampshire
and I said it's simply because of
basically the bond issue a building Aid
to renovate the high school and although
today our propert property tax aren't
quite as low I believe they would still
be in the top 10 probably the vice chair
could enlighten me there's probably
other communities that have higher
property tax rates and for Claremont
because our property values are low
that's a real problem so I would urge
you to pass this bill it's not a perfect
bill as the prime sponsor just alluded
it's a compromise but if you could give
us some some money that we could use
to hopefully relieve property taxes for
our taxpayers they would appreciate
because I get this constantly from
taxpayers and anybody else who
represents Claremont and cyen gets the
same uh Kickback uh feedback and it's
been for you me I've been in my in my
17th term and that's been one of the
most top issues and top complaints the
state needs to do more to fund education
but also you know reduce property taxes
I want to thank you very much for
listening thank you very much are there
any questions for representative cluder
yes represent McGuire yes thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question part of adequacy is conditioned
on property tax value per student should
should building Aid be the
same uh I I'm not sure how to answer
that question maybe but I'm not on an
expert I'll admit I didn't bring any
technical figures but you know and I
come from Claremont we've been involved
in in lawsuits over school fund I'll be
right up front with you and it's still a
problem and I know how it will be solved
hopefully we as a legislature and a
state can come together on this within
the next couple years but and I'll admit
I'm open to anything uh as far as
funding uh but I want something done so
that we can protect property poor
communities like the ones I represent in
Sullivan County uh from from having to
pay such high property taxes to educate
our kids so they can compete with people
in other districts that are maybe have
higher property weals for the jobs of
the future it's it's we want to be sure
they're well equipped to compete for
these jobs and and uh have you know as I
said be become good citizens and
whatever you can do and I think this
bill that I'm a co-sponsor is a small
step forward I don't know I'm sorry if I
is said but I think something needs to
be done to help property poor
communities representative Damon do you
have hand
up yes thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative cluer as folks know we
overlap in our
representation I just wanted to
um hear you perhaps emphasize the early
statement you made that Claremont was in
Jeopardy of losing the high school
accreditation if the building project
was not done which would really curtail
student opportunity for higher education
graduating from an unaccredited
institution was that correct that yes I
me time it's a problem I I'm by the way
I'm a clont na a graduate of Stevens
High School class of 75 by the way that
was 50 years ago but re reaccreditation
I learned way back as a student is very
important if you want to go on to
college and get uh as I said it helps uh
graduates of that High School compete
for for college spots compete in the job
market so reaccreditation whether you
like it or not is is very important so
that's why our community felt they had
to renovate the high school and as I
said we we did one plan rejected by the
voters very narrowly we came back with
another plan that was approved by the
voters but we still didn't get any state
aid and our school board struggles and
works hard and they're going to have to
come in with a school budget that I
think they managed to keep it very low
this time preliminary reports so but it
is not easy to be a member of a school
board in clar mod is probably in a lot
of other communities in Sullivan County
I hope I answered your question includ
here Senor as co-sponsor in this well I
do have a question and I'd like to
address uh lines 8 through 14 within the
bill this is where we're paying back to
communities which have already gone
through the Hoops now my question is
if these communities which built during
the more atorium those 10
years did not have an application
submitted through the process and
approve a process to doe to meet certain
standards criteria that our Engineers
require didn't go through the school
building authority didn't go through the
State Board of
Education and now we're looking at
taking monies which are needed for new
construction and renovation
to backfill what has done do you support
this part of the bill versus the other
part which would more or less help uh
the communities which are on that list
of
17 well I I think this is as I
understand at 18 it's it's only five $5
million and it is a compromise we we
we're not asking for the entire amount
owed to us but we are asking for a
compromise to help us you can are as I
said I think I'm asking on behalf of
this of of Claremont The Claremont
School District for this as the prime
sponsor said it's a compromise and and
basically we need help in Claremont and
I'm and and a lot of other property poor
communities too so whatever you can do I
understand people's concerns but I I
really suggest that that this section at
this point be left in there okay with
all due respect uh to to you Mr chairman
but I feel that it's only as I read the
bill $5 million out of 60 million which
is very very small and so the prime
sponsor and I are asking that hopefully
you look at this bill and you pass it I
realize you may have to make some
technical corrections but pass it with
the principle of trying to help school
districts in the past and in good faith
you know put projects in and try to
apply for stated and the window is
slammed on them I mean maybe we had to
do that because of the Great Recession
we have to balance the budget and there
were no alter Revenue Alternatives that
were agreeable to everybody so I just
ask this for the sake of justice for for
my district and other districts who are
struggling thank you are there further
questions B and
Ames
question good morning good good morning
um you've mentioned several times uh
the truth that Claremont is a property
poor community and um have uh said
directly or indirectly that
um we should try to help property poor
communities as as I understand the uh
Aid building aid program is not uh
geared to steer money one way or another
depending on property wealth and I'm my
question to you is whether it
should I think with all due respect I
mean and I don't know whether it would I
think we should consider it I mean
either if we have to amend this bill or
another bill which I'd be happy probably
to at least sponsor I think as a matter
of fairness we ought to do this because
building Aid along with the rest of
Education uh I I think it's we we we
need to be fair and I don't want to
discuss as a general rule but building
Aid ought to be tied to a to a
community's property wealth in my
opinion off the top of my head further
questions not seeing any thank you very
much okay thank you very much Mr
chairman M members of the committee and
go to your
meeting uh representa
Weinstein thank you Mr chair and thank
you to the committee for hearing my
remarks I'll keep them brief U my name
is Tony Weinstein and I represent the
communities of New Market and
newfields I also want to extend my
sincere thanks to representative Cahill
for his commitment to this issue on
behalf of the students parents and
taxpayers of New Market and to people
across the granite state I got involved
locally on this issue about 14 years ago
New Market was again grappling with how
to manage our school facilities serious
life and safety deficiencies I was a
member of the PTA and I had two young
boys and therefore had a serious stake
in the future of our local
schools we had two failed votes in New
Market prior to the
moratorium then during the following
years even though there was a moratorium
on school building Aid New Market didn't
have the luxury to wait for the
legislature to change its policy after
years of struggling and no concrete
sense of when the moratorium would end
the community scaled back its push for a
new school and decided to move forward
on necessary Renovations of our school
facilities
unfortunately though there may have been
a moratorium on Aid that didn't make the
need go
away I was here in 2015 giving testimony
on a similar Bill a bill that would
allow school districts to apply for
building aid for projects approved
before the moratorium was lifted and
here we are now I met with a new market
superintendent just a week ago and we
talked about the many budgetary issues
facing the schools today including
increased special education costs
threats of unlimited efas and an overall
lack of adequate funding but he then
reminded me that in New Market they
start the budget process two million $2
million behind because of debt service
and a lack of participation from the
state New Market isn't the only
community that needed to move forward on
serious and Urgent facility needs even
though there was a moratorium in place
then and now we hoped and continue to
hope that we can somehow provide some
property tax relief to the communities
like New Market even if it's just a
little bit we sat here just last week
discussing the financial implications of
unrestricted
vouchers our priority should be funding
our Public Schools including providing a
safe and healthy learning environment
and I urge my colleagues to consider
this legislation and vote in favor of HB
366 thank you thank you very much are
there questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much just represent papovich thank you
Mr chair thank you representative for
taking the question I will be very very
brief could you you know you said that
you ended up having to build a smaller
facility when no building Aid was
available
does the current facility meet the needs
of the new market
schools um I would argue that it does
meet the needs um and and so yeah I
think that we went back to the drawing
board and
um and built a facility uh or renovated
the facilities um we renovated both the
high school and the ele the Junior
Senior High School and the elementary
school in the process
great thank you further questions not
seeing you thank you very much great
thank you I'd like to invite Robert
Thompson thank you Mr chair thank you to
the members of the education funding
committee uh my name is uh Robert
Thompson I am the superintendent of
schools in Hamstead um also a resident
of Milford um so so I want to speak you
uh in favor of uh the bill before you um
and I'm just going to tell you in full
disclosure that uh Hamstead is uh number
sixth on the ranked list of schools uh
to receive uh funding so they're clearly
is a benefit and a financial interest to
my school district to be here today uh
but so I wanted to just walk you through
very quickly some of the issues that
we're dealing with in Hamstead that I
know other schools are dealing with as
well so specifically we're looking to do
um an addition to our elementary school
and there's a couple of issues um that
are Urgent um and we need to solve those
problems today uh and one is uh
overcrowding uh so I know there are
other school uh school districts and
other towns that they're seeing
declining enrollments that is not the
case in Hamstead uh in Hamstead we see a
trend we see uh older uh couples uh who
are uh trying to capitalize on high
property values they're they're moving
and we have young families who are
moving into Hamstead and so we will see
over the next 10 years a pretty
significant uh increase in our student
enrollment and we don't know where we're
going to put them uh we have teachers
that are on carts we have uh teachers
that teach in undersized classrooms it's
a real problem and the second issue is
uh we have some safety concerns at the
building and I'm not going to go into
those specifically here uh but just say
you know we've appreciated uh being the
recipient of uh the safe grants uh the
last round round three uh the school
received
$100,000 uh and that money is greatly
appreciated uh but to solve major
structural building issues $100,000 is
not sufficient uh we need an addition uh
that will help us to address some of
those safety
concerns and the last issue and the one
I'd really like to focus on is special
education and uh so our special
education program uh the building was
not built when special education came
into existence and therefore the model
that we have has students being educated
in very small cramped overcrowded spaces
uh some that were previously closets uh
windowless
spaces and what I'd like to do rather
than just focusing on Hamstead is I'd
like to make that connection with uh
special education Aid and and I know
that's a Hot Topic but if you I'm sure
you uh you know you've looked into this
and you realized that the majority of
your special education Aid goes to out
of District placements that's tuition
and that's also Transportation as well
and I can tell you that part of the
solution to the special education
funding issue is building Aid and
Hamstead is a great example in order for
us to um if we had more space we would
be able to expand our in District
programming
right now we have an issue where we do
not have the space to provide some uh
programs that would educate children
with disabilities in our own school and
I'll even use the transportation example
I have students whose Transportation
Bill alone is
$50,000 a year just to transport
students to a special education
placement we can educate those children
in our own District if we have the space
the ability to expand it is a major
limitation of schools and one that needs
to be considered and if we look beyond
the money we really need to look at that
imperative if you are a family and
you've moved to Hamstead to benefit from
the Hamstead schools and your child has
a
disability that your child deserves the
opportunity to be educated in the
community they live in to be educated
with their neighbors and the other
children and not bust an hour away uh to
an an a of District placement simply
because we don't have the space there
will always be children with severe
disabilities that our school will not be
able to serve but that's not the case
with all children building Aid is an
investment in the future it's an
investment for children with
disabilities and it helps to solve some
of the funding issues that I know that
you'll be discussing when it comes to
special education Aid thank you for your
consideration are there any questions of
the superintendent yes thank you Mr
chair and thank you superintendent for
testifying I want to be very brief again
it's a long day you said $50,000 for
transportation I it's the first time I
heard the number of that magnitude can
you very briefly give me an
understanding of why God's name does it
cost so much in that particular case I
know special ed is unique but I just
would appreciate a bit of background so
absolutely so first is um supply and
demand there is a limited number of uh
Transportation Prov providers uh
particularly those are going to work um
with students um in uh special education
with disabilities uh we are permitted to
uh transport a uh student up to 1 hour
away from their uh their residence a 1H
hour uh in we have children with pretty
uh specific disabilities that require
certain schools and even those schools
are fairly Limited in number so that is
uh student that could travel up to an
hour away from uh their home home uh
both ways uh they require some type of
specialized Transportation uh because
they may have a physical disability uh
they may require a bus monitor because
uh they have an emotional disability or
even an LNA because of a medical need uh
the costs are are pretty significant and
again it's also another issue where uh
special education Transportation it's
not only the cost it's the availability
uh there's not enough out there to um to
meet uh the actual demand thank you
represent fellows yes thank you um do
you already have the plan for what you
want to do for the renovation and if you
do I'm wondering if building um
including space that's good for the
special ed special
population could help other school
districts nearby also because could they
to would you did are you planning to be
able to accommodate some out of District
students y so uh our plan right now uh
is um on file uh with the Department of
Education uh and includes uh class
classroom expansion a new main office
new nurse Suite uh in a library as well
what that does is it uh frees up uh
space for the um for expansion of uh
special education just a real quick
example our nurse's office for example
uh the existing nurses office isn't
adequate uh for the nurses needs uh but
it would be a space that would include a
bathroom having a a space with a
bathroom could really help with a
student with an intellectual disability
or another type of disability uh as far
as you know right now um I guess it's if
you build it they will come uh we need
to first uh be able to see the needs
that we have seem to increase every
single year so it can be difficult to
forecast in the future uh not just
meeting our own needs but those of other
schools I think ideally it would be
great we already work pretty uh
cooperatively with other school district
districts to help meet needs and uh if
the space were to allow it
absolutely thank you very much not see
any other people wanting to speak or ask
a question thank you very much thank you
and uh I'd like to call forward David
Trumble uh as advice for the committee
members we have one last person has pink
card in it is the Department of
Education and and Tim Carney is here uh
if in case there are some questions
thank you good morning Mr chairman good
morning committee members my name is
David Trumble I'm from the town of where
uh in where we had a middle school that
was in violation of the school state
building codes we failed State money
allowed us this is 15ish years ago to
rebuild our Middle School a new building
at that one with three votes if the
state money had not been there it would
not have passed so your money when you
spend a dollar on State Building Aid
you're leveraging two or three dollars
coming from the local communities I had
a few points to add to the discussion
first this I think the state has a duty
to assist in the funding for building
local schools for over 100 years we've
had the standard School Statute in place
it's RSA
18924 where the state mandates suitable
and sanitary Public Schools everywhere
so it's this is not like fire
departments where there is no mandate
that there be uh fire departments you
mandate that there be suitable schools
in every town I think when you mandate
something then there comes an obligation
to help fund it the second is that the
10year moratorium has put us at a spot
where we can no longer provide an
adequate learning environment the New
Hampshire school funding fairness
project did a report on the State
Building aiding condition of New
Hampshire public schools in July of 2023
it's the most recent report that I can
find anywhere here's what they found 20%
of New Hampshire school students are in
buildings that have not been updated for
35 years as bestos and Lead are found in
24% of New Hampshire's public schools
and the largest group of students 30% in
New Hampshire go to buildings where
their most recent construction or
renovation was in the 1990s that's 30
years ago so what does that mean for
schools how old is too old for a schools
um I did a little looking around the
internet to find that out because it was
not clear to me and the national Center
for Education statistics wrote a brief
on how old are America's schools and I
said when a school is 20 to 30 years old
frequent replacement of equipment is
needed between 30 and 40 years the
original equipment should have been
replaced roofs and electrical after 40 a
school building begins rapid
deterioration and at 60 years most
schools are abandoned so what that means
is you got 20% of your schools that are
in the state of somewhere between rapid
deterioration and abandonment another
30% by the end of this decade will enter
will enter that phase as well that's
half of the schools if we ex do not
adequately fund this project now you're
going to end up in a state of crisis in
your schools the last thing I wanted to
add is well does school buildings is it
just a matter of comfort or does it
actually help with school attainment
there's been some studies on this
there's not a lot of them but I found
one from a professor from Virginia
polych Institute Glenn Earthman and he
looked at studies from around the
country he cited several studies and
said that the condition of school
buildings has a sizable and measurable
influence on the achievement of students
the average difference between students
in old or substandard buildings and
those students in modern or above
standard buildings is 5 to 17 percentile
points and an urban areas it's 14 to 17
so what's a percentile point it's not a
percentage it's a percentile so if
people come in and say why is my school
only performing at the 50th percentile
if they had a decent building they would
go up 14 percentile points point they
would be in the 60th percentile so in
other words basic things like having a
decent building which has obviously room
for special ed students so they're not
in closets but temperature control
ventilation natural lighting all these
things provides better performance you
can get over 10 percentile points by
taking schools from substandard to
standard so it just seems like since we
mandate that schools do this the state
has an obligation and that that I urge
you to look at that report from the New
Hampshire school funding fairness
project thank you thank you very much
are there any questions representative
papovich thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking the question you are
citing a scientific study do you know
whether they accounted for other factors
that may have uh impacted the outcomes
or have they established a causal
relationship between the building
because frankly it's kind of hard to
believe that if I put the same exact
teachers and students in a different
building academic performance shoots up
by 20% or the number you quoted
thank you representative for that
question this report um and I I will
submit it to you you can look it up
online it's 80 page it's it's many many
many pages like we we do have a copy of
that report we've had it before and and
there's a direct
relationship between lighting sound
heating all that to the learning of a
student in school it's between five and
15 percentage points as you mentioned
but we have those report reports those
reports not just this one but they date
back for a good 15 20 years we will have
that thank you Mr
chairman further questions represent
Ames you newbies on this commit for the
newbies on this committee Could you um
could someone provide us with the link
to that report yes and with the other
information we have like the age of
buildings those that are over 50 60
years old we have that information as
well um we had Amy uh Clark who was the
engineer for the state in the previous
years researched some of that for us so
I'll gather all that up and make that
available further information thank or
questions thank you very much thank you
Mr
chairman um before I close this down uh
is Tim still here I saw di Fenton here
second ago there she is back there too
Tim do you have anything to add to this
uh no I'm just available any question
okay are there any questions of the
department representative luno thanks
very much Mr chair thank you very much
uh uh director Carney for uh joining us
this morning
um during the introduction of the bill
um there was some there was there was
some um some question and some
discussion with respect to um uh
applications for building Aid that may
have uh you know during the moror period
and and and I guess this is just I I
don't know the answer to this are were
there applications for uh for building
Aid projects submitted to the state
during the moratorium period and um and
how I guess how did the department act
on um on those if if such applications
were submitted yeah so thank you for the
question um a little background I'm in
my second week in this position and so I
I've been with the department for a bit
so I do have a little bit of knowledge
but no exact knowledge on the your
specific question I know that during
moratorium many schools did not submit
applications because there was an
established moratorium um I can't speak
to year toe if schools went ahead and
submitted applications or not despite
there being a
moratorium so we are aware and Amy which
uh the chair did mention Amy Clark the
prior engineer did put together a list
of projects uh School building projects
that occurred from 2009 to
2019 I do not know whether or not all of
those projects are only some of those
projects or any of those projects
submitted an actual application or not
okay we did approve one emergency
project and towards the end of the
moratorium some districts started wising
up and put their applications in and
three eventually received
funding further Prof Burton just a uh a
note um we built a new bu Middle School
in Oyster River for $50 million on a
76% approval vote um we insisted because
all of our public buildings are now zero
net buildings that it be that school is
a zero net building no one's mentioned
the fact and maybe you can Enlighten us
how much an operating cost do you save
by having a new
facility thank you for the question
unfortunately I don't have that
information yet um again being new to
the I can tell you it's significant I
would imagine yet along with the fact we
have no do you have a followup question
represent Burton no okay are there any
further questions from the committee
with that I'm going to close this
hearing thank
you and prepare to open up the next one
here the next bill coming forward is uh
a bill uh number 515 repeat ing the
Charter Public School eligibility for
the state school building a
program and I'd like to recognize
represent kahill thank you Mr chair uh
if I if I big your Indulgence just for a
moment just to answer a couple of things
that came in in the preceding bill um no
I'd like to have you just going cuz
we're getting way behind here I'm sorry
so let's move right on with uh 5:15 okay
thank you thank you very much uh
515 is a bill that would repeal the
eligibility for charted schools this was
passed last year and the reason I
opposed that that bill and the reason
I'm trying to repeal it now is I think
you've heard in the testimony in the
previous Bill we don't have the
money uh we haven't been meeting the
needs of the traditional Public Schools
uh there's a long backlog it's going to
take money and time
and adding to that the chartered
schools uh will take more money than we
have
um I I did send you all a link to that
uh to the to the uh floor debate and I
wanted to bring out a couple of points
with that in that uh representative
luno ran through some of the concerns uh
about
the condition of our of our schools and
that we did in fact you know have that
obligation and that uh Charters you know
Charters do have other sources of of uh
Revenue uh I'm thinking of the uh
lionart School uh which is done by a
venture capitalist here in New Hampshire
somewhere uh bought a building to set up
a Char of school got naming rights for
it um and there are other organizations
that are you know it's sort of like a a
franchise I think I've seen where this
privatization but as I've stated we we
don't have the money we are we have
burdened uh communities who did apply
who could not apply their applications
were they couldn't put an application
and we have those schools that are still
waiting and there are many more because
as as you know we have yet to pass a
bill that would allow us to really good
get a good assessment of how many
schools are out there and what they
conditions are that was I think this I
think the other body put your bill into
uh uh interim study or whatever their
polite term is uh but I wanted to draw
your attention to the to that debate
where representative McDonald spoke you
know eloquently and passionately about
extending the eligibility to Charter
Schools and she used the word
always the traditional Public Schools
could always apply
and
always uh invariably without exception
that's what that means and these lists
that I presented to you indicate that
that's not the case we don't always get
the money we can't even always apply as
in during the
moratorium uh I know that the new market
School Board worked closely with Amy
Clark to make sure that we were kind of
in line with what the expectations were
but we couldn't do an application
so uh again you have people who are
thinking that this you know I know in
New Hampshire we talk a lot about needs
and wants and we have to make sure we
take care of our needs first and the
needs are demonstrated across the state
in our traditional public school
buildings uh we talk the the prior a
prior witness talked about uh 40 years
is a long time long shelf life for a
building uh our our high school was
built in uh
1925 I mean as old as Jimmy
Carter and you know we've done some
additions to it over the years and our
elementary was fairly new I think in the
late 70s or early 80s but then we had
the you know the New Hampshire miracle
and all of a sudden we had a lot more
kids we had put in uh MERS that were
there for 30 years before we could pass
a war article to build real classrooms I
know in Nottingham there there another
another another school that's uh running
out of space modular it's it's not an
answer I I I learned recently about the
uh the commission on school public
school infrastructure and that we did
you did get some co uh some uh Cobra
money I'm not Cobra gopher money uh to
do to do some work on security how are
you going to have security for modular
classrooms so we're going in you know
we're doing little bits here and there
we we're trying to get internet in rural
areas we're trying to do bulletproof
glass on schools uh this isn't really
necessarily all what we should be doing
we should be assuming making sure that
we have a decent solid safe efficient
classroom environment for our
students and we're we haven't done that
yet so that's why I keep on bringing
back this bill I I know that Mr Maguire
is probably a little fatigue but we we
have talked about it and I I appreciate
your patience and as well as the other
members of the committee uh who may be
new to this but it's an issue that we we
need to do something and we cannot
spread our thin resources further by
adding the 30 Charter Schools or
whatever number might be uh whatever in
the next I I know we uh we took uh $47
million from uh the feds to double the
number of charart schools not that we
needed them but the money was there and
our our traditional Public Schools do
serve the vast majority of our students
our families our communities our
business looking for educated Workforce
they were doing the job we didn't need
to bring Charters here they have their
place but they don't have to be every
place I'm gladly take any questions
thank you other questions represent
McGuire thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question um section s s of
your bill on page four line
35 um it's deleting a paragraph that has
nothing to do with school building Aid
it it's just about um school records and
and so on is that just in there
inadvertently uh I think it probably is
thank you my
confession further questions from the
committee yes represent luno thank you
very much Mr chair thank you very much
again I represent kale you referenced
the uh the federal Charter um expansion
Grant the $47 million and I know the
state hasn't received the whole chunk of
that but um but can those dollars be
used for um for uh facilities uh I I
believe they're used for startup costs
and I know we we give a we provide lease
we financial assistance for leases which
I think could be included I don't know
whether or not uh they could use those
funds to ire a building but certainly
they can lease an
abandon uh Shopping Center or wherever
they put the schools uh and again that's
kind of that's kind of a string I know
we don't like strings attached from
Washington but that was a
rope great thank you further questions
from the
committee not see you thank you very
much thank you sir I'd like to invite
represent Moren Mooney
there is her
testimony there multiple copies there
will pass
me we do have a sheet coming around uh
Welcome to our committee again thank
thank you very much Mr chairman and good
morning to you good morning to members
of the House funding education funding
committee my name is morine money and I
represent the town of marac that's
Hillsboro District number 12 I've
provided a copy of my testimony for each
of you today and one for the clerk I'm
here in
opposition opposition to House Bill 5:15
and act repealing the chartered Public
School eligibility for state school
building Aid by means of background I
was the Prime sponsor of the bill to
include public charter schools in the
application process this is about the
application process for school building
Aid that bill that I prime sponsored was
just last term House Bill
354 introduced in
2023 House Bill 354 which will be the
focus of my testimony considering House
Bill 515 wants to repeal all of it was
signed into law less than a year ago
June 14th
2024 and that signature came after an
entire year of the House Education
committee chaired by your
chairman to review it study it ask
questions amend it very carefully
after that full year of review the house
voted ought to pass with Amendment on a
roll call 190 to
177 on January 4th
2024 and then the full Senate voted
ought to pass on a Voice vote May 2nd
2024 here's a synopsis three main points
that house bill 354 did first of all it
corrected a glaring contrib iction in
the law there was a section of law that
said Point
Blank public charter schools don't
receive building Aid and then an
entirely other section of law that said
well they do and it's in my testimony
under number one but the amount of the
grant to any chartered Public School
shall be 30% of the eligible cost of
construction well which is it as a side
note I sit on house finance and there
was a bill to have an attorney be hired
for the Department of Ed to go through
the hundreds of rsas and House Education
I mean in education law and look for
discrepancies and you know what it was
that they used as the example for that
position this very contradiction related
to building aid for public charter
schools synopsis point2 The Bill simply
allows public charter schools to apply
not get apply like any other school that
wants to apply for public uh Aid
building Aid uh to be included in that
application process just like any other
traditional Public School
can and then in my synopsis number three
there are parameters around this it's
not a
blanket uh the first is that the public
charter school that applies for the a
must own its own building own its own
building so that's not everybody in fact
that's um the department of Ed can
clarify this I think don't quote but
it's around 11 schools that would even
be eligible to apply for this building
Aid because they own their own
buildings the grant payment is spread
out over a typical loan term that's very
different than the traditional public
school that would apply for school
building Aid and thirdly and this was
part of the amendment that the house
education committee proposed last term
the chartered school must have its asset
disposition plan approved by the State
Board of
Education so this law currently that
came from House Bill
354 allows the public charter school
that owns it its own building the option
of applying but there are very strict
parameters around it that were crafted
by the House Education Committee just
last
term House Bill 354 has been signed into
law less than one year ago for the
reasons stated in my testimony I
recommend that you recommend House Bill
515 inexpedient to legislate and with
that I'll conclude my testimony and I
thank you all for your attention thank
you thank you very much representative
Mooney are there questions from the
committee yes representative Maguire
then representative fellows thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative for
taking my
question I'm wondering about this
provision that they must own their own
building wouldn't a charter school that
leases space be more likely to want to
build a new you know get rid of the
lease and build a new building and
shouldn't they be
eligible a very good point um there is
lease Aid available for Charter Schools
that's something separate in fact I was
uh responsible for increasing that but
uh with regards to your question I leave
it to the house education committee from
last term they spent an entire year
reviewing and carefully amending this
bill and decided to go in the direction
that it did as opposed to what you
suggest thank representative fellows uh
thank you um my question is about your
statement that 11 schools own their
building um which may be true but in
their disposition plan that's part of
their Charter
it or part of their plan that building
there may be specifications that that
building reverts to whomever gave them
that building initially so it's not the
normal kind of ownership that you would
see when people own houses and and ask
for a loan to make um improvements on
the loan so can you respond
to the issue that maybe what they're
renovating and up not being their
property in the state gave them money to
fix it up or build in thank you for the
question I would simply say that um what
was agreed upon last year through a very
thorough amendment process was the word
own uh the logistics of that maybe could
be fleshed out further i' be open to
that um but I do see your your point
Thank you further questions representa
luno uh thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you very much representative um I
was wondering if you could talk to the
committee a little bit about excuse me
about
um excuse me um the um the number of
charter schools that have over over the
history that we've had them in New
Hampshire the
last couple decades is I believe since
the 90s all right so so three decades um
uh how many have um have either you know
become insolvent whether that was due to
um mismanagement or or you know um you
know financial fraud or something like
that I was wonder if you could just sort
of put that in context to the number of
charter schools that that we've had over
that time thank you for that question
that did come up last time and I know
that all of the closings have been
carefully documented I believe it's a
public document and perhaps someone from
the doe too could flesh this out but um
my understanding I remember seeing the
list last year it circulated during this
very discussion not only did it list the
school that had to close but the reason
and I remember reasons such as uh
finances and things of that nature but
as I recall uh from a year ago or so the
list it was maybe about 10 or or so I
think in that ballpark that closed um
and the the primary reason was a lack of
fundraising and things of that nature
and then follow up Mr chair that's my
recollection yeah thanks and I think
that's that's sort of along the lines of
my recollection uh as well and and you
know and I'm I'm interested in your your
your thoughts to this particularly as a
as a former Charter School administrator
correct um um that that what recourse
would the state have if it had invested
taxpayer money in in a um in in building
aid for charter school and then that
charter school later became you know in
her
bankrupt well uh that's a a real big
topic with regards to uh insolvency and
closure and the process that the
department of Ed then has to uh enact in
order to handle this of the schools that
were on that list for example I don't
know who owned their own building if any
did so I don't know to address that what
the circumstances would have been I also
U I'm not familiar with their Charters
and I know that their Charters if
they're done properly and the doe
appropriately uh accepts them that they
should have a disposition plan within
each of them as to how the assets would
break break up that should be all not
only filed with the Department of Ed but
very public and on every Charter
School's website their Charter and a
plan for disposition included in that
Charter so I I hope that um begins to
answer your question but you bring up a
big topic yeah yeah and just a a really
specific followup uh to to that Mr chair
last one yeah yeah no appreciate it so
so so so if if a charter with a within
existing you know Charter approved by
the state board were to receive a
building aid grant would would would
they
be would would this bill require them or
not this bill would the current law
require them to update their Charter to
be specific about the disposition of the
state's Grant um and where it sits in
line with with with other assets um
during a uh during a bankruptcy or a
dissolution uh thank you for that I
would say to answer that um no the
current law doesn't get that specific
however I would hope that the department
of Ed more specifically the Board of
Education when they're hearing reviewing
and approving these Charters would see
to it that the language includes exactly
what you stated okay thank you thank you
very much are there further questions of
represent Mooney not seeing it
representative Ames your hand up go
ahead
um and you may have spoken to this and I
missed it but uh do you have information
on uh projects that have been started
down the the application uh
roadway uh since the adoption of the law
that you sponsored last
year so just to clarify do you mean have
any of the charter schools in New
Hampshire that own their buildings
applied for building Aid since the
adoption of this bill law well I'm
really looking at a little bit beyond
that yes that part of it but as well
okay are there others that you know of
that are uh that are coming um to
fruition as applications my answer would
be no I don't know the information on
that
further questions represent McGuire
thank you Mr chairman um representative
would you believe that RSA 194b colon 16
provides that when a charter school uh
dissolves um its assets are given to the
local school district and the local
school district does not get any of its
obligations
if you are looking at the law I believe
that thank that's what we put in the law
just recently
so do you have a question of the on that
yeah absolutely we're not in executive
session we're not having a great discuss
thank you but I mean that that's a
that's a very good point that
representative Maguire brings up but um
are you aware of any um of the 10 or so
uh Charter dissolutions that had any
remaining assets that um uh and and were
those assets disposed per that um that
that uh provision in state law to the
local school district the answer is no
because I'm just not that familiar with
the the closings that have occurred
since the '90s in the state on the
public charter schools and how their
assets were distributed thank you thank
you very much any further questions
thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman thank forward uh Jody Adams
good
morning can you turn your mics on yeah
thanks hello uh I'm Jody Adams I'm the
executive director at the New Hampshire
Alliance for public charter
schools um I just wanted to say uh first
and foremost um charter schools are
public schools and we want to be
included
with traditional Public
Schools um so as representative Moody
was Mooney was saying um this was only
added just fairly recently so none of
the charter schools have really had the
opportunity to even
apply um we understand there really
isn't a lot of funds in in uh are
actually available right now this is
more about being included now to even be
able to apply there could be more funds
down the line in the future so we
understand that there's not a lot of
funds to go around
so to his point you know we are we
understand we're competing for a small
amount of money and we may not get it
and and that makes sense um but securing
facilities is a big challenge for
charter schools and we would still like
to be able to be included with other
Public Schools um and have that ability
down the down the road um so
so we don't have the ability to have
local taxes uh for facilities we pay uh
Market rates for those facilities and so
it is very expensive um to
representative Moody's Point um most of
our schools don't own their facilities
we lease so this really is a matter of a
small amount of our schools who are have
the ability to
apply thank thank you very much I think
everybody else has pretty much made most
of my points already are there any
questions of the alliance represent
luno uh thank you very much um Miss
Adams um you started off by saying
charter schools are public schools and I
just wanted to to uh to to check on that
a little bit so are you saying that are
do Charter Schools I mean are Charter
Schools political subdivisions like like
our public schools are and are they run
by publicly elected um um um school
board members not publicly elected but
we are considered public schools are
public charter schools okay and then and
and as far as as far as how public how
your Charter Schools operate are are
they operated through through I
guess a a 51 C3 type are private
nonprofit organization we are we are so
wait a minute we're not how many
questions are we going to have
represent that was it was really getting
at the term public we are financially
and academically held accountable as
traditional public schools
are thank you very
much pick up is that what you were
getting up no I was getting oh yeah and
we'll get into that corporate and the
contracts and all that later when we are
in executive session we did this last
year um as every public school student
deserves they receive money not from
this fund but also from the public
school infrastructure fund which deals
with Homeland Security issues of
security safety Access Communications
all that and those grants have been
going up we want all public school
students
safe yes the chair so so um I I I
appreciate we'll get into that during
the executive session we also be getting
into it during the work sessions that
you talked about we would be having for
these groups of bills during the work
sessions any information going to
contribute to our getting to the end of
where we have to get we will bring in um
but this discussion is rolling down the
road we even had a separate committee
looking at this last year and looking at
records of charter school when we do
have dissolution what happens those
records who's in charge the public
school uh so the of the of the district
so there's a lot to this a very in-depth
subject um as building eight is uh
totally so we will get into this these
are the Bills which are just going to
get us into where we have to
go further questions of the alliance not
seeing thank you very much thank you and
with that I'm going to close this
hearing I have no other pink cards up
here and we're going to get ready to go
into
494 which is a a bill that's been
presented dealing with the math learning
communities
and okay yeah okay well you're going to
be running this meeting because I got to
go present the bill yeah
yeah
me those are the ones which has been
handed in I haven't F my not I
will you're going to introduce it yes I
got to
introduce okay I'm going to open the
hearing on a HB 494 and recognize
representative lad the prime
sponsor well thank you very much to the
committee for the record my name is Rick
lad I come from grafted five that's haal
Benton Pont Warren Landa up on the
Connecticut River um I'm here today to
introduce 494 this is a program uh that
we uh have been funding here for several
years initially through a Federal grant
that the community college has received
and subsequently last year when we
placed uh
$250,000 into the budget to continue
with the math learning community so I
want to describe what this program is to
everybody very briefly here uh for you I
think I there should be a sheet coming
around that has my testimony on it and
I'm just going to jump down through the
three categories there um how do we
describe and how what is this program
this program is a program where we know
that we have within our K through2
system that we've had our mathematics
achievement kind of level if not even
going down when I came on board here we
had roughly around 40% of our students
uh proficient in mathematics we're right
in the same neighborhood today we have a
need to address what is going on with
some of the students that need uh
support initially this program was put
into place in the high schools through a
grant money from from the federal
government which the Community College
had
received and the minister it through the
in conjunction with the Department of
Education what we did is at the end of
the ninth grade those students which
were appearing to have a hard time in
mathematics they were given a a an
assessment which is was used at that
time at the community college the uh
accuplacer Next Generation accuplacer I
think the name was it's no longer used
that would uh the kids would take that
and see who is really prepared to go
into algebra algebra 2 we know that
there's a number of students coming out
of the elementary schools and the middle
schools which just don't have real
confidence in mathematics for one reason
or another they're they're not really
able to grasp from the conceptual
understandings that math
requires so what was done there several
foundational math class was introduced
in the high school along with another
one in quantitative math where it was
presented so the learning style of the
student the teaching style matched that
of the
learner not taught in that conventional
traditional manner it might have been
more Hands-On it may have been more you
know uh relating these skills to actual
Pathways and careers so kids became able
they they could see some of the rational
why to do that since that time the
program has had changed we had at that
time about 38 high schools participating
at throughout the state and we were
seeing remarkable gains we were seeing
that we were not having that 60 per rate
when kids went into the community
college system that required remedial
mathematics we were a to cut that down
the Federal grant money stopped and and
also our Appropriations reduced too to
the point where there were none and that
program fell apart because the Community
College was also offering professional
training and training of the instructors
and how to teach the math learning
communities program last year the house
and the Senate and the governor had the
wisdom to sign it a law that the
$250,000 to reboot this program and it
has been done so and now we had changed
directorship over there and the
directorship prior to was an excellent
directorship the community college has
always been very supportive of this
program and as the Math teachers
throughout the state are so the program
is now administered clearly and solely
through the community college system of
New Hampshire in partnership with post
secondary high
schools it accurately defines the the
program is used for struggling students
who have not been able to master the
skills and it it it stresses to do the
same thing it was originally designed to
do
the program now is being redefined in
statute it's it's in statute uh I
believe
193 I I believe um and in that in that
statute we have written up the structure
and the sequence of courses that are
presented the program shall consist of
one or more High School level courses if
a student goes through these courses and
is able to master these and come out
with an understanding Algebra 2 which
many of them are doing through this
non-traditional way of teaching they are
able to take concurrent the the last
year at concurrent and dual and
concurrent uh I'm going to say dual
enrollment program and get college
credit for that uh so the students
mastering Algebra 2 concept shall be
considered for dual enrollment college
level mathematics dual enrollment means
it's taught at the college by a person
with the same standards that it is for
every other student that's been approved
by the crediting Association at the
Collegiate level concurrent enrollment
is where it's done in the high school by
high school teacher but with the same
standards same materials as used in
college the the community college system
is providing professional training for
the the teachers which are teaching this
program and the new statutory language
which has been placed here you can see
in the bottom portion of the class of
the of the page here reporting to the
New Hampshire Department of Education
house senate and education committees
the Community College shall report every
October 1 now a report and that report
to us will reflect the number of
students participating in the
program number of participants that have
been trained in the program instructors
professional development update
Community College practice uh offerings
that are done databased student
achievement and growth uh data will be
provided to the to the Department and to
this education committee and other
information as determined by the
Community College the first year we're
talking about the FY uh 26 there we are
allocating $200,000 for this program to
continue and in the SEC year second year
um
$250,000 I attended a workshop or a
training session on Friday August 16th
in
nhti where we pulled in instructors
throughout this state in mathematics
I've never been in a in a program like
this before where I've seen so much
excitement for where we need to go with
the teaching of mathematics it was well
done and I congratulate the community
college system for really helping us out
in this endeavor it's come out though
that this program and other programs we
really need to start dipping down lower
than just in the high school the fear of
mathematics starts well down in the
Elementary grades and these teachers
that are working with the community
college system now are being trained on
working other folks uh in their school
system on the back side of that paper
you can
see that because we are rebooting this
program and that will be explained in
detail by folks behind me that there are
12 confirmed Partners already expressing
desire to be involved with this in FY 26
in Lakes Manchester Central Manchester
Memorial Manchester West marac Valley
molten Boro Nashville North Nashville
South Plymouth Prospect m Spalding
Woodsville havil these schools have all
had identified they have staffed they
trained and willing and to really start
this program out I think this is
something that we need to continue this
is an area of our curriculum and
achievement of our students which needs
our address mathematics is our weak
subject area in this state and it's not
just a result of the pandemic as you may
recall and representative fellows may
recall working with Paul Leathers Paul
chaired a task force on math uh
instruction in the state 12 years ago
and they identified math is needing a
lot of help it continues to need that
help I'm glad to see that the community
college system is recognizing that the
old conventional method that we've been
working has been netting results and
what they're doing here is something new
and I really really feel that this is
one of the ways which we're going to
really upgrade our math results in our
school district so with that I'm going
to stop and let the community college
system take over they're the ones who
have the specifics on this program the
good thing is that the money goes to the
community college system and it's
administered through the community
college system and um it
works I'll take any questions Mr
chair yes representative Maguire thank
you Mr chairman thank you representative
um so this is a program that's already
in law that's being Rewritten could we
ask our committee researcher to do a
side by side and and sort of what what
we're doing now versus how the rewrite
changes including financial
matters the financial matters haven't
changed the they the same as we've
always had
$250,000 although this is lessening in
the first year $200,000 then $ 250 the
two there's two sections if you look at
the statute which this language in this
bill is replacing with updates we're
taking the accuplacer out we had
specific names to test tier one tier two
and the names of that what we're doing
is we're letting the local assessments
now do that assessment it's not going to
have to be done through that accuplacer
which that was all being provided
through Federal Monies and quite frankly
it's outdated now and it's not what
schools are using so yeah we can have a
side by side done there's no problem
with that thank you may I have a
followup yes thank you Mr chairman um it
looks to me like this is spending
General funds would it be more
appropriate to be education
funds to
me that's one way the other is fine as
long as the funds are there what we're
doing as school districts are really
getting their training from the
community college system we're getting
instructors from the community college
system they're paying for the training
for people to come in the summertime to
nhti the travel we're paying for the
time that they're at the stien all
that's coming through this so it's
really a savings to school districts um
and it's just what we're doing here this
is trying to put in place legislation to
continue what we have been doing
and the funding amount in there is
trying to continue to see this reflected
in hb2 and
hb1 further
questions
yes so
uh I could be wrong but so I believe you
said that the reporting oh I'm sorry
thank you for taking my question thank
you very much I believe you said that
the reporting section is new do we have
any um data from when how I guess how do
we know that I mean I know you said that
it's doing great and I'm sure that it is
but do we have any data and could if we
do can it be maybe shared with us I
think that the data can be shared from
the by the community college system in
New Hampshire we're seeing fewer kids
when they get into the Collegiate level
having to take that remed in fact we're
not giving a remedial education they can
explain how that works now um few are
there and we're seeing those students
coming out with math already under their
belt so when they go to the community
college system they've already met that
credit okay yeah thank you they can
provide that info
thanks representative
Ames thank you and thank you um
representative lad uh looks like a great
program uh I'm just wondering about
reaching out to outline districts and uh
I noticed that these 12 are uh outside
of my county jure county and um we're
all concerned about being sure that
every kid in the state has access to
good programs like this so can you speak
to that yeah I think Community College
represent I think the Community College
can do that remember we're rebooting
here we had 38 schools before
now you see the 12 for that but there's
more to come that are on the docket they
have to gear up make sure that they have
the people on board to teach these
courses I know that the town I'm in
Woodsville havil we just hired a ma
teacher which we stole from rivendale
and uh able to do this now and do it
well and I'm I'm seeing already just by
watching what's going on in that school
kids are enjoying mathematics where it
hadn't happened before so yes it's got
to be in other counties as well
grafton's pretty far north and uh so I
guess they tapped into it because Rick
lad was able to inform them that there's
a program get involved but I think it
was also because of the superintendent
there was recognizing this is our
weakness and two years ago they rebooted
their whole math program and wrote the
math standards and over they know we
have math standards but wrote their
curriculum
and bought new materials and that's
making a difference so that you had your
high school teachers now working as the
more like the directors of mathematic
working with the Middle School working
with the elementary school and getting
everybody in the same book and close to
the same
page
yes thank you Mr chairman thank you I'm
I'm probably the only one in this room
that actually took the acup Placer and
barely passed uh as president of a
Community College but why this is so
important I I ask you to agree with me
is that students coming to community
colleges particularly often lack
confidence and and they need to get by
this barrier and we saw our students
bestm the acup place by a few points it
it cost them financial aid it cost them
time it cost them choice of major it
it's a major hangup so this program and
we had similar to it later is extremely
important it's EXT and I I'm asking you
it's extremely important especially in
minority students and new immigrants
which I had thousands of um to to get by
this barrier and move on into the majors
that they needed to get into with the
confidence they had the math my question
is would you support uh a bill to force
anyone elected to the New Hampshire
state legislature to pass The
accuplacer Well Community College system
dumped the accuplacer just for some of
the reasons you spoke about and now it's
up to the recommendation of the teacher
the parent and all saying my youngster
this youngster needs to go have this
alternate rout their learning style does
not match up the way math is being
taught presently they need this
alternative route and they need to
better understand the concepts and how
math works I was one like that when I
was in grade school I was dreadfully
afraid of mathematics I loved history I
loved writing I loved all that but when
it came to math it was my forte it
wasn't until I hit the right teacher in
high school who taught geometry and I
could see it I could live it and I knew
why I was learning it and so I think
that's what we need to be doing that's
what the community college system is
doing and hopefully we can get more high
schools doing that as well thank
you all set thank you chairman lad oh
yes representative Damon thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
which may be for the community col
person but following up on
representative aims there are no
Sullivan County Schools listed here
either and so I'm wondering how the
program gets promoted or marketed to
school ask them thank
you all right then thank you very much
thank you chairman lad okay we have two
uh from the community college system and
so I'd like to call them forward
together Shannon Reed and Dr Chris Comey
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is Shannon Reed I represent the
community college system of New
Hampshire which consists of seven
colleges located across the state we
offer associate degree and certificate
education customized training with
businesses and dual ment for New
Hampshire High School students um we're
pleased to uh testify in support of the
math learning communities bill um I'm
joined today by Dr Chris Cony one of my
colleagues who is a project director and
she can answer all the detailed
questions that you that you have had and
others that come up um in addition to
updating some of the language to bring
it into alignment with how the program
is evolving um this bill also contains
an appropriation to enable us to
continue it the we weren't really sure
the function of this this funding
committee versus the finance division 2
and the finance committee so um I'm not
sure where those pieces will be
considered the language is important
because it helps us to um make sure that
the statutory language aligns with how
the program is kind of changing over
time we're trying to remove some of this
um the specifics from the
legislation so that every time we evolve
in how we um how we assess how we uh
structure the courses we don't have to
come back to the legislature for for
that type of detailed work
um let's
see the um one of the changes that we do
seek to make in the funding is to enable
us to bring our current part-time
coordinator Dr coni into a full-time
role so that we can build the program
continue to reach out to more high
schools um and continue to offer the
professional development to teachers and
deepen those Partnerships um because
those Partnerships between the High
School teachers and our college math
teachers is really critical to kind of
making sure that the that there's
alignment between what students learned
in high school and what they need to
know for College and Career so with that
I'll turn it over to Dr Kami to speak
more about the the program as it um it
was initially created and run for
several years and the more recent reboot
and her work to um expand this to more
New Hampshire High
Schools thank you very much for seeing
us today um I am Dr Chris Cony and I am
the Project Director for the math
learning communities at the community
college system of New Hampshire um and
thank you to representative lad for a
good um overview of the program as it is
uh makes my job a little easier um as he
mentioned this program initially started
in 2006 and ran through
2017 through various federal funds um
however a lot of those funds are
designated towards startup programs and
once you have a program that's running
operational um and is no longer
considered a startup those funds are no
longer available and there weren't any
other funds to replace those so
unfortunately even though the program
was seeing a lot of success with the
increase of scores on the accuplacer at
the time um and the decrease in the
number of students enrolling in remedial
math courses at the college and
university level um with the absence of
that funding the program did go away
um part of that is because a significant
part of our funding as the program
becomes operational and rolls forward is
for ongoing teacher training and
development so um without that ongoing
teacher training and development it just
was not possible to continue to
implement this program in its full form
there were a lot of high schools however
who continued to offer the courses that
had been developed in the program um
even up until today so um that in
addition to the increase in scores and
decrease in um remediation later on that
is kind of a testimony to how the
program
began when this bill was funded the
originally um the program was able to
restart and um after I was the initial
hire for the program we implemented and
created a project leadership team and
that project leadership team is
responsible for the development of the
curriculum and that consists of
community college math department heads
in partnership with high school teachers
so that committee um of that combination
of the community college and high school
are the ones who will be developing the
curriculum and the decision was made
rather than just reinstituting the
courses that were created back in the
early 2000s let's take a look at what
today's student needs and in doing so um
we created a new you know we we took a
look at students coming into this
program in the past trying to prepare
them for Algebra 2 and there was still a
primary focus there of college readiness
we decided to expand our Focus to any
kind of post-secondary pathway that
students would be interested in pursuing
so we want our program not just to
prepare students for college but if
they're going into the military if
they're going into trades or
apprenticeship programs if they're going
directly into career programs we wanted
to make sure that this program provided
them all of the math skills that they
would need so what we did was met with
the university system to make sure that
the content that we have in our Algebra
2 course meets the entry requirements
for the University system but doesn't
necessarily proceed beyond that um a lot
of Algebra 2 content traditionally has
included things that are preparing
students to take calculus
and unless you're on a stem path um that
isn't something that most students need
so rather than including those elements
we were able to redesign the course that
included more quantitative reasoning
skills number Theory and other types of
things that will serve students
regardless of what their path to the
Future would be we also took a look at
the dual enrollment course that was
going to be offered as the second course
for these students and in looking at
today's environment today's world um and
also looking at College programs and
other programs that students might
proceed into it was determined to offer
a statistics course to those students um
that statistics course transfers in at
the college level it transfers in at the
University level it meets the
quantitative uh literacy requirements at
our University system and our community
college system it also meets the math
requirements for many of the majors at
the college so this also gives students
a Head Start if they do decide to follow
a career path that's going to take them
to college or some post-secondary
schooling that would require that even a
lot of the trades and apprenticeships
require um
statistics um as a happy coincidence um
the State Board of Education is also uh
working on requiring statistics to be a
course that students take before they
complete high school so we're already
ahead of the game when it comes to that
um we in this first year we're in a
development year right now and as
representative lad said we are in a
recruiting phase of bringing on board um
schools while our project leadership
team is in the process of preparing the
curriculum and the training for that so
our first schools will be implementing
this program in the fall of
25 and we have um now 13 schools that
have already committed to starting this
program in the fall of 25 we have two
schools already committed and when I say
committed I mean that their
superintendent already signed memorandum
of understandings so that's about as
committed as you can get um they we also
have two schools that have already
committed to start in the fall of 26 um
if you're not familiar with how schools
um operate from a curriculum perspective
um they typically need to plan a year in
advance for when they make curricular
changes so as we started recruiting
schools in September there were already
a lot of schools that it was too late in
the process for them to do that so we
have a number of schools already lined
up um who are very interested in in uh
offering this in in Fall of 26 and this
year we'll be working through that
formal curricular process with their
school districts we also have a
significant number of schools that
are anxious to see how this first year
goes they would like to see now that the
program is being rebooted um they're
very excited about the changes in the
program which I'll talk to about in a
moment but they want to see that those
changes are uh taking effect and having
the the required effect on
students um some of the changes that
we're making to the original program um
we already mentioned that the accuplacer
test has is no longer in use for the
most part at the community college
system of New Hampshire and that's being
replaced not only at the Community
College Center but also uh will be doing
that within this program by other
measures and what Nationwide is being
done right now is a system of multiple
measures is the thing that is is working
out better so even if there is an
assessment exam of some type that isn't
the only thing that we'll be looking at
we'll be looking at teacher
recommendations parent
recommendations um guidance counsel
recommendations uh we may be doing a
student self- assessment survey a lot of
times when you ask students what they
feel comfortable with and what they know
they are the best judge of what they do
and don't know um and so we'll be using
all of those and our goal is basically
to design a non-level version of this
algebra 2 course that almost all
students will be able to take we don't
want to have a leveled course um
statistics show that leveling is not
effective in education um as it once had
been thought to be so creating a course
that's going to be accessible by all is
the direction we want to go the only
students who may not take this course in
some of the larger high schools is
students who are on a very firm path
towards a stem career those high schools
may continue to offer another version of
Algebra 2 that prepares them for
calculus um the other most significant
change that this Pro program makes to
the way that math is
taught is that it is no longer an
algorithm memorization base where the
teacher comes in and teaches you here's
the topic of the day these are the notes
we're going to be taking now we're going
to have you try some problems the method
that we're employing and this is
something that's being employed by um
there's a Consortium called The Learning
um learning years initiative and there's
a Consortium of 23 States already
involved in that in um working on
creating new curriculum that support
this kind of exploratory
base and um with a lot of grant funding
have developed curricular materials that
we're actually going to be able to take
advantage of at no cost to give to our
high schools so in the way that this
teaches and as representative lad we you
know uh mentioned at the conference last
September we contacted schools around
the state and said come see what we're
about come take you know see an example
of what we're going to be doing with
your students and that is a task-based
process where students are allowed to
explore a concept and come to understand
it on their own so rather than being
presented with knowledge that you're
supposed to memorize and remember later
we're going to present problems that
students are going to explore they're
going to find challenging they're going
to make mistakes they're going to figure
out what to do with those mistakes and
that kind of exploratory learning leads
more to Mastery and also remaster if you
learn how to learn effectively then when
you need to do something again in the
future you're able to um do that more
successfully so um that
is is kind of the program in a nutshell
the the differences in the the changes
that we're making to the bill for this
time around um the original program was
geared towards High School juniors and
seniors one of the primary feedback that
we got very vocally at the conference
that we had in September is why are we
waiting so long it's it's you know I
never want to say it's too late but it
is very late to start saying let's help
students master math in as Junior in
high school so a lot of the high school
teachers said can't we please start with
algebra 1 can't we consider doing this
down in the middle school so part of the
rewording of this bill was to allow us
the flexibility to offer and create any
math course and our goal going forward
would be starting with algebra 2 because
that's what we had to start with under
the current wording and then start
working um backwards and create uh
similar courses for all four years in
high school
um that that was one of the Prime that's
pretty much the primary change that we
wanted to make um in the way that things
were going to be doing um we also wanted
to change some of the wording around
students who are not ready for Algebra 2
um students who are going into Algebra 2
have had algebra over and over again for
several years starting in the middle
school and progressing up through
algebra in high school in Geometry again
we don't believe that there should be
any students who aren't ready to tackle
the next level of topics we just need to
do it in a different way because what's
been done but in the past is not working
effectively so we know that that
knowledge is in their mind they've been
exposed to those topics and so we want
to be able to say that um we can use
this course to now move students forward
regardless of where their grades or
other things might indicate their
knowledge level actually
is thank you thank you very much I'd
like to lead with a clarification and a
brief question uh this has an
appropriation so it's a two committee
Bill and it will go on to the finance
committee both committees will review uh
so what specifically is the difference
in the spending level requested for FY
26 and 27 200 versus 250,000 what
changes
um because we started this program well
into the current bium we didn't expend
all the funds in year ones we were able
to roll some into this into this coming
bayum that's last first year other
questions
yes so let me just oh thank you thank
you let me just start by saying that for
um most of my career I was a math and
physics teacher so I commend you on
these I looked for for many of these
types of um learning opportunities for
my students um I have one clarifying
question did you say it was called
learning years
initiative um sorry it's the thank you
for the question it's the launch years
initiative launch years I'm
sorry and so I I want to come back to
the data that I had asked representative
lad about do we do is there some report
or was there a yearly um data dump I I
that you you did dur in the 2006 to
2017 years of um I I mean I know that
this will make this is different we're
using different assessments um but I
would really like to see that data that
happened and I also want you to know
that I am chair of the May ma Valley
School District so I'm glad to see that
may Val is um thank you very much Mar
Mac Valley was actually the first one to
sign of course they were CU Randy was a
math teacher
also um as far as the data from the past
uh we have had some challenges with
getting the past data we do have data
from one year somewhere in the middle
between the two that showed an increase
from 40 uh you know students would take
the acup Placer before the class and
then they would take the the accuplacer
after the test uh after the class and
their scores went from approximately 40%
to 70% on the exam and you know so there
was a very significant increase um as I
mentioned we're not going to be using
the accuplacer again so we will start
with data collection again this year um
although a lot of the you know if we
look nationally at the lawn shars
initiative and other things like that
they are already showing significant
Improvement ments in students abilities
not only in math classes but in other um
related classes as well because a lot of
what gets addressed in this course as
well is social emotional learning um you
know for example what I mentioned before
you know learning comes from making
mistakes and growing comfortable with
making mistakes and that that's
something that's um transcends
mathematics yes representative fellas um
can you just clarify the dates because
as you said it started back in 2006 but
then something happened and when did it
start up again and also do you can you
tell me anything about how many teachers
have been participating in this sure so
um the original program um the first
granted that they received was in 2006
those um and there were three or four
different grants that it um fell under
over the years 2017 is the last year
that it ran before the program um kind
of fell apart and as far as the number
of teachers participating um that is
kind of a rolling number at this point
so just to give you some examples um
last August when we um put out the
conference
we literally came to the idea that even
though the program hadn't launched yet
we wanted to get a lot of feedback from
teachers and be able to get their
thoughts on what we were doing so we
gave them three weeks notice in July to
say we're offering this conference in
August and we had 30 teachers come um
and that was the conference was free but
they had no expectation of getting paid
for that they were just passionate
teachers interested in hearing about
what the next thing was going to be so
that was um 30 teachers and they
represented um oh sorry 48 teachers
representing 30 high schools so that's
that was a significant number to CH to
choose to attend we also continue to
have monthly we call them Community
conversations where we're just talking
with teachers about the program allowing
them opportunities to talk with each
other about what's going on in their
schools and what they need help with
that helps to in us to inform us of
what's going on we are we are starting
to plan for this Summer's conference
which will be only for teachers in the
program and we already have 60 teachers
signed up with the the schools that have
signed their contracts
we have told this the schools that are
not going to start programs until fall
of 26 that if they sign the memorandums
before this they will also be invited to
this conference um you know the more
teachers we can expose to this type of
teaching the
better representative
Burton thank thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my
question excuse me um the accuplacer was
required by federal law for quite a
while to prove your students were
eligible for Aid um and they used to
show up in my office in June wanting to
graduate but they hadn't done the math
requirement um we went to a
computer-based uh Learning System where
a student only had to learn what they
were deficient in and and we did away
with classrooms and we had a math lab
with three faculty members there so
every student was on a different track
depending because they'd get bored if
they had to go back and take geometry if
they already knew
it um do you use that kind of software
in this program to individualize the
training for every
student um we we don't in this program
um they do in some of the community
college courses however in this program
because they're going to have the
opportunity to take that dual enrollment
statistics course um at in their second
year many students are going to find
that if they go on to college a lot of
majors in college only require one Math
course as to complete their program and
so a lot of students who are in this
program who do decide to go on to
college in non- stem careers are going
to find that they no longer will have to
take a math course at at the college
level because they'll have completed
this college level course in high
school just a quick followup I I know
it's complicated because some Majors did
not re
the Proficiency in math that others did
so it was a very
individualistic uh
process yeah it and it does it works
very effectively at the college level
high schools are not usually set up to
have access to or or you know to
purchase those um products which are
often tied with the textbooks that the
colleges are Contracting to purchase so
um and at the high school level
especially the types of students for
this type of program that type of
Independent Learning and independent
testing is not necessarily something
that they're
um proficient in yet they haven't quite
reached a maturity level that somebody
who's going into a college might to be
able to do that thank you very much
thank
you do we have any further questions
okay well thank you to both our
Witnesses I'm going to oh we do okay
representative Earth uh thank you Mr
chair and thank question getting back to
the metrics uh discussion previously
could you expound a little bit on what
you described here as a summary of
database student achievement and growth
in terms of specific metrics that you
would Envision reporting back to us sure
so you know starting this fall when we
launch for the first time at the end of
August when Schools go back to um go
back to session there is going to be an
initial assessment of some sort uh
actually there will be multiple
assessments um as we go into this so one
might be um more of a test based type
assessment but then we'll also be
looking back at data from student school
records previous scores of classes um
previous levels that they've taken Etc
and then as we go on through the program
um there will be one thing that we're
doing this time that's different from
last time too is we are the curriculum
that we're using is much more
standardized the teachers regardless of
which high school they're in will be
using the same um it's called an open
educational resource it's an online
textbook they'll be using those same
textbooks they'll have access to the
same projects Etc and as part of this
program what we'll be doing from a
program assessment perspective is
filtering in through their standard
assessments for their High School grades
specific questions designed to assess
whether the program is actually
succeeding in in helping students Master
the the learning objectives that we've
defined so rather than just a a solid
test at the beginning solid test at the
end and let's see what the difference is
going to be we're going to be assessing
throughout the process um to be able to
make whatever changes we need to as we
go as well as to give the students the
best opportunity possible to demonstrate
what they understand um that's really
important rather than doing a unitby
unit assessment some students may not
have mastered something at the end of t
test one but by the end of test two even
though a topic was from a previous unit
that was something that was necessary to
understand the second unit and now
they've mastered that um that's really
kind of how learning takes place in with
people not just here's a chunk this is
your one chance to show you learned it
now here's another chance but it's for a
different Chunk we can't go back and see
that you've Advanced your
knowledge does that help thank you
all right thank you very much and uh
with that I'm going to close the hearing
on HP 494
okay I I see we have the university
system here as well for the next one so
let's uh get on to it uh the next bill
is HP
510 uh that's a bill which is going to
be introduced by representative
Lynn from across the hallway welcome
representative
Lynn and let me read off what 510 is all
about here uh 510 is a bill and act rela
to establishing certain due process
rights for students student
organizations and faculty members facing
discplinary actions by state
institutions of Higher Learning welcome
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee that's my pleasure to be here
uh my name is Bob Lynn I'm a
representative from Rockingham District
17 uh which is the town of Windam and I
appear here in support of this bill um
for those of you who uh are not freshman
uh you may recall that this bill passed
the house last year uh but died in the
Senate U from speaking with uh one of
the Senators who uh was was uh heavily
involved with this bill in the Senate my
understanding was uh that there were two
issues that particularly troubled U the
Senate um one is you may recall that
there was language in last year's bill
which I've specifically have taken out
of this year's Bill uh to the effect uh
that I I can't quote the language
exactly but it basically said that if
there is a criminal
proceeding that uh is instituted against
a student or a faculty member um the the
the process of internal discipline which
this bill deals with would be held in
abeyance until the criminal proceeding
was over I should indicate that that was
not something that was in my the
original draft of the bill that I
presented last time but it was the
education committee at the time that
added that um and you know I said I
could live with it I didn't uh I didn't
particularly think it was absolutely
important but the committee did and that
was one of the things that the that the
uh the U Senate apparently was was
concerned about um that that could mean
that intern disciplinary proceedings at
the University or the community college
system would have could have to be hel
you know held in OB bance for a very
long period of time if a criminal case
uh got delayed for some reason or other
and that I think that was a legitimate
point I took that out in this bill the
other uh thing and perhaps even more
substantial that I understood the senate
had a question about or trouble with
last year was
um dealing particularly with with the
application of this bill to faculty me
members um the argument was as I
understood it well we have collective
bargaining agreements in effect with
many faculty with many uh faculty
members who are represented by unions
and this bill is inconsistent with that
and it'll cause all kinds of collective
bargaining uh agreement problems
um let's accept I'm not sure that I
actually believe that that was true but
let's accept that that was true um I in
ever in an effort to alleviate that
issue I you'll notice that in this bill
in uh what is proposed as RSA 188 K5 it
has specific language that says if
there's an existing collective
bargaining agreement that's in effect um
that you know covers uh these kind of
proceedings then you can continue to use
that process um until that collective
bargaining agreement expires you can't
extend the the the collective bargaining
agreement as to this subject matter uh
and you can't have a new one that's
inconsistent with this but if there's an
existing one that's in effect fine let's
uh you can do that I hope what what the
the important point that I want to make
on this and I'm trying to anticipate
what I suspect some of the objections to
this may be from some later witnesses as
you consider this bill I hope that the
first first thing that you will ask
yourself is to look at section K3 on
page
two and go through the
rights in subsections 1 a through J and
as you look at those I hope that you
will ask yourself which one of these
rights do I think we shouldn't have
which one of these rights is unfair is
is uh is is something that uh some who
is Accu whether it's a faculty member or
student who's accused of something for
which they could be suspended remember
this doesn't apply I should also note
that at one point the this this uh Bill
had talked about it covering simple
reprimands and there was I think a
legitimate objection last year that that
was too that was too that went too far
it should have to be at least
suspensions or expulsions and that's the
way the spill is now worded it applies
only to something that is serious enough
that a student would be suspended or
expelled but if you have that situation
which of the rights in the that are that
are created by this bill should should a
student not have which one is too
much and I submit to you that none of
them are that they are all sort of basic
fundamental rights that anyone who is
accused of something for which they
could be suspended or removed from
school should have
and you know there was a there's a
question so you may ask yourself well
why do we need
this well one of the reasons we need
this and I I think you know this is hard
frankly for me to imagine but it's
absolutely
true in the Obama
Administration and then it was reversed
by the Trump admin first Trump
Administration but rein reinstituted or
at least tried to be reinstituted um in
the last Administration the Biden admin
ation the message was sent out in the
form of either regulations or quote
unquote guidance which uh was done in an
effort to uh avoid the idea of having a
formal regulation that might be
challenged that you you shouldn't give
students these rights you you you
schools universities you shouldn't be
too Fair it's okay to to throw somebody
out on you know less than a fair process
imagine that imagine the government
saying that that's that's that you
should do that and then if by the way if
you don't do that you are at least at
risk of losing Federal funding I me can
you just imagine that don't be too fair
to students that are accused of of of
wrongdoing or you might risk Federal
funding as a result of as a result of
this that's why a number of states and I
think an increasing number have adopted
legislation like this now one of the
things that I suspect you will
hear from some of the other people
that'll testify here are everything's
working fine there's no problem in our
in you know with the disciplinary
process we have in place
now so I would ask you again as you
analyze that question then ask
yourself which of the rights that I said
before that this bill gives is is not
important so that if they say their
disciplinary system is working just
fine does it have all of these rights or
doesn't it one of the things that I
never heard and I don't know whether
this whether the Senate heard this or
not or maybe the your your committee did
but one of the things I never heard was
I heard I heard the statement we have
disciplinary procedures in in place and
they're fine they you know they they're
fair and all this and that I never heard
and I don't know know whether this
committee ever received the details of
exactly what are their disciplinary
procedures and how do they differ from
this and one of the things that I think
you ought to really be care be very much
asking yourself is you'll notice the
fiscal note on this bill talks about you
know five maybe it's going to be
$500,000 or something to uh they need
three more people to implement this um
and I have to say if
you know it seems to me you can't have
it both ways you can't say that look our
procedures are just fine and they're
very fair and there's and there's you
know there's really no problem here on
the one hand but on the other hand if
you want to implement these
procedures and again if you think that
some of the procedures are too fair I
guess that's you know that's for you but
if you want to implement these
procedures it's going to cost this much
more if that's true I submit that that
suggests that their procedures are
really very different the existing
procedures are really very different
from the procedures established by this
bill um and that's why it's going to
cost so much money and if they are
really that different ask yourself what
are you know what what are those
procedures um one of the things that you
that you I I remember being said last
year was um well what are the complaints
you know do you have do you have
evidence can you say you know here's the
evidence of all the proceed of all the
students that were treated unfairly and
I and I had to say I have I have gotten
one or two you know sort of anecdotal
things about about people that that uh
felt they were treated unfairly or
parents that felt that students were
treated unfairly but you know candidly
it's I I I'm not in a position to
investigate those I don't know whether
those are true or not or whether they're
you know there somebody's complaining
because that they were they had they had
a fair procedure and they just didn't
they were they came out on the losing
end of it I don't know the answer to
that but one of the things that I that I
I think is very important that this
committee consider an analyzing that
issue is some of
these stop and think about the the
motivation somebody has even if they
felt that they were treated unfairly not
to come forward for example suppose you
are somebody that um was accused of
let's say a sexual assault of another
student and there's some procedure um
and you don't think that you were
treated fairly and you think that there
was some some result that was uh that
was not you know not fair to you well
you might say you know maybe you're
maybe you're brave enough to come
forward and say I'm you know I I protest
this or maybe you think geez you know uh
um I don't want to I don't want to you
know sort of go public with with this
with this problem even though I do feel
that I that I was treated unfairly so I
guess what I'm saying is I'm not sure
that public complaints are something
that um is should be the be all and end
all again what I would go back to
is do you think that the procedures that
are outlined here are unfair or are
unduly
burdensome um to to you know to
basically give students the the kind of
basic due process rights notice an
opportunity to be heard a fair decision
maker um uh those kind of things this
this doesn't turn this in any way into a
criminal trial the burden of proof is
the burden of proof that would apply in
any civil proceeding um I included
you'll notice I included a provision
although there's a a presumption of of
Innocence which I think is should should
apply in any proceeding like this there
is a provision that says that you
can an accused person can invoke their
right not to testify in their own
defense if they want to that you know
the what would be considered the right
against self-incrimination but because
these are civil proceedings generally
the law in civil proceedings is that yes
you can invoke your
right U against self-incrimination but
in a civil proceeding the FactFinder may
take that may draw an inference from the
fact that you've invoked your right to
um to uh not to test invoke May invoke
an inference against you and so I've you
know I've had that had that in here in
summary I really I believe first of all
that I'm very skeptical about the cost
estimates here and I know that's
something that finance will look for if
this committee passes the bill but I'm
very skeptical about that in the first
place but secondly if it's really true
if it really is true that they need you
know that they need to hire all these
additional people to implement what are
basically Fair
procedures that should be of a great
concern to this committee about exactly
what are the procedures that are
happening now and and also bear in mind
that this bill specifically says that
students or faculty members whoever the
accused is is free to wave the pro the
protections of this bill as long as they
do so knowingly and voluntarily so if
the you know if the procedures are they
have in place and I hope you'll ask ask
them to specify in detail what those
procedures are but if the procedures
they have in place really are basically
Fair procedures I wouldn't students wave
them why wouldn't they say fine I
suggest to you that that the the reason
that you know the logical reason why
they wouldn't want to wave them because
this will this will you know if a
student really wants to insist on
everything that's in here they'll they
have a right to an advisor uh or an
attorney but they don't get the attorney
for free um so if you know a student was
going to end up having some teeth or
some money in the game why would they do
that if the if the existing procedures
are basically fair I suggest that you
know is again something to to really ask
yourself as you think about whether this
bill is appropriate or not I'm happy to
take questions thank you very much
representative Lynn are there any
questions from the committee yes
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative for
taking my question if we're talking here
about fundamental rights shouldn't they
apply to all colleges and universities
and not just public
ones well I think the the problem would
be if private um you know the
Constitution doesn't generally um
regulate private activity so if it's a
if it's a if a private college
um private Co I guess maybe the bluntest
way to put it is private colleges can't
violate your constitutional rights
because it's the the Constitution
applies against the government um so
that I think that's yes you may thank
you well we have some institutions like
the human rights uh commission which
apply to all employment not just you
know apply rights for all employment is
that only because there's specific kinds
of rights in the
Constitution that are different than
these
rights well no we in other words we have
um in for example this you know the
Human Rights Act we have listed certain
kinds of discrimination based I mean
basically you know racial sexual uh
sexual orientation those kind of things
whereas this um is is sort of a general
due process right I um that that applies
against the government I I mean I
suppose
well I don't I mean I guess there would
be a question of whether we would have
the
authority um the power to um require
private
institutions uh to adopt these kind of
procedures and you know I I I don't know
the I'm not sure I I I really want to
think very carefully about it I'm not
sure that we that the state would have
the authority um to do
that thank you representative uh
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question so if I understood you
correctly you informed us that you're
only aware of a couple of anecdotal
cases that would have been handled
differently if this statute If This Were
statute
and it doesn't sound like you're clear
on what the current policies and
procedures at the University or
Community College systems
are so I'm wondering if you could share
what
initiated why you think there's Merit
for this to go forward in the absence of
understanding what happens presently BEC
well I guess what I would say is the
when I was speaking before I was
speaking about my my own personal
knowledge and things that have happened
in New Hampshire my understanding um
from from you know from a number of
different sources is is that this you
know there have been um sort of uh
horrendous situations in other states
involving some given publicity some not
I can't sort of recall specifics of any
offand but that there were a number of
uh instances around the country um of
relatively publicized instances of you
know of uh processes that weren't fair
and again as I understand it and I I
have to be careful because I'm not
positive on exactly how far the decision
went but I I I understand that there was
a um uh to the extent that the Biden
administration had sort of reimplemented
the title 9 that at least a one Court in
Kentucky I believe had enjoined the uh
had enjoined the enforcement now whether
that applied across the board or was
limited to the sort of transgender issue
I'm not I'm frankly not positive on that
but I think I guess what I'm saying is I
you know the the motivation for this
bill was what what I regarded as really
a very
unfair procedure by initially the Biden
Administration and and then later the B
I mean initially the Obama
Administration and then later the Biden
Administration
quickly thank you could you share with
the committee either now or as a
follow-up
communication the specifics of the
regulations from the Obama and Biden
administrations that you're referencing
uh I I mean I I suppose I could but I
think the committee is in as well as
good a position to do that as I am it's
as I understand it's Title 9 uh Title
Nine regulations uh uh of uh I think
it's the Education Act amendments so I
I'm I mean
you know I I I could find it but I think
you're probably in as good a position as
as me to find I just wanted to be clear
what you were referencing F further
questions represent
hean thank you for bringing this forward
and thank you Mr chairman um and thank
you for your clarity as well I just am
very curious uh has thought been given
to extending these rights specifically
also to high schools and to public
employees in the high schools and the
public schools
um to be to be completely candid with
you I had not you know that was not
something that I thought of as I uh
drafted this whether that would be um a
good idea or not
um uh I guess I'd want some more time to
think about this but I certainly
wouldn't I wouldn't you know dismiss it
out of hand for
sure where the questions represent
Ames this really is a follow on from
representative Damon line of questioning
um youve you spoke of I think adding or
changing the uh 188 K5 provision
relating to collective bargaining
agreements and um that uh leads me to
ask what is in those agreements that you
know of that uh would be allowed to
continue and then would
expire naturally at the end of the term
limit is stated in the agreement that uh
that may differ from what's in
this you know I mean that that is an
excellent question and as I said I from
I don't know the answer to that question
and from
the evidence that was presented at the
hearing last year and I maybe something
will be presented differently this year
I know there are representatives from
the University system and the community
college system here
my recollection of the testimony last
year was General statements from those
Representatives that we have procedures
in effect that are fair procedures and
that everybody's happy with them what
exactly those procedures
were um it was never stated so I don't
know exactly what those procedures were
um but as I said I when they say it's
going to cost $500,000 to implement
these procedures that suggests to me
that whatever their procedures are they
must be quite different than what I
think are sort of the basic fairness
procedures that are specified in this
bill okay thank you yes representative
Burton excuse me uh thank you for taking
thank you for the question um as having
been a Dean a couple of times and
president of two
colleges my general impression is you're
looking for a
solution uh trying to find a problem
that needs a solution all of the schools
I know of and in higher education have
really
tight processes that to to protect the
students and the institution in a unique
situation where if someone commits a
crime in a dormatory they're going back
into
you have to count for the setting the
students in anyway um can you site any
any kind of problem that has
happened that caus you to believe you
should impose a state law on the
institutions who now are required to
already have uh processes in place and
and I sure if you wanted to see them
they would send them to you um and
that's why I'm concerned about adding a
third third party to a process that's
already in existent already proven and
has tested past the test of
times well I guess the way I would
respond to that you know was again if
you're asking me to site to you some the
details of some specific case no I I
cannot do that um but what I guess I
would say
is you've said they already have
procedures in a place that are you know
that are just working fine how do those
procedures from this what I mean don't
you don't get adequate notice or you do
get adequate notice and if you do then
then the change caus then then there
really is no
change uh proposed by this bill if you
have the presumption of innocence under
the practices that you're talking about
that exist then there is no change on
the other hand if you don't then there
is and I would submit there should be Mr
chairman that followup um i s I can
assure you that any institution you
requested that information from would
provide it including the University of
New Hampshire um and again I get I I get
concerned what are you talking
about is it
a anyway thank you for your thank you
for taking my question he remember we
got to be ask specific questions here uh
further questions from the
committee yes representative
Brown thank you for coming today
um as an educator a college professor um
is a college professor of overp decades
I've seen numerous examples of cases
where faculty have suffered um
discrimination um and problems with
their basic rights at college campuses
so I can think of specific cases where
this has been an issue but my question
is um concerning part two faculty
members where you say that faculty
member will not include um someone who
has has a probationary status because
probationary faculty in my experience
have been the most vulnerable of Staff
when it comes to particular abuses of
rights as they're attempting to get
tenure at
colleges well I
mean you you raise a a valid point and I
have to say I uh
um I put that in there because I guess I
generally thought that you know it's
it's it it's it's not unusual for new
employees to have
less you know to have less rights so to
speak than than somebody who's been
there for a while but you know if if
you're suggesting that that should be
changed so that it should apply to new
employees I'm you get you get no
objection from me I think
that fair I I I favor fairness rather
than unfairness uh every time thank you
further questions representa spillsbury
um I'm just curious because I read that
phrase differently you're talking about
probationary status as somebody who's
new during maybe a 90day exactly that's
what I had in mind whereas whereas I had
read it to refer to somebody who's
already had a problem and was placed on
probation yeah yeah
I you know no you raise you raise a a a
valid point that I had I had not
intended it that way but you raise a
valid point and I would suggest that
maybe you know an amendment to make that
very clear that the somebody who's who
has been employed for less than 90 days
or what six months or whatever it might
be but that that's a very valid point I
I did not mean it to be somebody that
was already disciplined yeah good point
further questions we do have more people
coming up but you
represent fellows you have a
question so I just on on the last page
at the end of K uh four it says that the
organization can't um do something that
gives the dis the person being dis
disciplined um less protections right
but then in the next section down below
which I assume means that that they can
the institution can give them more
exactly but when you get down to five it
says after the end of the collective
bargaining agreement they have to use
the ones in this statute no it says
which contains grievance procedures
grievance or disciplinary procedures
less protective of fact they cannot have
they cannot adopt grievance or
disciplinary procedures that are less
protective than the ones in the statute
they could certainly understand but in
in five it says when they when there's a
conflict what are supposed to do are
aren't they supposed to adopt the ones
in this
statute no I think what it says is you
can't that you that they cannot adopt
from an let me read the last sentence
from and after the effective date of
this chapter no institution of higher
education and no Union representing
faculty members of such institution
shall enter into any new collective
bargaining agreement nor extend the
expiration date of an existing
collective bargaining agreement which
contains grievance procedures grievance
or disciplinary procedures less
protective of Faculty members do process
rights than those established in this
chapter so they can they can have they
can
adopt procedures that Grant more
protection okay thank you but not less
good further
questions thank you very much
representative thank you the next card
is from uh the university system New
Hampshire Lauren banker and Katherine
prenter good afternoon Mr chair um
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Katherine preventure I
serve as the chancellor of our state's
uh University system with me is Lauren
Banger she's um joining me she's the
senior director for government relations
for the University system um appreciate
your time this afternoon um
representative Lynn is correct that the
university system opposes this
legislation um we are happy to provide
any oh sure is that better okay we are
happy to provide any processed documents
we have eight different collective
bargaining agreements with um faculty
across the university system to provide
you with the procedures uh enumerated in
those collective bargaining agreements
each of our institutions has a variety
of policies governing due process we're
proud of the ample due process that we
have across the university system um I
will speak to representative Lynn's uh
comment around added cost when we we
were asked to complete the ls the fiscal
note for the LSR the word reprimand was
still in the language and I will get to
cost in a minute but that the the
original language included that there
would be Provisions for hearings and
documentation and
cross-examination even for a reprimand
and that would
absolutely we would absolutely incur
quite a bit of additional cost if we
were going to go through procedures for
for a
reprimand um I will say
that um there's there's no such thing as
cost-free regulation you're going to
hear me say that probably for a number
of bills that are coming before um your
committee this session at a time when we
must reduce our cost structure across
the university system with fiscal
challenges as well as state budget
challenges um we do not want to add any
administrative compliance
regulatory action um to the work that
we're doing we I as I mentioned uh we do
have extensive due process procedures
that that work for each of our
institutions and we're happy to provide
you those uh copies of I think we did
last session but maybe we maybe we did
that when the bill got to the Senate um
and we're concerned with a kind of
one-size fits-all rigid process um
rather than have
institutions and the various faculty uh
unions develop those those procedures
and and also the
student I know with the um our
fraternity and sorority councils they
have due process guidelines in place as
well and they may vary from institution
to institution um
we we have specific examples we can get
into um Lauren can walk through some of
our specific concerns um we we are not
aware of any problems inherent in our
due process framework now and um but we
do believe there would be some
additional cost to have a hearing a
hearing for um all the copies of all the
documentation and interviews um it it
could be there could be legal costs on
the University system side as well as
for students faculty and student
organizations and I'll say on you know
when it comes to cost even if it's
$100,000 that's net tuition fees for 10
New Hampshire students so I I'm trying
to boil everything down to what um a
student impact is and I um I would agree
with representative Burton Burton's
comment
that this may be a solution searching
for a problem that will add some
administrative burden and and cost to
our work um I if you want uh Kathy are
you going to take a question before you
pass the wand on here or the Baton
certainly um I do have a question here
I'm looking at the last sheet which is
the financial that You' predicted or
proposed that this may cost three
additional staff to manage increased
workload if in fact much of what you're
doing is done informally right
now can you explain to me why three
additional people to manage a program
like this which is going to be dealing
with procedures that representative Lynn
spoke to um thank you for the question
representative again when when we
completed did the fiscal note the word
reprimand okay was still in the um in
the LSR um so I don't know that we would
need three additional people with the
reprimand
excluded but again I do not believe the
cost would be
zero okay thank
you represent papic is it for yes
related if I may just additional
clarification since the fiscal note is
based on a version of the bill that's no
longer here do you know whether we can
get an updated fiscal note at least
before we get to finance because
obviously we need to work with the best
data possible thank you Mr chair and I
would say prior to yeah this committee
also needs that fiscal
note yeah yes okay La Lauren or can go
both ways to both
people you want to ask Kathy prenta
right now or do you want to wait and ask
the question when we really get into
that it's up to you sir I can do let's
go on Lauren's here let's let's get
let's Lauren Baker banker and then we
will get to you first question thank you
Mr chair uh thank you members of the
committee um as Kathy said I just wanted
to walk through a few of the pieces of
the bill that we have um several issues
with um I've outlined them in the
testimony but I'm going to just um pick
a few to to call out um at this hearing
so the first being if pass this bill
would require copies of all written
documents statements of witnesses
photographs to be provided at least
7even days prior to the um hearing we
are concerned with this provision um
because it's very possible that these
documents could contain intimate details
of you know sexual misconduct or in the
case of Faculty private personal files
Title 9 standard says that you're
provided access to review documents but
not provided actual copies so we're
cautious on this believing that once the
possession of these sensitive materials
is out of our hands um it could have
serious privacy concerns for folks um
the other point that we raised here too
is um connected to the confront and
cross-examine witness um piece of
language in the bill um it says uh that
uh folks are provided the right to
confront and cross-examine Witnesses who
provide evidence against the student
student organization or faculty member
current Title 9 allows for cross-
examination but it must be done by an
advisor so we feel with the bill as
written you know we could have a student
accused of sexual assault directly
confronting and questioning the impact
of parties with victim Survivor in this
case um and we really think we could see
a chilling effect on this and the
likelihood of future parties bringing
reports participating in this sort of
resolution process um the final thing I
wanted to raise also has to do with a
confront and cross-examine piece um so
this would this would be permitted um
for any person to do against anyone um
who is uh providing evidence against the
student student organization or faculty
member so we see a costly solution with
this and you know the time that would
need to be done is you know for every
underage student who might be caught
drinking would they would we be required
to call upon each police officer who
made the arrest for
cross-examining um and you know our
current
uh resolution for that is you know if
it's a student's first offense they're
given warning they're required to
complete a mandatory alcohol and drug
education counseling course but an
extensive disciplinary hearing where we
bring in Witnesses um would be deemed
costly and
unnecessary those are the few that I
wanted to raise and I'll pass it back to
Kathy and we can answer questions okay
repon B you had a question yes um there
was an incident at UNH in June I'm very
familiar with where students protested
that
violence in
Gaza um I was really impressed with the
way uh president Chilton who came in
after the
event made sure that all of the students
involved were given due
process uh for that it was a very
complicated system but I I must say and
I I wrote the resolution in the Town
Council uh expressing concerns about
that and and because the town was
involved but I was really impressed with
not only the way the structure of your
current policies worked to make sure
that the students got due process but
with the results as well but she even
went beyond that she formed a a
committee in of towns people and others
to make sure that due process was
followed and now there's a report as
you've seen it I'm sure and you have too
um as I have that outlines
um what happened and what the situation
was and how we might look at it and so
forth but my impression was that this
was a serious test of your due process
structure and and it it is survived and
it was in place and it was utilized am I
right in
that yes
representative for the questions
representative uh spb and then represent
luno then represent
papovich so there's an extensive list of
Rights they they tend to mimic uh the
fifth and sixth amendment protections as
interpreted by the Supreme
Court you've specifically identified
ways in which you think B on the
document
sharing and uh D on on excuse me and E
on
cross-examination might go a little too
far if we if we were to examine what
that problem is and make an amendment
that limited that language would that
overcome all of your objections or do
you have any objection to any of the
other rights listed
here representative I I don't h i don't
take exception to B folks having basic
rights we I I'm confident that our due
process framework allows for that um but
I mean specifically as articulated in
this bill would that alleviate your
objection to the
bill I would have to as has as has been
requested need to revisit the fiscal
note but I have to think about that
representa spillsbury what what's any
additional
cost and I would take a objection so let
I need to think
about the cost versus
the changes to the
language okay uh represent
luno thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you very much for taking um taking
a question um how do your um actually um
representative Lynn um referred to your
your current um policies several times
during his bill introduction and I was
wondering if you could uh talk to us a
little bit about how your current um
policies and practices work when there's
an imbalance of power between the um um
the the the parties you know allegedly
involved um in this and and for an
example of a imbalance and power you
know think like faculty and
student so with me this afternoon is
the University Systems general counsel
Chad pimel this is exactly why I asked
him to join because he knows the
specifics of the various policies and
practices we have I'm happy to say this
for for attorney P well yeah I'd like to
hear from Chad too um somewhere along
the way on
this at the end okay great thank you uh
represent papovich had was next then
represent
Mr chair in the order in the interest of
Saving Time could I point out that I
have two very quick questions on two
different paragraphs and that's all I
have I I don't want to create the
impression that I'm trying to get
additional questions here the first
question is on your um first page or
saying that the title 9 standard states
that you may be provided access but not
the actual copies obviously Title 9 has
35 words none of which says that would
you be so kind and share with the
committee later after the the
testimonies over the specific part of
the title 9 guidelines or regulations
that are changing every time the
presidential office changes hands and
would you also be so kind when you do
that tell me whether that interpretation
is consistent or is it something that
changes every time when the you know
depending on the party that has the
presidential office because we have at
least 12 years of history between the
last three presidencies and my
recollection is that the guidelines were
extremely different so this is more of a
please follow up with a committee
question the other question I have and
that's again very short in the next
paragraph top of the second page of your
testimony there is concern about
students accused of sexual assault could
directly confront and question the
impacted party victim
Survivor there should be a presumption
of innocence right I would have expected
to see the alleged victim or Survivor
that language seems to imply to me a
very lack of presumption of innocence
when we are saying that before anything
has been adjudicated somebody's already
a purp and somebody's already a victim I
would just again like you to think
about the testimony you put here and the
impression it causes on the committee
because you know those are allegations
they are very serious allegation that
should be investigated it doesn't mean
that we stop stop taking any measures
until guilt has been established but
again that language seems to be a bit U
presuming that facts have already been
established at the time when it hasn't
so thank you repat I would appreciate it
thank you mire thank you Mr chairman
thank you um Chancellor um how roughly
how many um disciplinary proceedings
that are more than just somebody having
a conversation with some official uh
take place annually in these three
categories students student organization
and faculty
member I'll have to get back to you
representative and I will and maybe a
little historical numbers certainly yeah
thank
you I I do have one question I'd like to
follow up on uh or it's a new area um I
went through years ago when I first got
in here dealing with situations
occurring at another large private
school in the
state um and we had work with the county
attorney on that uh when do you because
you have a police force with Jim Dean on
campus when does an
accusation or where we get into this
business of due process
rights when does local Authority being
Jim Dean or maybe the Durham Police get
involved or notified we have something
going on
here representative I think that would
likely depend on the situation certainly
if we think it's something somebody's
ilal I'll take a light one they're drunk
and they're un
underage the unpd would be
called and just just for your your own
information all of the authority of the
UNH Police Department flows from the
town Durham yes Police
Department because that would be
illegal an underage someone's drinking
underage so the UN police would likely
be called some somebody would call them
that that um there are due process
policies and procedures but in as Lauren
mentioned in all likelihood if it's
their first offense there would be a
warning and the student would be asked
to attend um some alcohol and drug so
followup question so are there two sets
of laws here one for the person that
lives in Durham that's not a student at
UNH the UNH student then has a hearing
before the college with controlled by
the college but the other person's going
to have to have that hearing through
civil
Authority that's
right the you I don't believe the UNH
police department has authority to
arrest Durham residents yeah
okay represent Mahan yeah I just want a
clarification on the bottom paragraph on
page two in your testimony you say
specifically it would require a full
trial and appeal process and yet on um
on paragraph five the first paragraph on
the top of page two in the law itself it
says in all disciplinary proceedings
against a student student organization
or faculty member they shall be entitled
to to a hearing are you suggesting that
being entitled to a hearing is a
requirement
no okay can you
explain as representative Lyn mentioned
um a student student organization or
faculty member could wave their their um
right to a hearing yes but I'm just
trying to clarify why you said it would
be a requirement that there would be
like a full Pro full tra process I'm
sorry just
follow I'm sorry representative could
you on the bottom of page two in your
testimony okay thank you Mr chairman on
the on the bottom of page two in your
thing you say specifically it's the
fourth line down you say specifically it
would require a full Tri trial and I'm
just wondering where that requirement is
seen in the
law Chad do you want to add something on
that no you're right representative I'd
say it it could it it doesn't require
you're absolutely right my apologies
thank you it raises the possibility I
think you yes thank
you can I just put one caveat on that
representative if you don't mind by the
way my my name is Chad Pento I'm the
general councel for the University
system sorry for parachuting in um the
the question that arose in our minds
about whether it was required or not is
if you look uh in K3 Roman 2 um at the
very bottom of page two says the
procedural rights including the hearing
specified above shall be afforded prior
to the imposition of discipline now
there's also waiver language how you
read that together with the you're
entitled but not required it's a
question but it does say shall be
afforded prior to any discipline being
imposed thank you are there further
questions of the University system yes
represent L thank you Mr chair I'd like
to go back to um the question I raised
earlier about how your um your current
uh policies and practices uh work in in
situations particularly where you've got
an imbalance of power such as with a
faculty and student um situation sure so
it's probably easier if I work with a
specific hypothetical so can I propose
one you'll tell me whether it makes
sense all right absolutely because the
last hypothetical we heard last year or
two years ago in this bill was um was uh
uh a couple of fraternity Brothers
drinking Bud Light outside their
fraternity so I'd love to hear more you
know something more at some St sure so
so to the extent that we have something
serious like a a student uh making an
allegation of U sexual assault against a
faculty member um it would move over
under over multiple tracks at once um
the the respon the initial response
would be governed largely by the federal
title n regulations because that's what
we're obligated to do um currently
what's in force is the 2020 regulations
that the Trump Administration
promulgated um as representative Lyn
sort of highlighted there is a an order
that came out of district court and in
Kentucky that said the Biden's attempted
regulations have no Force so the current
state of play is that the Trump
administration's regulations are in
effect we're sort of assuming that the
Trump Administration is not going to
appeal that ruling such that the 2020
regulations are going to remain in
effect um for the foreseeable future um
those are complicated they provide for a
lot of um initial sort of what call
supportive measures for the student to
make sure that they minimize contact
with that faculty member to make sure
they have the academic support they need
to progress through class um there's an
investigation and a sort of a report a
factual report that's created by the the
Title Nine um coordinator and the folks
who work for them um that report then
goes out and feeds into if there's a
finding of yes we think there was a
problem here into the faculty discipline
process and the faculty discipline
process is a little different because
it's governed by by cbas but let's for
this again just for to pick a
hypothetical let's say 10e faculty
member at the University of New
Hampshire um the next place that report
goes if the administration wants to
proceed is to a fac a committee made up
of Faculty members because the
university has shared governance and it
means that the faculty are meant to have
a voice and so the question of whether
or not the faculty member ought to be um
suspended terminated whatnot goes to
this faculty committee there is an a
purposefully informal hearing where the
faculty U hears information and
basically expresses its Viewpoint to the
university president as to whether or
not there should be discipline post um
the University president then makes that
decision as to whether there should be a
termination should happen the faculty
member in the union then have the right
to grieve that and if the grievance goes
all the way it ends up in front of
arbitration in front of a neutral
arbitrator in i i the last one took six
days
um so a a a very fome arbitration
process um so that's how it it is sort
of handled now um I I think one area
where that differs from how we
understand it would work under this bill
is this process of very informal
opportunity for the faculty to chime in
decision grieve if you don't like it all
the way to arbitration gets replaced
with in every instance we have
internally first this full hearing um
and that is increased staff time people
having to do other this about another
work that's increased lawyer time we
don't have an in-house trial lawyer
capacity um that's usually outside
Council and outside Council cost money
which is part of why we think there's
still going to be some dollars
associated with this if it goes forward
um and again this this that process
which is get internal to the university
there's at least some private
protections inherent in Title 9 UM this
faculty process is inherently sort of
again um you know informal such the
people might be more comfortable
participating um the arbitration is what
the arbitration is if it goes that far
but that gets replaced with a process
that is more formal more costly and we
were read less privacy protective than
the one we have now thank you any
further
questions not seeing any thank you very
much Mr chairman yeah I have a question
of you MH um this bill is very important
do you know when we'll be executing it
because I have no idea okay I'd like to
do some more research I I have a lot of
experience in that none of our bills
have been uh scheduled at all at this
point in time okay so there'll be plenty
of time to do the preliminary research
thank you although any bill it's an
early bill has a certain date out of
here is this an early
Bill yes yes this this is an early bill
but bet get get at
it yeah yeah that's march by the first
week of March has be out I was a
beneficiary personally of due process at
the University okay I have no other pink
cards on this one so this uh Committee
hearing is closed and we'll start the
next up at scheduled time of 1
o'clock
e
e e
minute here would everybody please take
your
seats
okay yeah
okay for the information of people on
the committee here this is one of those
days where some of us are going to end
up having to testify at the same time in
two different locations I have that
happening to me at
1:30 presenting a bill here presenting a
bill on housing so I'll be gone and uh
that's when we that occurs if there's a
co-sponsor around that can introduce it
for us that will occur there is a
co-sponsor of that bill 193 here on this
committee yes probably already done this
but in case you don't housing just
finished their first bill oh they just
finished they just finished
hp60 so that might influence your timing
yeah so I I'll go check it out when and
one there's my deal
okay so right now we have a situation
too where representative Moffett who is
presenting this bill has been engaged
elsewhere
and but here he is that's wonderful
isn't
it yeah I tell you these Lieutenant
Colonels can make it happen can't they
so at any rate um I'd like to open up
this hearing today for HB 112 requiring
students in the university and Community
College systems of Hampshire to pass the
United States citizenship and
Immigration Services Civics
naturalization test I'd like to welcome
the prime sponsor the bill
representative Moffet thank you Mr chair
yes I just uh introduced a measure
across the hall and I Sprint it over
here or I move quickly let's say thank
you for giving me a few extra moments
minutes so to get right to it for the
record uh I am representative Mike mfet
of marac 4 which includes the beautiful
towns of Canterbury in
uh hb12 is the same bill as HB 319 from
two terms ago which our legislature
passed and sent to the governor who
vetoed it and more later on that did did
you get one yes it's right here I was in
the Mr fig uh filling it out and it's
going to come okay that's fine represent
when when you're done make sure we get
one up from please
absolutely so uh HB 319 the the the same
bill that we passed asked earlier that
is uh now
hb12 uh was a bipartisan companion bill
to two terms ago to HB 320 which some of
you will remember 320 was the high
school Civics Assessment
bill and uh Governor sonono happily
signed that measure 320 the high school
Bill we even had a signing
ceremony now the high school bill
created a graduation requirement on the
secondary school
level um that students passed the 128
question
USCIS exam which immigrants need to
study on their Pathway to
citizenship uh feedback indicates that
uh 320 has been uh wildly successful to
use a term that's been used a lot lately
uh which in providing a solid Universal
Foundation of civics knowledge for every
student every single high school public
high school gradu
graduate in fact I just checked with my
niece Malia uh who grew up in Denmark
and she just took the test here in
conquer at conquer High School um she
got 126 out of
128 of course I asked her about it and I
said so how do the students feel about
that and they said they they W didn't
really like having a test requirement
until I took it and after they took it
they were glad they took it and believe
it or not they recommended that
everybody after them also takes it and
um no surprise there but I'll also say
that parents seem to love the
requirement that's in law now the Civics
testing requirement parents uh love
it the ones that we've heard from uh
very much for it so anyway hb12 today a
recent report
called America's knowledge crisis a
survey on Civic
literacy found frightening shortfalls in
student knowledge of history and how our
country
works a poll of over a thousand people
mostly college grads found 63% didn't
know the term Links of US senators I
could go on and on and on and on about
all the specific basic civics government
history knowledge that people don't have
college graduates do not have and that's
not okay some people don't care about
that or they're not bothered by it many
of us are I am that's why we're here
that's why I'm here it's not okay that
we're graduating uh so many most college
graduates who just don't know how our
country Works how our government works
who our people
are numerous other states this is
important to i chair a committee and I
always ask questions so what are other
states doing if if no other state has
ever done something that's significant
or if if most other states have done
something that's significant too and
I'll tell you that many other states
have implemented this very requirement
on their postsecondary
schools uh Florida Missouri lately
Christy gome just just recently signed
South Dakota's version of this bill so
this is something that many other states
are doing and Beyond the states there
are many private colleges who not in a
state perview who understand the need
for this Purdue
University universities like that now
have citizenship Civics various versions
sometimes is off an assessment so that
somebody who graduates from these
institutions people know okay they have
a some sense of how our country
Works uh some folks dismiss the test as
factoid It's Quickly forgotten I
disagree whether it's multiplication
tables or Anatomy or or this uh there's
things people need to learn and they
need to demonstrate it's why we give
driers tests it's why we have bar
examinations it's why we have Reg
Industries for nursing or Healthcare
people testing assessments I know some
people hate them I think they're
essential whatever the subject may be so
again why is it okay to promote the
climate awareness but not constitutional
awareness so back to two terms ago while
the high school Bill 320 sail through
through uh this legislature signed by
the governor became law the college
version 319
also
passed uh education committee the full
education I mean the full legisl the
full house uh but by much narrower
version there were people back then who
had were not comfortable necessarily
with applying the same requirement to
postsecondary that we did for secondary
and we address that so it passed the
house went to the senate senate
education heard it I introduced it and
they kill they voted unanimously to kill
it in Senate education okay so I met
with the Senators individually to see
why they were so spooked and they told
me it would be too expensive which was
misleading we talked about that and I
addressed that we addressed that the
sponsors did senators were also told it
was not the legislator's business to
promote such an assessment and we
thought oh
contr State legislatures not only have
the right this a Civics but the
responsibility to care about education
not just on the secondary level but post
secondary but well particularly public
post secondary so we talked to the
Senators about that the Senators are
also told that was uh you know teaching
to the test and again I I just touched
on that assessments are important I
spent a lot of time in education the
teaching to the test argument is often
made by folks who just aren't nuts about
accountability or assessments uh is I
said earlier uh the sponsors think
assessments are crucial uh the senator
were told it would set a dangerous
precedent but we talked about that and
the legislature routinely passes
measures that uh impact numerous aspects
of
postsecondary uh in the college version
again then and now was in intended to
cover gaps especially now the 320 is law
the high school bill is law Mo most high
school students uh all all all high
school grads have passed it so bottom
line uh we met with the Senators I met
with the Senators addressed all the
questions that had spooked them and then
they flipped uh good on them you know
they listen and they said we made a
mistake okay we should have passed this
and so they did so they had re-referred
it and then they special ordered it uh
319 the version identical version to
this it went to the full Senate and the
full Senate passed it so the sponsors
including myself broke out the champagne
L literally uh but then we get a message
from the governor uhoh uh clearly the
same misinformation as we saw it was
sent to that spook the Senators was sent
to the governor's office to spoke the
governor so we set up a meeting with the
governor uh had to reschedule it
postpone we set up another meeting with
the governor had to reschedule it
postpone so finally uh we did get into
the governor's office at his
invitation which is rare most people who
have bills vetoed uh they don't get to
the governor doesn't invite them in to
talk about it so we finally had the
meeting Senator Lang time representa
Lang accompanied me we had a wonderful
meeting with the governor and I we did
the same thing with the governor and we
did with the Senators and we addressed
all the things that it spoke the
governor who spoke the governor I don't
know probably the same folks who spoke
the Senators uh but the governor still
vetoed HP 319 and we found out later
that when the bill was enrolled the
clock started a lot of you know this
bill is enrolled you have a time limit
so because we had to postpone several
times our meeting with the governor uh
come to find out find out much later
that he'd already made a decision before
he met with us he had to uh meet the
timeline so and I think this is very
important the governor put out an
extraordinary social media tweet with a
photo of uh Senator Lang and myself and
the governor in his office talking about
this
bill and uh that he V that he vetoed and
this is strictly my I'm not speaking
this is my interpretation the reason he
did that
extraordinary post uh of him and us a
picture uh saying how great it was that
we came in talk about legislation I
interpreted that as his way of saying
sorry guys you know like we just should
have met
earlier which brings us to today in h112
FN FN stands for f fiscal note this is a
fiscal committee and we need to touch on
that fiscal note the earlier version of
the same bill HB 319 had no fiscal note
no FN at all so we put this in again we
didn't anticipate the fiscal note that
you see attached to
hb12 we saw minimal manageable costs
associated with giving an online exam
every High School in the state gives
this
exam um and
I spent 20 years with ccsnh and I spent
as a professor and I spent 12 years in
PR and I taught grad and undergrad
courses with the university system it's
thir 32 years in uh in Po in post
education almost as much as the uh
representative from Durham probably so I
know a little bit about colleges and for
the community college system in
particular
93% of of uh community College grads in
New Hampshire are from New Hampshire so
now that 320 is
law uh 93% of the
ccsn ccsn students who are from New
Hampshire uh recent grads who have
already taken this uh so the intent of
this particularly for ccsnh is just
simply to cover the gaps the older
students or the very few out of state
students uh who would also take this so
that we could say every community
College granted has pass this test
universally and that matters a
lot and the simple fact is that uh as I
just said New Hampshire grads have
already passed it so hb12 would cover
that Gap and we saw this requirement as
being relatively easily met not by
hiring anybody but by simply putting I
know how regist operations work you put
the names of the students haven't taken
the test into a group you put a link
online and then the students take the
test online nobody has to correct it
they take the test online as many times
as they need to to pass it they can take
it in their pajamas so we did not see
this is an
onerous uh expense and that's why the FN
was so
surprising um so usnh a little different
uh the university system has
a much higher percentage of folks who go
there who are out of state so there'd be
more a higher percentage of University
system people who would need to take it
to get the
universality again that's the purpose of
this
bill so the the Department of Education
has already created an online version
which the commissioner offered to share
for free with
postsecondary and uh
the FN when I saw it I saw that
the anticipated a need in order to
satisfy the requirement of administering
this exam of hiring uh a person at
Plymouth a person at Durham a person at
can had $130,000 a year to do
this I I we were shocked that there was
a fiscal note that said this
for exam that needs no one to correct it
for exam that's already available online
um the the fiscal note said the cost
could be up to a million
dollars again uh a uh we're just looking
to give an online test we're not looking
for a Manhattan project uh you'll likely
hear that of course there are expenses
it
expenses uh administrative expenses it
we saw the cost as being so marginal
there was no need for a fiscal note
inevit inevitably there are some pieces
that would require some time and maybe
minimal expense as we saw it uh the
notion that you got to hire all these
people and uh spend up to a million
dollars uh it just doesn't pass the
smell test at all so I'll close by
saying that the sponsors get constant
Kudos and you you probably have received
and will receive uh you know all kinds
of uh people who say we want this we
need this like the parents of high
school kids love it so this this is
something that will strengthen the
credibility and the value of a
postsecondary diploma uh makes makes the
degrees more more valuable and and the
hundreds of people watching online uh I
hope they they understand that I also
want to say that a test is not a Panacea
to solve the entire crisis of ignorance
uh that's out there but it it makes a it
can make a big difference we believe
that it's it's been proven in other
states and we believe it can happen in
New Hampshire and again we see it as
coming down to knowledge versus
ignorance and we can keep giving degrees
to people who have no idea how their
government works and who have little
appreciation for their American Heritage
or we can do like so many others do and
and take this relatively simple modest
action relatively and uh guarantee that
every college graduate has a solid
foundation of uh Civics fundamentals and
finally uh I I do want to acknowledge
the good folks from both secondary
systems the community college system the
university system we've had constructive
back and forth I know they're sick of
getting emails from the likes of me but
we care we're doing this because we
worry we care and we believe that we can
do better we should do better of course
that's going to be up to you all um the
folks have acknowledged the problem and
they've they've indicated they want to
work with us to address it and uh I will
add that nhpr did a story on this And
the reporter included 10 questions from
the US CIS test I sent that link to the
committee uh it's in my online
testimony um one of the chancellors of
the two systems I heard uh actually took
the test and scored 10 for 10 I won't
say which Chancellor it was but that's
excellent to which I say uh Bravo Zulo
and I I think I saw in line that the uh
representative from Durham perhaps also
took that same assessment and also got
10 for 10 uh and I say Bravo there as
well thank you for your patience and for
hearing us out hearing me out and be
happy to try to respond to any questions
if there are any thank you very much uh
representative and I'm going to ask one
question for first thing I may have to
run out of here too for another hearing
um regarding the community college
system we have many students uh a vast
many that are adults which are coming
back for
a uh not a four a two-year degree but
maybe certification in a career field
are they going to be
required uh before they get that
certificate uh in the trades area to
take this if they're there just for like
say one semester sure thank you Mr
chairman great question is one that
we've already talked about I mentioned
we've been in touch with postsecondary
and uh if it's not clear you have the
the measure you can make that clear and
language our our desire is for degrees
people who get degrees to have taken
this exam again I spent 20 years in the
community call system yes there are many
folks who who take just a course or they
take a certificate and it would be great
if did take it but no we don't ex we are
not looking for that to be a mandate
only for degree programs so it's your
intent that this will not be covering
something right we're fine with with
clear making it clear that it's strictly
for degree programs not certificate or
otherwise further questions from the
committee representative uh spillsbury
thank you Mr chairman can you tell me
the rationale for exempting exchange
students in foreign Nationals sure the
question was
uh with regard to exempting foreign
Nationals uh my personal preference
would be uh to have foreign Nationals
required to take this um I mentioned my
uh my niece was from Denmark um when we
put this together two terms ago that was
a compromise that we made uh there were
some folks who could not and would not
support this measure if we imposed it on
foreign Nationals and so uh the language
that we put in three 319 which you see
again here today in 112 Exempted foreign
Nationals uh because it was a compromise
to move things forward for the folks who
didn't think they should take it as I
just said I I uh I I personally think it
would be good for them to take it if if
you wanted to make that requirement uh
i' have no problem with that but
hopefully that answers your
question represent papovich thank you Mr
chair thank you representative for
taking the questions um I'm trying to
part the language and the the text of
your bill says pass the 128 question
2020 version of the exam I looked it
online and when it's administered you
know in the office it's a 10 or 20
question sample and I by the way passed
the same my exam when I got my
citizenship but that was a while ago and
it was before 2020 does
this where does this Define the number
of questions that will actually be asked
right because it says 128 questions that
would be a heck of a long exam if we ask
all of them sure great question with
regard to the numbers of questions on
the
assessment uh as some of you may know it
probably you represented more than
anyone uh is someone who apparently has
gone through the process and have taken
the naturalization test the way this
works is the prospective uh new citizens
have given all these questions U 128 or
100 these different versions and they
are presumably they study all of them
they hopefully learn all those learning
objectives or elements and then they're
tested orally on 10 of them which they
have to get six you Shak in your head
that sounds familiar that's what I did
in a nice cubicle in a federal building
in Boston yeah so you obviously got at
least six out of the 10 right um and uh
so why 128 okay so there
for people who are already citizens and
in school whether it's high school or
college uh we thought we would have a
higher bar than getting six out of 10 uh
now there are two exams that are out
there there was a 100 question test
there was 100 question test and then was
ramped up to
128 uh in 2020 and then a new
Administration came in and they for
whatever reason they went back to the
easier 100 question test so to be clear
we picked the 128 version it's a little
more rigorous there's a little more
information there to study and to learn
and uh we asked in in Statute in its law
from 320 that students score 70% on 128
questions to to pass so hopefully that
answers your question uh so we clearly
designated the assessment instrument the
the 2020 version 128 questions 70 to
pass Mr chair quick followup yes just
trying to understand my question was
also how many questions will somebody
have to answer during the assessment I
know it's a pull of 128 questions total
I got that right we fig that it's 90s
something if if you do the math uh 70%
of 128 how many will they have to answer
all of them or I see it yes all yes all
128 thank you yep uh representative uh
luno and then representative m i just
real quick no I I want to back and forth
between represent luno thank you very
much Mr chair and uh thank you very much
for taking my question so um so
represent mofet you've you've refer
referred to the high school version of
this as wildly successful and that
parents and students love it uh I'm
wondering what sort of data you've
collected so far that um that talks to
that and the efficacy of uh of having
this as a graduation requirement exam
sure that's great a great question uh
it's the answer answer your first
question anecdotal um I the folks that
I've heard from uh and I've heard from a
lot uh like it initially they
they did not appreciate having this
imposed on them but now that it's out
there the feedback I've received
anecdotally that we've received is that
they uh they're glad they're doing it
and they think it makes a difference and
the second question was efficacy yeah
efficacy meaning meaning you know does
does having this as a high school
graduation requirement for every high
school student um in New Hampshire does
it somehow improve our um this test
alone does it somehow improve our degree
of Civic awareness and um and
involvement um among these this cohort
of high school grants sure and that's
another good question does it does it
basically does this test make it
difference uh is what I'm hearing and
the answer in my view is it makes a huge
difference it gets
everyone on on uh the same playing field
in the sense that there's a universal
requirement I I taught Civics in in
history and government so obviously it's
an area that matters to me and before
this test came into place there was a
broad spectrum of how schools handled
Civic social studies some did much
Milford by the way uh reps and patrino I
just came from the east from Milford
Milford had had a reputation of doing a
great job uh with Civics and there are
other schools that did uh not much uh
some schools did great some school just
a wide spectrum and what worried the
sponsors like myself of the schools that
were were not Milford schools that they
didn't teach it at all or or when they
did teach it uh they didn't get into
fundamentals they they'd have people go
to town meeting which is great or or a
political thing or whatever and that
would be that would satisfy the Civics
requirement uh Senator dallis Sandro uh
is a longtime friend of mine uh who's
also a Civics teacher and when I went to
the Senate I wasn't able to ask him on
the senate floor but I wanted to say
coach uh by the way he recruited me to
play basketball at for him 50 years ago
so we went way back and I wanted to say
coach would you send players out in the
court of the field who don't have
fundamentals and uh I didn't never get
to ask him that question so the value of
this is that every student what whether
the school does a good job or a poor job
with with classes every student has this
solid 128 question element Foundation
across the board uh and so I think it's
been good for every school and every
student in my opinion so M Mr chair just
re real quickly and follow up on this
because we had an earlier earlier
question that um that really wanted to
drill down on um on what what's the
scientific basis behind making um U
making such assertions and clearly
you've said it's uh it's anecdotal but I
think from the little bit of data that
I've been able to collect at about 20
minutes after one uh there were 11
people that signed up to support this
bill and 18 signed up to oppose the bill
and that doesn't e neither one of those
pieces of information sound like it's
wildly successful or that parents all
over the place love it so just putting
it out there for the little bit of
actual data we have sure doesn't point
in that direction I'm not sure if that
sample uh and I did take a grad course
in in Ed measurements I don't know if
that's a valid sample to make a judgment
on but as you know so well
representative the uh the signin things
matter we look at them uh sometimes they
can be uh uh of course 11 and 18 that
may change sometimes as you know we'll
have hundreds of people from out of
state call in and and sign in and check
in and support or whatever uh but we
still look at them and thank you for
sharing those numbers and uh but I
wouldn't base the any decisions on uh
the numbers you just looked
up it's further further questions
representa spillsbury
very quickly is it your intent that this
applies only to undergraduate degree
granning programs or also graduate thank
B question undergraduate or graduate the
intent is strictly undergraduate and uh
most graduate students not all but most
of them are from that would have already
satisfied the requirement on the high
school level and then hopefully on the
on the uh associate or borate degree
levels uh graduate is not part of the
equation here if we wanted to make that
clear you would have no objection
correct
certainly further questions
yes thank you Mr chair um I just have a
question about the potential cost and
and you mentioned that you know we could
get the software from the Department of
Education um but would you expect any
cost in the area of test prep um
assistance to students who might have
different learning styles or special
needs um and then the cost if if kids if
the students can't pass the test sure
great question I'm glad you asked that
uh the initial legislation from two
terms ago uh on on the secondary level
Exempted or provided for special needs
FK folks who or students who had special
needs would could take the test uh
through a special needs professional to
answer that part of it the other part uh
before I step away I'm glad you answer
that question uh this this is a fiscal
uh Financial committee and I've already
said that the sponsors did not see this
is terribly expensive we're actually
surprised that there was a fiscal note
we thought that the current registar
offices and and the the the many
professionals that the institutions
employ could e in our view easily absorb
this uh would have taken some some
measure of time uh we thought it was
minimal now I'm sure what you're going
to hear uh that there's going to be uh
all kinds of it uh requirements it's
going to be all kinds of administration
time uh I've already mentioned and thank
you again for the question I've already
mentioned that the fiscal note we think
is
wildly uh off uh stun stunningly
surprised that that the uh we see no
need to hire anybody that you may hear
differently uh and I hope that you'll uh
listen to whatever testimony you get on
the cost and understand that uh
you need to be maybe a little bit
skeptical that's your job is to look
into like represent the representative
from Hopkinson just looked online to try
to get some numbers uh do some due
diligence I'm very dubious about what
I've heard what it's in the fiscal Noe
and probably what you may hear shortly
in terms of the cost and I would also
say as I've already said that you know
all the high schools do it and so many
other states are doing it and that might
be a good thing to have some researcher
look into you know did it cost a million
dollars for South Dakota to do this I
don't think so I don't did they have to
hire all these $130,000 a year people to
uh administer a test that's already been
made up already formatted already online
that no one has to correct uh I am very
dubious about what I've seen and and and
I would be very careful about what you
may hear in terms of cost the
representative does that help a little
bit
uh represent I have one question for
you this is the season in which there's
been some real exciting football games
and we have the final four coming up on
us in another month and students are
transferring from one school and now
going through the
portal uh we have some kids that were
playing for Notre Dame or Ohio State
which we saw last night um they've been
in one of those schools for maybe a
semester um are those students that may
be receiving that degree from that new
school also required to do this to come
in for the portal or is that going to
impact our athletic programs well thank
you for the question Mr chairman uh I am
kind of a sports guy as some of you know
I actually have a bill into Commerce on
the new world uh nil name image and
likeness even division 3 students now
can sell their likenesses and yes there
are college students who are uh
transferring from school to school to
school uh so the the athletic piece of
that is of of interest uh but I think
more to the point you're asking about
transfers um and again the requirement
is uh for any degree you need to pass a
test so if somebody comes to whatever
institution from what other institution
and they haven't taken the test they
would need to add their name to the list
click on the L link take the test done
does does that answer your
question yes as you see it yes okay any
other uh questions from the committee to
the thank you very much thank you m
chair yeah uh we next have uh Laura
Banker Banker again and Katherine
prenter
good afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee again for the record my name
is Katherine prevent service the
chancellor of our state's University
system and Lauren Banker is uh
distributing some
testimony so
um yes I will admit I am the
chancellor that took the 10 question
exam that representative mofet sent sent
us one evening um I will also say that
that um I agree with representative
moffett's statements and intent on the
importance of um the citizenry being
educated in
Civics um however as I mentioned this
morning there is a cost to
administer the bill it is it is not a a
no cost
bill um I will I will add that when
the last session when this uh I don't
remember the bill number uh came forward
we were not asked to complete a fiscal
note we're we only complete fiscal notes
when the legislative budget Assistance
Office sends us the request so that's
why there wasn't a fiscal note last
session um the the other part of the
fiscal note and I want address that
because um again we've been in
communication with representative mofet
quite a bit over the last few
weeks we know that the Department of
Education spent over half a million
dollars on its platform and its test at
the time we completed the fiscal note we
didn't know that the Department of
Education test would be available um
there's still some question I think we'd
need to to there's still some dialogue
happening between the Department of
Education ccsnh and usnh on how that
would work because it's a third-party
vendor um so so there's still some
question
there but at the end of the day it's not
zero cost the bill does require the
university system and the community
college system to administer monitor
ensure
compliance um and and again the language
of the bill does not exempt New
Hampshire High School grads now
presumably they would be exempt because
after I
think January 26 they everyone all high
school graduates need to complete the
exam about 48% of our students are not
from New Hampshire so we would need to
administer the test um even
online keep records of it and certify
presumably um passage and the the other
part of this is um and I believe
representative Weinstein asked this
question so what happens with for
students who don't pass the
test I mean I guess you just keep taking
the test over and over and over but we
don't want
to um you know cause a student not to
graduate timely because the test wasn't
especially if they just paid for their
education um so again the
the I agree 100% with the intent of the
bill but it is not a zeroc cost
effort um and one other point I I would
like to make the the the enabling
statute of the University system is RSA
187a and um the legislature back in 1981
that was the most recent iteration of
the legislation gives broad authority to
the Board of
Trustees um on on a number of of issues
including you know differing the
graduation requirements that flows down
through faculty and
administration um we do think it's a it
could be precedent setting that we're
going to have graduation
requirements mandated by the leg
legislature this session alone there are
three different bills that mandate
various graduation
requirements and um so just another
thing to think about as you as you
deliberate the the bill the cost and the
graduation requirements in the testimony
there are some other areas of question
that that um we have with the bill but
th those are the the
primary concerns that the university
system has with with
hb12 happy to take any questions thank
you very much are there any questions
from the committee yeses representative
McGuire
thank you Mr chairman thank you madam
Chancellor um so I think you I just
heard you say that you and the and the
Board of Trustees and the faculty have
the authority to add this
requirement if you thought it was
valuable for graduation is that without
getting into trouble with your
accreditation or some other thing yes
yes I believe so the the you know the
faculty kind of own the curriculum if
you will but yes I believe that's that's
the case did I follow up yes thank you
and would you say that that that group
of people has an incentive to uh have
more um non- New Hampshire students
attend the University system and and
graduate and and and and get a good
education no I I don't I don't believe
there's an incentive to have more outof
State students
is I'm sorry was that your question
representative yeah I mean let me put it
this way so if
you assuming you thought that this was a
good idea and would get get more
students interested in coming to the
university would would improve uh their
education you have some incentive to do
so
certainly if if right if we believed it
would increase enrollment and education
sure okay so all right thank you further
questions from the
committee yes representa
Damon thank you Mr chair following up on
my colleague down the lane
here wouldn't it be correct that a
potential student could simply take the
test that the opportunity to take the
test isn't an incentive to become a
university student
I'm I'm sorry representative that one
more
time I'm just trying to highlight and
confirm that if this were imposed on the
University by legislation to require
this
test that perhaps you would not perceive
this as an incentive for students to
enroll in the University because they
simply could take the test anyway
without being a university student
I I agree I'm not sure that um I I don't
know that requiring this test would
encourage more students to attend our
institutions thank you further questions
from the committee yes representative
papovich thank you and uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you again for taking
questions in the line of the stuff that
we've talked on an earlier Bill if the
fiscal note is based on an incorrect
assumption about the availability of the
system could we please have it updated
because this committee and the F and the
finance committee will need you know
something closer to reality and I know
that we never can get it on the nose but
could we please do that too yes we're
working on that right now are there
further questions from the
committee thank you very much thank you
next uh person up is Shannon Reed from
the community college system
and I support the bill
probably with amendments could you speak
to your amendments please sure I can I
can speak to all of that the pink cards
don't allow um a great range of um
possibilities it's I support I oppose
and we're at a point with the community
college system where we we would like to
get to a point where we can support it
um with a few amendments that the
sponsor and I have discussed and um I'm
making sure that you all understand a
few things about implementation and I'm
sorry let me start correctly uh I'm
Shannon Reed director of government
affairs with the community college
system of New Hampshire um thank you for
the opportunity to testify on H
112 So as I said uh a moment ago we are
interested in making this work we would
first like to figure out the mechanics
of it internally implementing this is
not as simple as it sounds and we don't
have that mapped out yet we'd like to
get a better idea of how to set it up
how to keep it going and what resources
that will take so um just quickly a
couple things about the the test itself
um the way the test is used for
citizenship purposes versus the way the
test would be used in this instance
there are two main differences when
someone takes a test for
citizenship they go to a room they're
they're face to face with the person
who's asking them the questions as as
you've done there the questioner chooses
any 10 questions from the test and the
person takeing it has to just get six
right some of the questions are somewhat
open-ended there are more there's more
than one way to get it right um they're
not all true false or multiple question
and this is why the test itself in its
in its official version does not lend
itself to being taken online it can't be
um it can't be taken electronically and
scored automatically because of those
somewhat subjective um Elements which is
why the Department of Education when
they were implementing House Bill 320
they went to a vendor they had a version
of the test created that was close
enough deemed to be close enough but was
all multiple choice Andor true false
questions so there's a version that New
Hampshire owns I'm told we can use it um
that the department has purchased that
would work to be delivered online it's
something that we could in theory we
could load it into our learning
management system canvas and deliver it
to students that way they could take it
and it could be automatically scored and
we assume after our conversations with
the Department that this test could be
made available to us at no cost even
though it did cost the department um
some some resources to have it have it
uh set up so as far as the
mechanics um I have been talking about
this bill a lot over the last a week um
with our director of it whose team would
be the ones that would need to set this
up and make the process work and in at
least initially it would be a bit of a
lift um it would have to be set up
managed monitored some of what we would
have to do would be um in addition to to
loading the test basically putting it
into our LMS we'd have to crosswalk
confirmation of completion to our
registar and get that put into our
student management system we'd want to
set that up manually so that it's not
I'm sorry we'd want to set it up
automatically so it's not a manual
process we would need a mechanism to
show um completion from the high school
students who come to us because
presumably they all would have taken it
after a certain date we' need to
automate communication to students to
make sure they get reminders if they
haven't taken the test and they're
approaching their graduation date and
for us that includes multiple points
across the Academic Year we graduate
people in December May and August at
least um and then we we basically need
someone to oversee and manage this at
the beginning and then be responsible
for ongoing compliance so as as my as a
previous speaker said all these things
are doable but but yes there is there is
there are cost elements to it um and we
have a small it team are already fairly
overextended on things like network
security and cyber security and and
managing our networks so we'd have to
figure out do we task this to somebody
new how do we get this how do we get
this um the the how do we get this
staffed basically and we just haven't
started to lay that out yet so since the
legislature passed House Bill 320 and
made this requirement in the high
schools starting this year um those
students will have already met it and
that's that's the good news the
challenge is that there's no mechanism
in the department of education's
platform to transmit verified completion
to us so that would just have to be
built um and whether their vendor would
work with us um through the doe contract
or charge us to to put that in place we
we don't know and I say these things not
to discourage you or to close doors on
this idea but just to be realistic there
is a cost to adding a set of tasks and
keeping that going over time um we do
have some concerns about placing
additional barriers in front of our
students um who will otherwise have
earned their their degrees um and we'd
have to address any issues related to
withholding degrees or certificates from
completers who haven't finished the test
yet something we have to to work out
we're do we're willing to do this work
to achieve the outcomes that the sponsor
described um but we do need to
anticipate it will require some time
oversight and and some cost and we we'd
like to know more about that before the
legislature commits us to move forward
with this um if something is worth doing
it's it's worth doing right and worth
doing well and worth understanding what
that will all entail so the two
amendments that I had discussed with the
prime sponsor um would would do two
things one is limit this to students
earning an associate degree which
um which just better kind of defines the
population as I believe the chair
pointed out we have students who come in
for all kinds of purposes it might just
be a course or two it might be a
short-term technical certificate and and
it's I think it would be simpler if we
if we restricted this to our associate
degree seeking students and then second
allow us to block exempt anyone who's
graduated from a New Hampshire High
School from say January 1 2026 forward
now we'd still need to code them in some
way we still need to figure that out but
if we could do that as a block rather
than on an individual student basis um
on the assumption that they will have
complied with this pursuant to House
Bill 320 so um I'll just wrap up by
saying that you know ideally we'd like a
little more time to figure this out
before this committee or the legislature
commits us to going forward we are we
absolutely willing to do that um but I
hopefully I've outlined some of the you
know some of the kind of specifics that
that cause us to understand that this
will be this will be some work and I'd
be happy to try to take questions thank
you very much questions yes
representative luno then representative
spilsbury thank you very much Mr chair
thank you very much um um M Reed for uh
for joining us this afternoon um I want
to get back to a question that that I'd
asked the prime sponsor earlier and so
I'd like to ask it to you as well with
in a little bit of an expanded scope but
are you aware of any um any data out
there uh with respect to the efficacy of
this type of exam that's you know it it
doesn't come packaged with curriculum or
instruction or anything like that it's
just an exam any efficacy in terms of um
in terms of I guess student
understanding and involvement and and
Civic engagement n that's number one and
um and what are other community colleges
around the country doing with respect to
uh this and have they seen any data so
with respect to efficacy if there is
data which there may well be I'm not
aware of it um and your second question
I I don't think that the is a widespread
requirement among community colleges in
the across the country representative
spilsbury thank you Mr chairman uh so as
the sponsor indicated 93% of the
students in the uh community college
system did graduate from New Hampshire
High Schools I assume your request for
an amendment that would allow a block
exemption is to reduce the
administrative burden of having a case
by case show proof is that correct or is
there more to it um that's mostly
correct um thank you for the question
the yeah the request to have us able to
exempt this group as a block is to
reduce the administrative work but I
just want to clarify something on the
93% 93% of community college students
are New Hampshire residents
but about 40% of our students are what's
considered non-traditional age Learners
so I think that's 24 and above so they
would not have met this requirement in
high school that's not a it's not a huge
number it's not a small number but it's
it's a group that that we would have to
kind of you know deal with as individual
students got it so that's why your block
exemption related to those students who
graduated after a certain date right on
the assumption that they will have
complied with this requirement oh sounds
like this the Amendments you're
suggesting would be
helpful thank you further
questions represent Ames
my question is uh is related to May
overlap with the efficacy testing
question um but
um it's it's a simple
question to ask but probably much harder
to answer and it it's really performance
on the test um what is the what's your
understanding of the failure and uh need
to repeatedly take a test
of those who have been taking this test
in different different environments and
different places different ways of
administering the test I understand all
of what you said about that it's
different again for you in the community
college system figuring out how to do
this but any information on uh on who
passes and who doesn't pass I mean since
we haven't had this requirement
implemented I don't have any performance
data to offer I I can say I I believe
the answers to the test are fairly easy
to
find um and this isn't a proctored exam
this wouldn't be something where you
have to study and then come in hoping
hoping you remember enough and know
enough you could literally look at the
answers as you're looking at the
questions which you know may have some
value though it it it kind of forces you
to engage with the questions um so I you
know just because you can do that
doesn't in my my opinion anyway and I
I'm not a teacher um but I don't think
that invalidates the value of of seeing
what the questions are and finding the
answers and matching those two things up
but I don't have any information about
um
performance advocacy history Etc oh
thank you that's that is helpful what
you just said thank
you uh Shan and I have a question um you
mentioned the word proctored a few
moments
ago if the test is proctored and you're
looking at the whites of their eyes you
know who's taking it I could take a a
test or do a report on this thing now
and AI could answer everything for me
and um you don't even know if I'm Johnny
Jones uh taking the test so how how how
would you manage online assessment well
to a certain extent we could and to a
certain extent we couldn't students do
need to sign into their canvas accounts
so the student has to do that could they
then say hey come take this for me to
someone in the room I guess they could
hadn't thought about that as a as a
complication
um you know I think we would try to do
some messaging around this about the
value of knowing these things on your
own knowing these things um but sure
could someone pull someone in to do it
for them I I I guess we couldn't prevent
that thank you further
questions yes represent Brown
so I use canvas for my online courses
and it seems these cost estimates are a
little high because all you need to do
is set up a canvas shell populate the
the quiz with questions and then upload
the student names and um you can also
have videotaping of the session where
they hold up an ID card and you verify
the actual student and that you get a
report after the video is recorded
indicating if there's any detection of
um illegal or you
know un um acceptable behavior going on
during the quiz so I don't understand
how um the fiscal note can say that
there are significant complexity to
doing this and it's going to be very
expensive it would take me about an hour
to set up the quiz um both the community
colleges and the the universities all
use canvas don't they the the community
colleges Ed canvas I'm not sure about
the university system um so you I would
say yes or no to to that question um
things you talk about potentially
videotaping the sessions and auditing
the reports sure we could do those
things but someone has to do those
things which means someone has to be
paid to do those things which which
means there there there would be a cost
I think the more you the more you add in
terms of um validation and um the more
you add finish that to steps the more
you add to the cost the fiscal
note uh when I constructed the fiscal
note for this bill I was looking at what
the Department of Education had to go
through to comply which was significant
both in cost and workload and I was
looking also at um the possibility of
having to set up coding an API to have
the Department's vendor send us High
School completion data and the
vendor informally estimated that at
$100,000 now I think we could probably
set up something simpler if we're able
to block exempt as we've talked about
but that was part that was one of the
assumptions built into the fiscal impact
statement another was simply you know if
we can't find existing staff to manage
this and and might have to bring someone
on that would be a
cost are there further
questions
yes hi I just had question if um someone
is uh new to this country and did pass
um the citizenship test and our citizens
but they're not that proficient in
English um but they enter the uh
Community College for whatever it is
they're going for is there something to
help them or what would they go through
um and when would they have to take this
ver of the
test
um I just thought you know or would they
be um you know would they have to do it
again take the test the 90 questions or
whatever 120 question test and if they
did um at what time would that
happen uh thank you for the for the
question at what time that would happen
would have to be any time prior to the
student earning their associate degree
so presum presumably in a in a degree
program that might take two years
sometime within that 2-year period the
student would have to take it if the
student had an issue with English
language proficiency I haven't thought
about that um I'm sure there are ways to
deal with it I I just don't know what
those are whether it's some kind of an
AI translator uh type of um resource or
a person helping them to understand the
questions I don't know thank you good
question
representative
baky
okay yeah sorry thank you you're welcome
thank you um so I guess follow up
to what representative just asked you so
if they took the 10 question quiz or
test or um and became a citizen and then
went to college how how like how does
that or have you thought of that I guess
is really what I would so when I asked
when I said or would they have to take
it that was what I was thinking of I
think that in the in the bill itself
line line 21 and 22 it says exchange
students and foreign Nationals shall be
exempt from this
section sorry that's
okay thank
you question represent papovich thank
you again um one we talk amendments I'd
like to point out that if you want to
exclude people who already took the test
uh naturalized citizens would probably
also uh make that bill since uh you know
they already had to pass it just a
suggestion I don't know whether it's a
good idea I would appreciate you know I
hope it's worth your your
consideration I I think it's a it's a
good point and you know these are some
of the questions and possibilities that
we'd want to be we'd want to work
through so we had a better picture of
what we were going to be doing thank you
very much no more questions we're going
to close this
hearing 193 is going to be real quickly
I'll go introduce it and you can get get
me going bless
you okay we're going to move on to HB
193 and uh the prime sponsor
representative lad is is going to
introduce the
Bill thank you very much chairman
spillsbury and members of the education
funding committee uh for the record my
name is Rick glad I come from hail New
Hampshire Crafton 5 and I'm here to
introduce House Bill 193 this bill is a
bill that's being put forth on behalf of
the community college system uh in fact
they have basically written it uh it's
relative to the maximum number of
credits per course eligible for the Dual
and concurrent enrollment program this
is a bipartisan Bill the issue which we
had back when we first initiated dual
concurrent enrollment we allowed uh five
credit courses for a maximum of 15
credit hours that was back when we only
had grades 11 and 12 participating since
that that's all been changed it's now
open to grades 10 11 and 12 students in
those grades and up to four courses per
year the issue is that in various
certain trades and courses at the
community college system a course can
include up to 12
credits now we're talking more money per
course and the way it works is we fund
these courses through our allocation in
the state budget in the budget we
approve at $150 per
course around $2.5
million a
year and what we need to do is slice
this thing back so uh students going to
be right now it's only up to we say up
to four but they only have enough money
for up to two courses per year per kid
so now it's going to be up to these
courses that are no more than four
credit a piece so that is the change
that this build do you can see by
reading on the bill there's only one
line change each course funded pursuant
to this paragraph shall not exceed four
credits we've had courses which are up
to 12 credits and that is pushing the
appropriation dollar that we need Way
Beyond what we're going to provide to
the community college system and these
courses are really needed Down Below in
fact the community college system is
even offered to send kids or not kids
teachers instructors from the community
college system like nhti down to places
like Franklin which don't have people
qualified to teach these courses so the
courses would be taught concurrent
enrollment wise in the school so the
community college is really working with
uh education K through 12 and I
encourage us uh move this bill forward
thank you very
much thank you very much uh Mr chairman
any questions yes representative P pleas
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
uh taking questions your testimony says
that it's a $100 $150 tuition C cost per
course is that per course per credit is
there a relationship by course by course
and it's paid you know it's money is in
our budget which goes to the community
college system and takes care of that
tuition cost for students in high school
that are eligible thank you so the cost
would be the same whether they take a
one credit course a four credit course a
12 credit cours that's a good question
for the committee C for Shannon thank
you I will hold yep thank you other
questions yes represent thank you thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my
question um if this is to go forward
who's paying for how is this the or who
who's paying for the teachers at the
high school level to be um teaching
these courses if the revenue is going to
the Community College how are the
expenses for the teacher being covered I
see where you're going with that the
high school
is paying the teacher that they have
hired that's by negotiated agreement all
that on staff to teach that course if
that teacher meets the accreditation
standards for teaching that college
credit course so they're going to have
to make sure they a master's
degree and and using materials
associated with that course which are
taught used at the community college
system now your question is driving at
the fact well okay is the college then
going to
um the person is is that person is there
going to be $150 for that course and I
would say yes there will be seeing that
it's still a credit a course credit
that's offered through the community
college system so that's where that 150
bucks is going to be used it may be
taught through your high school teacher
but the the course is being one which is
approved through the accrediting
association and through that
college would you be amenable to having
the Community College reimburse the
taxpayers of that high school to cover
the teaching of that college
course we have a program that's been
working and when we look this over the
entire budget which we approve and when
we're looking what concurrent dual
enrollment does by providing this dollar
to the community college system we could
be saving that student who later takes
that when they're in the community
college system or Mom and Dad are paying
for it between 10 and 15
Million by that bit that we
appropriate this is not the cost for
that course that the person that's not
in high school is going to have to pay
this course is really discounted I can
remember when we
negotiated this fee of $150 with Ros
catel that's years ago when he was
Chancellor Economist of the community
college system so I don't think I would
be amenable to that I think that we have
a program that's working at a minimum
cost and it's a huge huge savings to
families so that's where the property
taxpayers is going to be saved between
that 10 and 15 Mill million do which
they are saving for not having to pay
for that when that student is no longer
a high school student but a college
student further questions thank you very
quick I I'm just trying to better
understand this topic would it be fair
to say that
this is a dual enrollment class and
therefore it's already part of the
obligation of the high school to teach
that class anyway all the program does
is that it makes it also applicable to
college a dual Roan Pro prr course is
one that's taught at the college by the
qualified college professor or teacher
the concurrent is one which has at the
high school corre correct thank you I I
meant thank you for the clarification so
the concurrent one that's the one where
basically they would the the local
school district already had an
obligation to meet you know to teach the
kids enough credits to get to their
graduation requirements this does not
impose an additional burden on the
school district beyond what they were
going to be required to do anyway right
right we the these concurrent credit
courses are done through oftentimes a
teacher that's doing an AP
course we we're competing
Keane Plymouth excuse me the community
college system oftentimes competes with
Sno who does not require the person to
have a master's they require only a
bachelor's degree we're getting I
believe and I've seen what snow is doing
at at the high school my own students
grandchildren go to I believe the what
we get out of our public school system
is better quality I I don't want to go
any further than that because we're
talking about one of
our education institutions in the state
of New
Hampshire so Mr chair uh would you agree
basically this is just modifying and
limiting an already existing program and
if it has any fiscal impact it's to
reduce it
somewhat
yes um okay thank you thank you Mr
chairman uh I would just like to follow
up on the question that my colleague
says uh asked so that I have some
clarification with the
concurrent education or or teaching is
there is the college system receiving
revenue for that student who is in the
concurrent enrollment or is the public
school the the the K through 12 school
receiving the revenue for teaching that
class the Community College systems
receiving that Revenue
the student is the benefactor of that
Revenue thank
you other
questions thank you very much
representative
lad we have any
sign okay frequent flyers thank you
Shannon
so Shannon Reed for the community
college
system thank you Shannon Reed for the
community college system um and I can be
fairly quick and simple I think the the
chairman explained um what this bill
does most community college system
courses are three credits or four
credits um however we do offer some
courses in formats that make them more
than four credits and we we're what
we're trying to do is simply um Define
the scope of what's covered under this
program to those that are through three
or four credits we would appreciate it
if you consider changing the effective
date of this bill to upon passage so
that this can become effective for our
summer semester um and if if I may um
just address a couple of the questions
that came up um these are the courses
that are taught in high school for dual
credit are 100% still courses that
confer High School Credit they're part
of a high school students normal course
load they're taught by their teachers
but they're designed as college courses
so that the students get credit so this
isn't something that the high school
students are doing that's an addition
the high school teachers are doing
that's that's an addition necessarily
it's what they do it's what they do
anyway it's just the course is of a
different nature um this the courses are
being offered already at a very
significant discount to the students um
so to the extent that the community
college system is receiving revenue from
this
program um it's it's a significant
discount off of what we would charge if
that student couldn't take English comp
the senior year of high school and had
to come to the college and take it so
we're sort of in a way cannibalizing our
own our own future Revenue in order to
support students while they're in high
school so that they can get dual credit
and I I perhaps assume um more uh
familiarity with this program than I
should but I'm happy to explain it in
Greater depth when you're not you know
an hour behind on your um committee
schedule today um but as far as what the
community college distri does is we
manage this program we employ
coordinators for our seven colleges to
work with high school teachers and
parents and students we promote and
Market the program we invest in a system
called dual enroll where um again it's
kind of seamless automated way of
crediting the this uh students course
course completion in our system they
received current strips from us so this
is not simply courses that that happen
kind of happen to confer credit there's
significant infrastructure that does go
into that so as the chairman said this
has been a very successful program since
about 1999 it's grown steadily every
year 10,000 high school students take
advantage of it as of the current year
and um we would it's certainly been a
success story and I think a win-win for
the state thank
you thank you very much are there
questions see none okay and I don't
believe we have anybody else signed up
for this bill so with that I'll close
the hearing on HP
193 our uh next and final bill is HB
550 and uh representative luno is here
to introduce his
Bill thank you very much uh Mr chair
members of the committee and it's not my
bill it's a bill I don't take U um
anything that uh that I file proprietary
in nature so um so for the my name is
David
luno and I represent the people of
Hopkinson and Bo and uh conquered
Houston be in my district too so throw
conquered in and um and people in fact
all over the wonderful Granite State
because everything we do in this room
matters to uh matters Statewide so we
have statewide responsibilities so so um
anyway so uh Mart County 9 here to
introduce house bill um uh 550 so
so before I get into uh to the bill I
just want to um just sort of take
everybody through uh through a little
bit of brief history what we're what
we're looking at here is a bill that is
in response to the uh the lower courts
decision in the conval uh lawsuit and I
think everybody around the table here
prob probably is pretty aware of what uh
you know what went into the conal
lawsuit what it's what it's all about
and uh but I will I will talk a little
bit about some of the things that were
in the the lower Court's order but the
um uh the lawsuit was filed back in
2019 um uh where the uh where the The
conell Cooperative School District sued
the state of New Hampshire and others um
with respect to the base cost base cost
of an adequate education so this is the
the the top of the of our current school
funding formula associated with the base
cost of inadequate education
um uh that trial went on for uh took a
little while and then in uh in
2023 the uh Superior Court um ruled in
favor of the plaintiffs and um uh and
basically in that order they um you know
they took a look at uh you know they
listened to a lot of expert testimony uh
experts including Kimberly Rizzo
Saunders who was the former um
superintendent uh at conal who had uh
sort of laid out um uh logic and
reasoning behind a base cost of um
$929 which lined up very very very close
to that of uh another expert uh Dr Bruce
Baker um who um who testified that uh
that a base cost in New Hampshire given
all the things that go into public
school public education uh would have a
base cost of about
9964 uh at the end of the day the uh the
Court um uh came up with a conservative
minimum threshold uh of
$735 and because everybody's probably
seen the one cent uh after that too I'll
just mention it here but I won't mention
that anymore um as a as a conservative
minimum threshold for base costs per
pupil for an adequate education um and
um uh but State didn't like that and so
it appealed it to the Supreme Court and
that's where the uh the case
sits now um in um uh in I believe it was
December may have been November November
December 2024 The Supremes uh heard oral
arguments and we're now awaiting their
um their decision um uh upon appeal so
so anyway that's the uh that's the brief
history let me talk just a second about
what the convel Cooperative School
District uh is all about and the
plaintiffs in this case so um convel
operative School District constitutes
the towns of um Anam Bennington Dublin
Francis Town Greenfield Hancock
Peterboro Sharon Temple uh did I miss
any so it's a lot of towns it's a big uh
it's a big Co-op but very impressively
they've been joined uh by other um um uh
uh school districts across the state who
have joined as plaintiffs in this
lawsuit and together conal and the
plaintiff uh school districts educate AO
approximately 25% of all public school
kids um uh here in New Hampshire so um
so the bill we're looking at here House
Bill 550 uh is filed as part of a
package of uh of school funding uh
legislation and um and U you know the
one here modifies the base um uh the
base Grant in conville but we'll be
seeing other bills as well they haven't
received received um Bill numbers yet
they're still at the LSR number level
but there's one that responds to Rand
with another lawsuit with uh with
changes to the differential uh Aid which
is the other part of the uh the formula
we see um uh we see on the books and um
and another bill with respect to special
education Aid which has been prated
although that may be in a little bit of
flux right now um and also a bill that
is really comprehensive in nature
in terms of reforming how we uh we fund
schools in New Hampshire and I'll and I
do want to talk a little bit about um
about that but um but the uh the funding
formulas that are in all of these bills
the one we're looking at here the one
that does differentiated Aid and the one
that does comprehensive are all talked
about in the 2020 school funding
commission report and uh we have more of
these reports in hard copy in the U in
the committee office uh they're
available
online uh for anybody to download um uh
through the uh the UNH Cary school and
um and and actually the while the report
you know I don't know it's you know sort
of half inch thickish type of type of
thing couple you know hundred Pages or
so is uh is is is is is supported and
probably the most important um uh
archive from the commission's work are
are in these these you know work
um you know pamphlets that that drill
down into uh into spec specific areas
and really constitute the evidence
behind um uh what's between um what
what's on the pages of this report here
but I'd be I'd be absolutely happy to to
go through it one-on-one or in in groups
with uh with any of the members on on
this committee you know as we as we
really sort of get into the the mode of
um of studying and
of you know these multiple uh uh school
funding bills and determining what what
sort of solution we may um we may want
to put uh put forward um but but you
know really simple what's in this couple
hundred Pages here boils down to the
fact that um that our current school
funding formula isn't getting the job
done for um uh for students and
taxpayers and um and it does make
findings and recommendations about how
we can can uh improve student outcomes
through through proper use or better use
let me say it that way better use of uh
of State funds and uh and also be more
fair to uh to taxpayers at the same time
so the bill
itself let sort of swing into it here um
it uh it makes change on line seven
that's right in the uh in the Statue of
1984a which is right where our school
funding formula is and it's a change in
in the first number in that statute from
about
$4,100 although in in in in the current
Year's in I'm sorry in FY
26's um uh budget year which is already
on the you know we're we're we're
already doing school meetings right to
to get into that um that that has gone
through CPI cost escalators so it's not
4100 it's
4265 and so it up it updates that to the
356 that the convel court um uh uh
ordered but um but just as important as
that is I think is an addition we made
to 193
e2a uh with respect to the cost of an
adequate education and this is what this
is what's in the statute now uh to tell
the legislature how it what what sort of
things to consider when costing out an
adequate education and the current the
current current statute calls out but
does not
articulate um uh what are called
necessary specific resource elements and
so that may be you know sort of parlance
that's in our in our statute today uh
I'm not sure if if those that specific
term is in the um uh the lower Court's
conval uh decision but the lower court
the conval decision does
specifically look at uh specific
necessary specific resource
when calculating that
7356 and so so I'll sort of read read
the top of it but I won't keep going now
shall include the cost for teachers
teacher benefits um uh student teacher
ratios principles administrative
assistance school counselors uh talks
about facility operation and maintenance
which was something I think denied by
the state during or oral arguments where
they said nope heat isn't included so um
so this makes it abundantly clear that
that all of the elements that at least
the elements that were um that were
required by the uh the ru off Court um
are to be included in the calculation of
the um the the base cost uh for an
adequate U
education so uh let's
see
so all right I don't want to um there's
there's going to be some people that are
going to speak after me and and um and
and speak about the significance of this
bill
yeah let's just let him finish yeah yeah
and yeah I'm and I'm getting to I'm
getting to the concluding the the
introduction on on this but but but I
was really interested in getting to the
fiscal note and and not all the bills
that I've put in are necessarily
compatible with with each
other this one's important because
there's a court case Rand is important
because there's a court case
comprehensive Equitable school funding
is important because that's actually
what what came out of our our commission
work and we want to all be able to look
at all of them but we need to be able to
look at fiscal notes associated with all
of them too and so the fiscal note on
this one comes out at nearly $500
million um real important to recognize
that our current funding formula um is a
flat funding formula and um it which
means that every school district
receives the same base adequacy amount
and frankly all the differentiated Aid
amounts as well per uh per pupil that
that quad qualify for the differentiated
but every pupil qualifies every student
qualifies for the um uh for the base so
so every student in every district is
going to well every district is going to
receive an additional 30 under this bill
an additional
$3,200 per student so for Newport that's
an additional 32 $200 per student on top
of the FY
26 uh funding of $1
13,25 by the state to Newport for the
student in Newcastle it's
$3,200 more per student on top of
the $
38,3 53 per puple that it receives from
the state and I didn't misread that
13,000
per student for Newport 38,000 per
student from the state and Newcastle
it's one size fits-all 3,200 bucks more
for everybody no matter um no matter
where you live and um and it doesn't
take into
consideration um any of the sort of the
cost differentials that we uh that we
see across the state you know Manchester
is a great example you know they've got
they've got a student body of nearly
what over 12,000 students 72 um
different languages are spoken 60% of
the kids live at come in low income
backgrounds that's very different than a
lot of other uh towns across the state
and I think um um uh you know anyway
we'll be talking about um uh more later
and and uh and certainly access to
financial resources is not something
that this bill contemplates others do
this one does not so um uh the um the
fiscal node also documents how our
current funding formula Cascades down to
Charters and vouchers um and um and and
why is that uh why is that important
because charter schools and um and
voucher um uh programs are not
accountable to the necessary resource
elements that are articulated by the
court and articulated in this bill in
calculating the co the base cost of an
adequate education so BAS basically uh
in summary this bill amends the state's
one- siiz fits-all formula to comply
with the minimum threshold defined by
the conal order um the um uh you know
the current funding formula uh as well
as um as others are presented in detail
in um in the 2020 school funding report
and uh uh and again um uh we can see how
though that you know different ways
turning different knobs different
directions
can uh can make a big difference for
student outcomes and for taxpayer equity
and i' be happy to talk one-on-one or in
small groups with anybody would like to
uh like to do more copies are available
in the office that's what I got very
good good introduction uh before I take
any questions I just want to for
everybody's uh benefit as representative
luno said this is one of a package of
bills uh that correct he is personally
on a number and there are others so
the the the chore for this afternoon is
to make sure we understand this bill not
to get into a comprehensive examination
of adequacy we will have work sessions
we'll have hearings on other bills uh
this is going to be a major Focus for us
for the coming two months so
representative papich Miller thank you
very much Mr chairman and I just wanted
to state that it was in no way my intend
to interrupt the speaker or would I ever
interrupt another speaker I just wanted
to get your attention to know that I
have a question whenever the right time
shows up and thank you for taking the
questiones representative I'm not going
to bring up the dollars yet because it
is premature to even go there right now
but I did have a question about the
language you have in line 18 and 19
that's the very last phrase in there
that says the general court shall use
evidence for actual cost for all
approved schools to determine the cost
of an adequate education I'm trying to
understand given that there are schools
that we situation in the 30s and 40s a
year and uh who knows we may approach
Northeastern University levels in the
60s how do you think that the general
court should take those actual costs and
reach the cost of an adequate education
do we consider every one of those cost
part an adequate do we recognize that
some schools have you know expectations
that go Way Beyond adequate I I'm just
trying to understand the intent that you
have as a prime sponsor yeah no that's
thank you very much um representative
for the for the question um uh the um
the the actual cost that the that the
state collects um is is some is is is is
is now pretty pretty you know complete
pretty comprehensive we've got it we've
got it going back now for at least the
last 10 to 20 years and uh and it's
something we can look at we can
something that we can see the costs of
of certain things whether it's regular
education in line 1200 or special
education in line 1300 or um um athletic
programs and it's all Broken Out In much
greater detail than than I have in front
of me right now but uh but certainly
people from the Department would be able
to to speak to exactly uh what
information's collected when you compare
that with our cost per pupil in some
districts that in some cases is is uh
could be as a result of very unusual
costs that perhaps very large
Cooperative districts might uh might be
facing in terms of Transportation or it
could actually be part of very unusual
strange aspects of New Hampshire's
school funding uh design which um which
provides uh um Newcastle with
$38,000 per student per year in New
Hampshire Public taxpayer dollars not
local new Newcastle property taxes but
New Hampshire New Hampshire um uh tax
dollars so so you know when when when
New Hampshire is funding Newcastle
$38,000 a year um that certainly could
have uh could could reflect in higher
than average significantly higher than
average per pupil cost in terms of how
they go about operating their um their
their uh Public
Schools quick notifications yes I
appreciate the context you provided do
you have any thoughts over whether again
this is intended to say that all costs
incurred by the schools should counter
the adequate and if not how would the
General Court decide what's necessary
for an adequate education and what is
the part the schools just go above and
beyond based on the desires of their
local cons so so so going through the
new language starting on line 13 and
going through um through line 17 um it
it's saying that the necessary specific
resource elements shall include doesn't
have to be limited to but they shall
include these and so anything that's not
articulated uh here in this bill um I
don't believe the uh the state would
have to consider those costs as part of
um an adequate education this came
strictly from the uh the convel court
order thank
you other questions
representative
Cen thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question how would you
consider um that we equalize these
numbers from District to District as
we're looking at this from a state
perspective uh what I mean by that is
what let's say snow plowing and sanding
for example if one district is paying on
a per incident basis versus another
District that's paying a flat rate um
throughout the season how do we equalize
those yeah no that's a that's a great
question and I think that that that goes
right to
the right to one of the flaws I think in
a one-size fits-all type of funding
formula do you average them all together
do you take the maximum do you take the
low the low one I mean the the
transportation costs on a per pupil
bases are going to be higher in karge
than they are in hopkington you know I I
don't know how I'm not looking at the
numbers but I couldn't imagine it being
the uh being the other way around so do
you go with hopkinson's um uh small
school district single School single
Town School District do you go with that
for transportation cost per people or do
you go with cure sges these are these
are the challenges some of the
challenges you have in a one siiz
fits-all flat funding uh model and and
as the chair was saying once we get into
uh work sessions I think we'll be able
to look at at at other funding
approaches that I think can get right at
um what you're what you're talking about
your your question is
spoton representative
MCU thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question so
this bill has one of the scariest fiscal
notes I've ever seen $450 million a year
more I rounded it to five fine
um but it doesn't say where that money
comes from do you have any ideas where
we could find that kind
of that amount of money well you know
it's interesting you say that because uh
because we are I'm not I'm not saying we
need to spend as a state not as let me
say a different one Allin I'm not saying
we need to spend more on our on our
Public Schools uh I'm just saying the
funding needs to be coming from a
different uh um a different pot and so
the money is already being there it's
coming from local property taxpayers so
we're already paying for it I'm just
simply s or this bill is just simply
suggesting that that and the court is
simply suggesting that the state pick up
a larger share of money we're already um
we're already raising as to your as to
the the where I can certainly think of
of some areas but I also think that's
that's something that um that maybe
we'll talk about in a work group but
it's certainly an important uh
discussion when uh when bills like this
or when whatever the product is from
this committee um gets over to
finance yes thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my followup so I'm sort
of hearing you
say it'll still come from property taxes
and and what I what no no you're not
hearing me say that we what I want to be
really clear what um what what what I'm
saying is that is that local property
taxes are already being raised to pay
this um uh this amount and that the
state needs to look for for State
revenues in order to um uh to do
that I I would suggest that this is a
perfect illustration of what I mean by
waiting for the rest of the package of
bills to come with us because the
mechanism of how that comes whether it's
incremental funding or whether it's a
substitution funding I think that's very
much what we're going to be
exploring yes represent fellas thank you
so one of the things I notice when I
look at this is there are two sections
to this bill and one of them is amending
a 198 bill um 198 RSA and the other one
is amending uh 193 so these are two very
different parts of our
laws one there're two two different
parts yeah they're two I mean they're on
the this piece of paper they're right
beside each other but they're really in
two very different parts so in in that
case when I look read the second part I
don't necessarily connect it with the
first part so is do you agree that when
we look at the elements that doesn't
mean that these elements have to be
turned into a per pupil amount that
there could be other ways to to um look
at the cost of these elements and put it
in some kind of Aid formula yeah so so
thank you for the the the question
representative fellows the um you know
the non-bold type under section two uh
is existing law so the general court
shall use the determin the definition of
the opportunity for an adequate
education in 193 e2a and so that's the
laundry list of items of um of um of uh
the the the required program elements
that every school must offer not that
every student must take but that every
every school must offer in its um in its
program of studies and um and the
specific section here in Roman 1 um uh
of3 e2b Roman 1 talks about how you go
about costing out those elements and
it's not just it you know it's not not
just teaching of history or teaching of
math or teaching of social studies or
teaching of science um it it
it it was clear from the from the conval
order that that far more goes into it
than just the delivery of instruction
and so so you know everything from
principles and administrative assistance
and school C I mean I'm just reading
from from what's in here which is uh
which is taken directly from the uh the
conval it's not taken as a paragraph in
the conval order it goes through each
each block that that discussed um these
resource elements and how they together
built up to the um
$735 base
amount thank
you are there further questions of
represent
luno represent LUN I have one I just
walked in but uh uh 193
e2a is the area we've talked about so
many many times before and it's those
areas where we identify the substantive
criteria for an adequate education and
list those 11 areas of study MH you've
Incorporated areas here Beyond those 11
areas are you now driving at the fact
that you're now going to consider these
areas components of an adequate
education so so so thank you very much
what I there were no this bill makes no
changes to the um the the definition of
the opportunity for an adequate
education as defined in 193 e2a what
what you just talked about Mr chair are
the the um the substantive components of
a of a program that offers and to offer
the opportunity for an adequate
education this makes no changes to those
substantive areas but it does make a
change in terms of how you go about
calculating the cost to deliver the
deliver a program that contains those
substantive contact UM substantive
content U areas and that that those
costs aren't just you know what I was
saying ear it isn't just the instruction
of um you know of of you know science or
math or or Ela
but it's all the things that are
included in providing that uh that
instruction in a um in a in a public
school environment and so uh library
media specialist actually I think we
have that in the um in the calculation
it's not in the law anyway anywhere but
it's in the calculation of the um of the
U of of of how a base cost is calculated
but uh but things like technology
administrators custodians Nurse Services
instruction materials um facility
operation and maintenance those those
have not been part of that uh that
spreadsheet calculation again which is
not in law so so uh so these changes are
not not to change the content of a uh of
the opportunity for an educate of an the
content of the opportunity for an
adequate education only to how you cost
out that opportunity
I'm noticing within the litany right
here not the litany but the list of
inputs that one of those areas is not
currently a result of the estherbrook
study back in
2008 and that is Nurses that's listed as
an optional area elsewhere in statute
but the other components are part of and
are built into that initial formula I'm
just wondering why did you then take one
item and put it in here uh because it
was included in the that's part of the
conell
order so th this is this is complete in
terms of um uh of um synthesizing the
conell order into our current um one
siiz fits-all um education funding model
thank you further questions from repon
Luna or
for thank you very much I'll take
questions anytime so back here all right
I'm sure thank you very much Mr CH thank
you represent Howard
thank you honorable Mr chair and
committee members uh my name is
representative Heath Howard I represent
the towns of straford and barington in
straford District 4 over the past 30
years the state of New Hampshire has
failed to meet its constitutional
obligations by funding each student's
education to an adequate level we just
had another ruling handed down in the
conal case as representative luno had
stated uh that states that schools need
a conservative $110,000 per student
minimum last year the house passed HB
1583 but the Senate moved to send that
legislation interim study HB 550 is even
more conservative than what was
introduced with HB
1583 and is still less than what was
suggested we should be funding education
uh adequacy to in the convo case
I understand we are seeing serious
budgetary constraints and revenues are
significantly down but we have
situations like in my town of straford
where half of the teachers are lacking
accreditation I've asked the
administration why and they've said it's
difficult to recruit teachers at the pay
they
offer we are offering starting teachers
people with four-year degrees about
$40,000 less than what they could get
working any other average job that
requires the same education level it
doesn't make economic sense for people
to take jobs at my town school and it
shows both of my towns uh both the towns
in my district have become poaching
grounds for other schools looking to get
teachers at a discount and unfortunately
my school knows the end result of what
happens when you defund a school a
little over 10 years ago straford school
was the number one k through school in
the state now it's in the bottom 25%
knocking on doors in my town I know a
lot of people who moved to straford
because of the education
system and there are a lot of them that
are very very upset schools like
straford will continue to be inefficient
and underperform if they are underfunded
and understaffed teachers will continue
to look elsewhere for better pay so that
they can put food on their family's
table and educational outcomes will
continue to decline un less start doing
more like passing
hp550 thank you so much for your time
and I'm open to any
questions thank you very much
yes yeah representative papovich thank
you Mr chair and thank you
representative for testifying and
answering questions you mentioned that
um the pay offered in stat for is about
40K less than what other jobs requiring
a similar degrees as somebody who's
negoti Union contracts teachers union
contracts before I I would like to
understand is that number based on the
anti- level wages on the average pay for
the teachers in the district is it pay
at the maximum step level which of those
numbers was used that's entry thank you
yeah no problem further
questions not seeing it thank you very
much thank you so much for your time I'd
like to call Donna
magon put her down next she's she's my
district
yeah oh God lucky
you good
afternoon my name is donon I'm
superintendent Newport School
District
sorry so good afternoon I'm Donna magon
I'm the superintendent of the Newport
School
District education is the foundation of
opportunity yet today our ability to
provide an adequate education is being
severely challenged as a superintendent
responsible for 700 151 students I
firsthand see the struggles our district
faces due to Staffing shortages and
increased student needs we are currently
down 14 teaching staff that's just
teachers that does not include our par
Educators or any other Staffing in our
building out of and 27 of our 83
teachers are on an alternative plan this
means that a significant portion of our
educators are not fully certified and
they their assigned roles that may
impact the quality and the consistency
of
instruction Beyond Staffing nearly half
of our student body 327 students require
an individual education plan with uh
with 29% on an IEP and 15% on a 504 plan
these students deserve special
instructions additional resources and
trained professionals to meet their
learning needs
additionally we have 16 students
learning English as a second language
each requiring tailored support to
succeed these numbers underscore the
growing complexity of our classroom and
the increasing demands placed on our
already strained
Educators an adequate education which
includes school funding is not just a
goal it's a necessity without enough
funding qualified teachers our students
do not receive the attention and the
instruction they deserve the long-term
consequences of an inadequate education
are severe impacting graduation rates
future employment opportunities and the
economical strengths of our community I
normally do not beg but I'm here today
to beg you to do the right thing for our
children they are not just numbers on a
report or figures in a budget they are
the future of our community and they
deserve better we we must prioritize
investment in education by recruiting
and retaining qualified Educators
providing the necessary resources and
support our diverse learning needs and
ensuring that every student regardless
of their ability background or language
has access to a quality education our
students are our future and without
immediate action we risk failing them at
a crucial time in their development I
urge you as decision makers to recognize
that educ ation is not an expense it's
an investment when we fail to provide an
adequate education we fail our students
our families and the future of our
society it's time to act I ask you to
please support House Bill 550 which
seeks to raise the state space adequacy
fund thank you so
much thank you very much questions
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman and you may rule me out of
order because it's not exactly on topic
but you mentioned a I'm new and you
mentioned a 504 plan what is that so a
five so an IEP which is an individual
okay education plan that is for special
ed so students have to have um need have
special education needs a 504 would be
something that qualifies them for
something that's not necessarily A
specialized plan so it could it could be
a student that may has may have ADHD
that cannot sit in one place at one time
they may need to go to another room to
do testing so it's things such as that
so it is um an alternative type of
learning let me explain for you a little
bit more um when I was a school
principal in another state we had a
student that was in a car accident and
broke both legs and was immobile for
over well over 3 to four months and the
504 was able to take care of
the education which was brought to that
child at home the child was immobile in
bed and so the parent or teacher
depending upon the needs of the IEP also
a special ed of the IEP were brought
there so it was a double dip and it
could have been without the IP they
would have gotten the 504 service
anyways because that's federal
law represent papovich question thank
you yes um two very short questions if I
may one of them is in regards to your
ESL student you mentioned them and I'm
you know obviously they you do need to
incur additional expenses can I ask on
average if you have how long does it
take from the moment they enter as ESL
students till they stop requiring
services for ESL ballpark I know every
kid is different but yeah so that's what
I was going to say it depends upon when
they come in right so if a student is an
ESL ESL student and they come in in the
Elementary grades the younger grades
it's easier to um to to help assist them
with their educational needs if they're
in the middle school or high school it
becomes longterm so I would say an
elementary student could be anywhere
from 2 to four years whereas a middle
school or a high school student could be
longer and just to give you an example
last year we had
five yeah and a quick second
question separate question but I had
both when you say we should do the right
thing for our students one of the
earlier speakers was saying they're not
necessarily looking for additional
funding they're just looking to change
the mechanisms used what would be in
your opinion the right thing for our
students in terms of the level of
funding that you are receiving overall
total funding are you talking the total
amount correct total funding for your
school district so so personally I would
like to see the $10,000 per student but
I would not want that funding to come
from the taxpayers because it's already
causing a huge burden on our families in
Newport cuz our taxes are already high
and so an example would be this year
we're in budget season my budget
basically was Hardy denied um and we
were asked to level fund it because we
just they could not afford any more on
their tax rate So currently I'm going
into my budget with minus a penny for
both my default and my budget because
the the ability to pay is not there for
our Newport families just to make sure
understood you correctly you would like
to see some additional funding but
ideally not from the local property
taxes I just want to make sure I
understood you that is absolutely
correct just to give you an example too
that a lot of my teachers actually
qualify for low-income
housing okay representa
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
being here superintendent nice to see my
neighboring
town you partially answered my question
with your last statement in regards to
some or many of your staff qualifying
for low-income housing which we barely
have could you give us some comparison
and and round numbers is fine of what
Newport is able to pay their staff
compared to school districts within say
a 20 mile radius that you compete
with absolutely So currently Newport
starting salary is roughly $34,000 a
year um and that is for teacher coming
out of college first year with a with a
bachelor's degree um I've had this year
about seven or eight teachers turned
down that position because they could go
to our neighboring town and make $88,000
more which is about 5 minutes and that's
just right down the street um our other
neighboring town is almost $10,000 more
so it's and if you go out further right
it goes higher so yeah so we are we're
facing that struggle that's why we're
we're I mean here we are in you know
going towards the end of the school year
and we're still down 14 teachers right
that's really impacting our our
level followup
yes in related to that could you just
share what the turnover rate for your
teaching staff is in a given
representative
Year yes so as um earlier uh it was
mentioned Newport is considered a
training ground so when we have we
approximately have between 45 to 50% of
our staff turnover every
year could you repeat sorry could you
just repeat the number about 40 45 to
50% of our staff so an example would be
I probably have about currently although
I have 14 teaching positions I probably
have about 35
positions throughout my district
represent
M thank you Mr chairman it um thank you
for working in an often thankless job
can you give me an idea of the cost the
average cost per student right now
currently in your District how much you
spend from the taxpayers money and then
can you average in the total cost
special that included all the special
high cost prices that you have to pay
just the both together well what I can
tell you is that um I just recently did
a present presentation for our for our
school district and um last year it was
$27,000 to educate a student in our
district roughly we get 4,200 from the
state and then um we do get more for we
do get some for Education reimbursement
but we get about 4,200 from the
state representative spillsbury
yes thank you you and I have had a
number of conversations on this subject
so I'm very familiar with the
unfortunate statistics regarding
vacancies
turnover um and uh the alternative uh
Arrangements but leaving aside the
question of where the money is going to
come
from what would you need to do in the
Newport School District to stem the tide
and stabilize the Recruitment and
Retention
problem so of course um it it comes down
to salary right because we have um our
staff like I said is and some of our
staff is in the as receives low-income
housing we do have some staff that are
living in low-income housing currently
so I think it would be stabilizing by
being able to provide an adequate amount
for our staff in order to keep them it
ends up costing us more money because
every year so could you ballpark
quantify that of how much it would be I
yeah so I would say our starting pay
would probably need to need to be about
45 to$
46,000 and we're at
34 now we do have you know we are asking
our district to fund because we're in
contracts right now but that has to pass
through our district and the funding a
majority of that funding has to come
from the taxpayers right so we're
worried and so one of the things that we
we're worried about currently is that if
that does not pass that um contract does
not pass we're going to have mass
massive teachers leaving our district
and where does that leave Newport right
because we're required by law to educate
our students but what do we do we
already have class sizes at 25 per
student because we've had we've lost
students now I also want you to keep in
mind that I mean back back in the day
when I was a classroom teacher like a
100 years ago you know I could have 25
or 20 students in my class but they also
had other classrooms that were
self-contained for students that had
behavioral issues or other issues that
is no longer the case all of our
students are together right and I've
often heard well they it's less money if
they go to you know a a u parochial
school or a private school but I also
want people to keep in mind we have to
keep our students I can't say to a
parent I'm sorry your kids misbehaving
today so they can no longer come to the
Newport School District where those
schools can so I think that is the big
the big thing that people really need to
look at that we're required by law to
educate every student that lives in
Newport further
questions yes representative fellow I'm
just wondering if you can tell us
something about are your teachers
certified in the in the subjects that
they're teaching or CU so as I stated
earlier I I have approximately 27 out of
83 teachers that are are not certified
in the areas of which they teach they
are what they're on alternative plan so
they have a plan in place that at the
end of the three years they will have
their certification but I can tell you
exactly what's going to happen at the
end of the three years they're going to
leave right so we're putting all this
money and time into getting them
certified for them to leave to go
someplace else where they're going to
make moreone
Mone yes rent cran thank
you um I just did you say the student to
teacher ratio was 25 in some cases yes
is it more can it is it more in some
instances yes thank
you I I'd like just follow up with with
a question see we just talked about the
pupil teacher ratio of 25 to1 uh is that
the year what's happening in the class
the state funds K through 2 at 25 to1
and three through 12 at 30 to1 that's
the state
share um if you put in your other staff
members music PE Library Etc that are
certified Personnel or working on that
alert um what what is the that ratio
come down to in terms of uh is it 20 5
to1 or does it shrink down to where we
are as an average for the state which is
much
lower so are you talking about if I put
them in the classroom when the teacher
is teaching well when we when we fund we
fund based upon the pupil teacher ratios
based upon classroom teachers classroom
teachers but also music teachers PE
teachers
Librarians counselors all that so it
would be exactly the same because what
ends up happening is under contract our
teachers have a time period where they
can prep and prepare for the for the
students right during that time their
students are in PE library music so it
it's the same group of students that are
going with those teachers so it's it
would still be the 25 to
one okay you know
I let's because where I'm trying to go
at is I'm looking at the in this bill
$735 is what we're looking at at that
base cost
correct in order to get the pupil
teacher ratio where you need to
get we need to move some money around
within that
formula and to do
that if we move it all to the leftand
side we're going to be putting a whole
lot more money in some of the towns
which I'll use the word donor we have
some towns are going to be
receiving that much and their adequacy
is needs are down here so how best can
we work on this form do you have any
ideas how to adjust the monies because
the state's not very supportive of an
income tax or a sales tax correct well I
think that for me to to
make a guess on how to do it wouldn't be
fair because I don't know the whole
budget process right I probably could
say things that like an example would be
and I know other departments would
probably not be happy with me but if we
don't educate our students where do they
end up they end up in our our jails so
maybe if we look at taking some of our
money and putting it to our students
when they're younger then we can
eliminate some of the problems that we
have when they get older right so I
think it's a matter of looking at the
funding and where all the funding is
being spent and I don't have all the
numbers in front of me so it wouldn't
necessar it wouldn't be fair for me to
say well take from here or take from
here if I had you know the opportunity I
would love to join the committee when
they're talking about it you know and
have some input with that having my you
know boots on the ground and being able
to to to talk about thank you very much
thank you further questions of the
superintendent thank you for coming
today thank you very much and again I'm
always available if anybody has any
questions thank you Deborah house
okay this is back on good afternoon
members of the House Education funding
committee good afternoon chairman lad uh
my name is tor how I am president of the
American Federation of teachers New
Hampshire and I am happy to be here
today to address you on House Bill 550
um we are in favor of the Big Ideas
expressed in this bill I understand
there are some other bills coming
forward on education funding so I will
not uh State an opinion on how they will
work together I will leave that up to
the committee as they come forward but
certainly um we are in favor of better
State support for all of our Granite
State students to access their public
education is the New Hampshire
constitutional right that all Grand
State children should get a robust
public education one that um prepares
them for Workforce career service
further studies and po civic
participation in their communities and
as we've just heard described very
ay that opportunity does not exist
equally everywhere in our state because
the funding from the state is extremely
low and the ability for local property
taxpayers to make up the difference
varies so much from Community to
community so in Newport they can only
make up so much and in places like
Newcastle they have abundance so um
increasing base adequacy to
73561 will go a long way to help meet
students needs uh to have actual lower
class sizes and give better individual
attention um from teacher
par Educators support staff so that
students can have both the academic
support and the academic challenges they
need because there are students who need
one students who need another and some
students who need both
um also changing that definition to
increase to include more of the real
world costs of providing education so
that you're including all of the
teachers and Educators the various um
administr ative assistance the
nursing uh staff which is very necessary
in our schools today because there are
so many kids who come in with medical
needs who need them taken care of during
the day and maintaining the school
facility on a day like today you cannot
argue that heat is optional or a luxury
um and also by the way in early fall and
late spring cooling because um it's very
hard to get kids to pay attention and
learn if they are melting um but those
ca are part of an adequate education the
state does need to pay more of a share
so that every single student in the
grand state has the opportunity for the
same kind of great public education
because we really are looking at doing
the right thing by all of our New
Hampshire citizens so they all get the
same great start and I will leave it
there because there are people here who
can speak more aily on the financial
aspects of this um than I do and we just
heard so wonderfully from a local
superintendent so um I will close there
thank you thank you very much Deborah
are there questions from the
committee not see thank you very much
and you will have this in your email
thank you Mark Magna
Nell from
doe good afternoon mark manganello from
the Bureau of school Finance uh
Department of Education I'm here for
technical assistance if you have any
questions are there any questions that
we have for Mark right
now yes represent spillsbury
thank you Mr chair so the bill
includes um in lines 17 and 18 the
general court shall update the cost of
inadequate education at least every two
years the fiscal note addresses the more
or less half billion dollar cost but uh
do you have any sense of what that might
suggest to us going forward in say the
next half dozen
years no that would be indeterminable it
would be based on the work the general
court performs
um uh I can't I made no predictions on
that but that's a a good thing to point
out indeterminable is a good answer
representative fellows yes thank you um
in the past six years have you modified
the doe 2 to now have school level
information
um that's uh that's correct we've added
a school level reporting to the
doe2 um we've been collecting it since
2019 can just can can you follow yeah
can you just describe what it looks like
is it the same all the same lines that
that we used to see for the whole
District but at the school level or is
it a smaller set of
information it it's slowly been growing
um uh the requirement to have a school
level cost per pupil was in Essa um
which is a federal law that has
reporting requirements for uh uh school
districts and so um those requirements
um at a minimum have cost per people
that parses out state and local funding
in one bucket and then also Federal
money in another bucket so that's sort
of the Bare Bones reporting um but uh
the US Department of Education has been
expanding the reporting requirements at
the school level so it's been going on
um it's been looking more like what you
would see on a doe2 including
instructional um 1100 series Etc um so
whatever the U used requires of us uh we
build into a supplemental uh uh
reporting requirement outside the do25 I
representative fellow probably only
knows this cuz she worked on this for
for so long um and so it's slowly it's
slowly going down the path of starting
to look like a
doe2 yes um Can Can we ask doe to
provide us with some reports are that
are along this addressing when we get
into when we we're receiving a number of
bills dealing with the Budget Building
catastrophic a this we will be sending a
report to them where we're looking for
information so I think you need to start
building your list I'm building a list
also and rather than having individual
submitt it'll come from us at one time
we need all this information to wait
through the tasks ahead of
us uh Mark I have a question for you
here line 1819 of the bill says the
general court shall use evidence from
actual costs
from all approved schools to determine
the cost of an adequate education so
we're looking at the actual cost for an
adequate
education are you using the doe 24 that
represent fellows just reference to find
out what these actual costs are and is
that Doe then an accurate way to
determine components which are the
adequate education
um good get to your question um uh just
want to say all of our doe 25s are
online um on the department's website we
have 2019 through 2023 we'll have 2024
on there shortly so if you ever want to
do your own homework you can pull
do25 uh by dist all districts and
Charter Schools um just want to if
anyone wants to uh read a doe2 you can
see it on our website I think uh
chairman lad that statement would depend
on how the general Court wants to
complete its task here so I knew you're
going to say that so so some of the data
collection tools we have the doe2 is a
data collection tool um the d25 just um
I think we talked about it during
orientation it is the financial
essentially a financial report that
districts provide to us um as they're
closing out their year um it's due by
September 1st a lot of very few
districts can achieve that September 1st
uh Benchmark um we typically don't get
it in and report it all out to you in in
the form of our end of year reports
until January um that because some
districts take the whole fall um into
some of the winter months to complete
the
doe2 um so that is um uh one data
collection Point um we can also just
survey the schools um so to get
information about the do25 wouldn't have
information about teacher salaries um
some of the information discussed here
uh the the cost of a uh the actual cost
of a custodian would not be in the do25
the doe2 has rolled up data um it has
instruction salaries um uh student
Support Services um in salaries um but
it won't get into the exact position um
that's in that accounting function so um
do25 would probably be a tool that the
general court would use but potentially
surveys and other tools would be
used thank you very
much uh representive Burton thank you Mr
chairman I want to wander r sacred
territory
um when I filed a bill to free New
Market from
theirs several years ago in a past
actually was overturned the committee
report I had warned them of overhead
costs they were going to have to have
their own sped Ed director their own
Deputy
superintendent um oer River shed two
sounds uh the next year my question to
you is we never talk about overhead
um the SAU structure in New Hampshire
was not designed to be economical it's
political and I'm just wondering if doe
has looked in any way and this is going
to learn me theity of all my colleagues
has anyone looked at an economic way to
reorganize secondary education in New
Hampshire so it would be less expensive
at the overhead level so we'd have more
money at the instructional level so I've
not seen the analysis you're discussing
um and the department has not done that
analysis um the only analysis we have
done is we'll analyze uh from time to
time analyze administrative cost you can
analyze it um you can kind of get two
views to look at it you can look at it
as a percentage of total expenditures um
so a lot of local budget committees are
doing that type of of work to see if it
how much is it eating up of your total
expenditures is it a big section or a
small section so um uh we have data on
that um and then also you can look at it
as a cost per p basis and so we've done
analysis on that but nothing nothing to
the analysis you're
describing yes represent
ccom thank you Mr chair thank you Mark
for taking my question on the
conversation of the MS 25s as we're
looking at them online um and we see the
various funds that they have going
across are the school
districts um responsible for reporting
all funds that they are making entries
in and out of um especially if they're
coming out of the general fund and going
into a different fund are they
responsible for reporting all of those
funds to
you um generally I I I think I would
always refer back to the accounting
handbook so the accounting handbook
establishes what was in the scope of the
reporting that is required for the
doe2 um but generally speaking if it's a
school educational expense uh an
educational expense I would expect to
see it on the doe2 if it's general fund
expense I would expect to see it on the
doe2 um could there be functions that a
school performs that is outside that
educational realm um and is not reported
on the
doe2 there could be an example but I I
would expect them to all be on the
doe2 thank you reent
bricky thanks um thank you very much
thank you um Mark is so I I think I hear
what you're saying so all of these I
don't know if you've seen the new the
new language of the bill but um the
necessary specific resource elements and
there's a whole there's a whole list of
them
Transportation so if I'm hearing you on
the doe2 transportation is not included
it is included on the doe2 it is not
included in the cost per pupil
measurement okay all right so I was
messing those up thanks so is that the
same with like instructional
materials uh yes so we would have on the
do25 and and um uh uh go ahead and study
for yourself but you can see that we
have um instruction is function code
1100 so we've all oh you you've sign um
you've signed off on a few sign a couple
sign a couple um uh uh function code
1100 is all instruction level and um
then we have it broken up by uh salaries
benefits and then purchase services so
if you're purch in uh supplies Etc um so
if you're buying supplies like
instructional materials the the cost
would live in the doe 25 but could you
actually drill in and say this
particular book or this particular very
difficult to do well we can't do it the
do25 the districts could do it okay
thanks thank you very much represent
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
helping us with
this do you have an observation on why
transportation costs are not included in
the per people cost cost um so every
time I've poked into the question of you
know why do we do cost for people this
way I I I I've talked to my
predecessors um it relates one the
answer I've been given is this is the
way we've always done it which is the
answer everyone hates to hear
um to some extent the way it's always
been done is nice in a sense it allows a
consistent methodology for you to look
at the cost PR people in 19 you know 99
and compare with now so you know dealing
controlling for inflation Etc
um I can speculate is transportation is
not included because District it's some
people use the cost per pupil as their
tuition agreement and essentially a
district would say yes you can come to
our school you can even pay the nhs's
cost per pupil rate but you bring the
you you send the students you pay for
the transportation essentially so that's
probably why it's not included because
some districts like to use it as a
tuition agreement and they want have
transportation separate um a separate
separate
negotiation a followup yes thank
you can you make any um
observation about how that current
structure of not including
Transportation costs in per pupil
cost complicates comparing between
districts since say a widespread
Cooperative District probably has a much
greater Transportation cost per people
than a compact geographically compact
District yeah when you go through the
exercise of analyzing Transportation
cost per people you do see a lot of
varying you see some well into the I
think maybe there's one out there that's
maybe 5,000 um per student um but the
averag is kind of hovers around a
thousand so and then some are well below
that average and some are well above uh
above that average but you know as soon
as you add that as soon as you add that
in to the state average probably a, is
dollar impact but it would depend
very unique for certain
districts uh represent papovich then
represented
fellows the
what on Transportation there's a lot
more to Transportation you can even look
at the inputs and find uh a small amount
I believe it's right around $350 per
pupil hidden in there in the inputs
developed by Senator esterbrook back in
the the reason on our reports it's
separated out to transportation is
separated out because sometimes you want
to look at just instruction what does
the instruction cost and the
transportation the other thing about the
transportation is that in rural
districts is obviously going to be
higher in Manchester they use the you
know the public transportation so that's
why they're separated and it's been like
that for decades
represent papovich thank you Mr chair
and thank you Mr mangara for taking
questions I know that you brought this
up at an earlier presentation this year
that there is a significant value to
having the longitudinal data and the
ability to look at it historically but
if that were not a consideration said
that you'd maintain the longitudinal
data but then you'd also have an
enhanced version of a cper you know to
educate a people report are there any
other changes the department may want to
make in order to better reflect the
overall cost changes that you that you
know the doe may find appropriate again
living out the value of the longitudinal
stuff um um so we' we've thought about
changing the format of our report um um
changing it it's been it's been the same
format also for SE multiple decade so um
I think the challenge with was having
multiple competing cost per people
metrics out there
is the uh it could create confusion so
uh I I would I would if we do an
analysis I always almost want it to be
separate and like almost isolated from
the regular metrics we're always
producing on a consistent basis um but
as far as ad hoc analysis and Reporting
if there's any request of this committee
um we could look into what we're capable
of doing um and showing different looks
at Cost PR people than the one that
everyone sees um as far as our routine
reporting I like it to be as simple as
possible to avoid confusion but if
there's any analysis requests from the
committee we can work on
that the last question to you Mark is
that if I look at my do25 form and I
take out tuition and
transportation and I'm trying to
determine what those expenses are for an
adequate education is the rest that Doe
going to reflect that or they're going
to be some decisions made locally that
push their expenses out further that are
being beyond what the state identifies
as an adequate
education so it it depends on the
methodology if your methodology was to
take the all the
doe2 and take all expenditure data in
there um uh and uh and come up with our
state cost per people number and call
that an adequate education uh uh the
critique would be that included in that
doe2 is all expenditures and therefore
um some expenditures that are not above
and beyond the minimum standards above
and beyond the Constitutional adequate
education so when the doe2 has all
expenditures on it um so if that's your
methodology the doe2 is limited and how
it can get to a maybe more precise
measurement of what is the cost of
inadequate education um and then if
you're doing uh uh some of the exercises
you've seen uh potentially in this bill
and some of the exercises you saw back
in 2008 um the due2 wouldn't have that
data thank you um all right um we have
other people want to testify here today
so can we let Mark off the
hook yes have a good
afternoon uh Jessica wheeler Russell
Andy hello um thank you very much for
letting me speak today um my name is
Jessica Willer Russell I'm a resident of
Penacook and um I also am a mother of
two children who are behind me um and I
serve on the marac Valley School Board I
am here though to represent myself and
not the board as a whole um I did send
an email this morning but I'd like to
kind of
uh reaffirm it so I uh as I wrote this
morning I'm here to express my strong
support for House Bill 550 which seeks
to address the urgent need to increase
education funding in New Hampshire this
bill is a vital first step to ensuring
that all students regardless of their
zip code have access to the Quality
education they deserve House Bill 550
establishes a framework to periodically
review and adjust funding levels
addressing the stagnation that has
historically hindered education funding
in the past by laying the foundation for
for a more Equitable and sustainable
system the bill represents progress
furthermore it allocates critical
resources for essential elements such as
facilities like heating our buildings
and transportation which are
indispensable for the effective
operation of our schools as a parent in
my district and as someone who serves on
my local school board I witness
firsthand the profound impact that low
State education funding has in our
communities each year the primary cost
drivers special education Healthcare and
retirement funds all which are mandated
uh expenses consistently increase these
increases directly impact the funding uh
resources of school districts and due to
the state not providing adequate funding
for elements some of which are listed in
this bill uh it places an undue burden
on the local taxpayers especially in
those districts with lower property
resources it's the state's duty to fund
education adequately to ensure that
every student in our state has an
equitable access to resources needed to
reach their potential and Thrive which
in turn will help our state to thrive
education is a Cornerstone of a thriving
community and a robust economy investing
in our schools is not just an investment
in our children but in the future of our
state the bill is a start to help our
communities and I urge you to support uh
house Bell 550 to stand up for students
families and Educators who depend on
Fair and adequate funding the other
thing I did not put in the email that I
kind of want to uh point out is uh I
want to Echo a little bit of what the
superintendent from Newport was saying
about these are not just numbers on
paper these are our kids these are my my
children behind me one of which is a
recipient of special education um I
myself having grown up in New Hampshire
though I did leave for a time I returned
home um I also received special
education and I here as a participant in
um our communities I have a job and my
my family and I'm a success story and I
would like to see more success stories
available for our children who uh whose
school districts might not have the
resources uh thank you very much and I
can take some questions before I have to
run these kids home thank you very much
any questions from the
committee you're off the hook thank you
very much for coming
today with your
kids uh David
Trumble one
oops excuse
me good to be able to
see thank you Mr chairman my name is
David Trumble I'm from the town ofwar
and I support this bill um I'd like to
go back to the Constitutional element if
I
could the state has a duty to fund the
public schools in the state it has to
provide an adequate amount of funding
and the duty extends to the public
schools that's been clear in both the
Claremont and the London Dairy
decisions when the conal case started as
representative luno said it first was U
sent up to the Supreme Court who said
you need to do more work got sent back
back to the Superior Court they had the
3-we
trial conal based on 5 years worth of
data came up with the numbers all the
other school administrators who came to
the trial said we concur with conval's
numbers and the state offered no
evidence to the contrary that's
important because the number the 7356 is
not just a number derived from a list
it's a
constitutionally required dollar amount
and if the Supreme Court upholds this
conval decision the state is not going
to be confronted with having to increase
base adequacy from 4,000 roughly to7
$300 that's going to be a substantial
increase but it's constitutionally
required I imagine there will be many
attempts to knock it down but that won't
work because the the the judge in that
case said and the superintendent said
and they all agreed the number is really
10,000 and the judge took conservative
estimates on every single element in
that case so 7,300 is what we're going
to have to to live with in New Hampshire
that's the true Base number um then I
would like to also go on to the question
of what H what's this look like and I'd
like to focus on the property poort
towns if you go to 7,300 this will make
a profound difference in the lives of
tens of thousands of students you've
heard from Newport but there are many
other towns in this state that are in
the same situation as Newport that money
will go to teachers My Town had the same
problem after two or three years the
teachers all left because the prices we
were the contracts we were offering were
too low if you have too many
inexperienced teachers there aren't
enough experienced teachers in that
school to provide the mentorship for the
inexperienced teachers that means that
children are losing a lot of educational
gain that they're not going to get back
that has lifelong impacts on them 85% of
the children in the state go to a public
school we're talking about our future
economy our future Society our ability
to run a functioning democracy this is
not I know it's painful to come up with
this much money but it has to be done
for the good of the state the second
thing is programming you look at AP
courses some schools in the state only
offer three other schools offer 36 you
can't really say you're offering an
adequate education to high school
students if their school doesn't offer
them a full range of AP courses you also
can't offer an adequate education if you
don't have enough money to offer the
remedial courses the found foundational
courses kids who have having trouble
reading and trouble doing basic math in
the early years if you spend the money
in the early years and give them that
then the rest of their years in public
school will be successful if you'd say
oh we just couldn't afford it when they
were in elementary school they're still
going to be struggling in years behind
and basic skills as they go through the
remaining years the other thing is class
sizes all the studies are very clear
this is a very simple clear line you
have lower class sizes you always get
higher results it costs money to do
schools right we had this morning School
building Aid School building Aid better
better results the study show it lower
class sizes you get better results you
give foundational remedial programs you
get better results you have teachers who
are experienc you get better results it
costs money to run good schools but it's
an investment in the future of the state
so how does this work in the big picture
the low property value talents when you
give them this extra 3200 per student
they're going to spend it on their
schools because their schools
desperately need that money the the
property Rich towns they can take it and
use it for property tax reductions if
they want to but there but it's the
state's job to come up with the $7,300
assuming the Supreme Court upholds this
decision it's a
constitutionally required number and I
think that's the key thing that this
bill really gets the second half of it
is you can argue about what's little
included here and did you have nurses or
transportation and so forth but the key
thing is if you give 70 300 per you are
going to make a big difference in the
lives of tens of thousands of children
in the state and if you don't we're
going to be in the same situation 30
years for a whole another generation of
children in these towns go in a negative
spiral it is unfair to them and this is
the time for the state to step up and do
the right thing so thank
you other questions of Mr
Trumble not see thank you very much
you're welcome thank you I have no other
pink cards up here on HV 550
I've not seen it there is no other than
I got a packet here with nothing on
it well anyway fill one out
yeah you could ask if you want to go
back to him and
I mean as an individual you could go
back and ask them right now get that
information
yeah thank
you okay we're going to continue here
Zach uh Shen welcome thank
you uh thank you members of the
committee my name is Zach shien I'm the
executive director of the New Hampshire
school funding fairness project I'm here
in support of House Bill 550 uh we're a
nonprofit organization that educates
citizens and policy makers about the
system that we use to fund our Public
Schools the impact on property taxes and
trying to work towards solutions to uh
make both of those systems more
Equitable I'm going to skip around a
little bit to try not to repeat things
that have already been said um I will
point out that the um we've talked a lot
about the gap between what the state has
determined to be the cost of an adequate
educ
uh roughly $4,000 in change and the
actual per people expenditures which I a
part of House Bill 550 um up to about
$22,000 per student um a few more
numbers based on some of the testimony
heard earlier um from the superintendant
in Newport um Newport and cipe both have
per pupil expenditures of about $26,000
per student newport's education tax rate
including swept
$12.61 Sun's educ tax rate to provide
that same amount of per people
expenditures
$484 so there's pretty significant
impacts based on the ability of the
community and the property there to
raise that money and these inequities
exist explicitly because of the lack of
funding from the state which is a
constitutional
responsibility about 70% of all school
districts Revenue come from property
taxes local property taxes in the state
as the highest percentage highest share
of any school District uh school funding
system in the Country House 550 seeks to
address some of these inequities by
increasing this base adequacy cost and
to be clear from some of the questions
this is a shifting of who is paying this
the ruling is about shifting some of the
burden from the prop local property
taxpayers to the state not increasing
the size of the pie so to speak for the
total amount of public education dollars
being spent uh and I think that's an
important piece for example if we just
did a direct shift it reduce the burden
on local property taxpayers from 70% to
about 45% I understand there's a lot of
complicated mechanisms for where that
money is going to come
from uh also uh some of other additional
claims that have been made um not
specifically in this hearing today but
um out in the public are explicitly that
if the legislature is to follow the conv
Val ruling and consequenc
hp550 one of the results would be
reducing funding in other elements of
the education funding formula that are
not under adequacy to pay for that base
adequacy increase therefore harming some
of our most vulnerable communities by
reducing some of the so-called right
side of the formula that is blatantly
not true and would be an active decision
by the legislature to cut that funding
the ruof ruling has said nothing about
reducing funding in one bucket to pay
for an increase in base adequacy for the
share of the state the state what the
state's paying for the cost of
inadequate education I want to highlight
again that the state over five years uh
and millions of dollars of taxpayer
funding um paying out of state attorneys
during the comat lawsuit presented no
evidence to justify the current base
adequacy amount they presented
absolutely no evidence saying this is an
appropriate amount to provide an
adequate education for our students the
entire case hinged on just attacking the
numbers and the witnesses brought on by
the conval
district I'll conclude um by saying that
I think it is a really incredible
opportunity this session to have a new
committee specifically focused on
education funding they're going to be a
number of bills that might take pieces
of this you've heard them mentioned
before relative to education funding
there's a lot of bills in Ways and Means
are be talking about swept and kind of
the revenue side of things and I think
that what is really really uh critical
is that this committee does
something digs into this asks these
questions what is a cost of an adequate
educ ation how do we cost that out if
it's not Rua's number is it the
plaintiff's number if it's not those
what elements of it hp550 gives a really
good place to build from in terms of
what specific elements are required or
should be required to provide an
adequate
education I'll um stop there and I'm
happy to answer any questions thank you
very much are there any questions from
the
committee
yes thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question
you mentioned uh in your testimony that
newport's tax rate is $12 in change per
um resident per thousand whatever uh and
that ctie was $4 if we are to increase
this adequacy Aid per student how is
that going to fix their tax disparity I
mean it's going to lower it for both
sides right because they're both getting
that additional money so how is that
going to fix that tax disparity that
you're referring to that's a really good
question so with that example I was
trying to show that both school
districts and it's probably not a
perfect example it's one I can pull up
on my phone real quick both school
districts are spending roughly the same
amount per pupil but to do that Newport
has to and this is just their education
tax rate not their full tax burden has
to have a tax rate like three times as
high and so if the state were to provide
more of that funding that would give
both those communities at the local
level the the P uh um more funding to
have that debate what are we going to do
maybe for Newport through their
budgeting process and and engagement
with their local school district maybe
they lower their tax rates with half
that increase and then are able to
increase their salaries for their
teachers but that's a decision to be
made at the local level so I can't say
exactly what each Community will do
because every Community through their
own process will have a different
different priorities but it'll give
Newport the ability to make that
decision whereas right now due to the
fact that they have such low property
values on average and so much of the
funding comes from property values
they're boxed in they don't they don't
have wiggle room like like some
communities do to say do we want to um
maintain taxes this year or do we want
to increase salaries they're just saying
we got to just survive here so
additional funding it will vary
Community to community based on what
they'd want to do um which I think is
really important that communities have
that ability to say what do we want to
do at the local level do we want to
build a new school do we want to
increase um teacher salaries do we want
to reduce property taxes but it would
give a lot more communities the the
ability to actually have those
conversations whereas right now many
don't because the margins are so thin
and the taxes are already so
high further questions yes
representative fellows um yes so so
you've been talking about how the tax
rates are very different between two
districts so I'm pretty sure if I went
and I looked at the average home value
of the of the average home value in each
of those two districts those would be
drastically different too so I pretty
sure that in Newport they they've got a
high tax rate but their typical home is
valued a lot lower than the typical home
in sunap would you not think that might
be how it would look I agree and I think
that that is exactly the the Crux of
this entire issue the reason that that
statement is true and I agree with that
and the reason that that is problematic
is because the state provides so little
funding for our Public Schools the
smallest share in the entire country
comes from the state for our Public
Schools system because of that fact and
we have to rely so heavily on local
property taxes 70% of all the revenue
then the impacts of differing property
values in different communities becomes
this this huge weight in terms of the
the local tax rates so it's it's
precisely because of that Dynamic um
where a town because they happen to not
have a lake or happen to not have a ski
Mount or coastline and therefore have
lower property values or a former
miltown that that you know decades ago
right had High property values and now
they don't because they get so little
from the state then it creates these
huge swings in their tax
rates further questions from the
committee not seeing thank you very much
thank you and with that we do not have
any other pink cards up here so we're
going to close this hearing on
550 a you can follow up by individually
with him he's right
there yeah let me know
we're
done okay we open up more questions now
and it goes and goes and goes it
does I'm not going to open it for second
round of
question for